[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
good morning
do we have any preliminary matters we
have some exhibits oh that would be
fantastic that'll make jamie's day
all right we're ready for the jury
then okay
all right
good morning ladies and gentlemen have a
seat
all right your next witness
your honor amber calls dr richard moore
all right dr moore
all right yes sir good morning dr moore
good morning can you please tell the
jury your full name uh richard salter
moore jr
where do you work uh emerge ortho in
wilmington north carolina
and what is your position there
i'm a shareholder physician orthopedic
surgeon practicing hand up extremity
microvascular surgery
for how many years have you been an
orthopedic surgeon
so i completed my
fellowship in 1997.
so for 25 years
and i believe that you mention this but
tell the jury
what
area of orthopedic surgery in which you
specialize so so i'm a uh orthopedic
surgeon i finished medical school went
to a five-year orthopedic surgery
residency at the completion of my
residency i wanted to specialize in hand
surgery so
i did an additional year of training
specifically in hand and upper extremity
surgery
before starting practice in my first
year as a as an attendee
where are you currently licensed north
carolina
for how long have you been licensed
since 1990
one or six
i think it was 1996 when i was licensed
in north carolina
beginning with your undergraduate
studies dr moore could you please tell
the jury
a bit about your educational background
i know you mentioned a little bit of it
just now so i uh attended university of
north carolina at chapel hill i
graduated in 1987 with a bs in biology i
went on to medical school at unc and i
graduated in 1991.
i then went to the hospital university
of pennsylvania in philadelphia
and did a five-year orthopedic surgery
residency there and in 1996 i went to
duke university medical center and did a
year fellowship and hand up extremely
microvascular surgery
and and on completion of my fellowship i
was invited to join the faculty
and my role was was
hand and trauma and so i went to los
angeles for about six months for a
preceptorship in pelvic trauma
and then went back to duke and uh
practiced
as a director of the orthopedic trauma
service and a member of the hand upper
extremity and microvascular
reconstruction team until
2000 when i relocated in north carolina
to wilmington
and you maintained an active clinical
practice since
2000
and before that when you were duke
correct
yes
just very briefly can you tell the jury
what is a residency
residency is
largely an apprenticeship so when when
you finish medical school you have a md
medical degree but you really
can't practice medicine
and you take a tract of internal
medicine or pediatrics or ob gyn or
orthopedics and then
it's a graduated training program
anywhere from three to five or six years
and what's a fellowship
and a fellowship is a year beyond
training when i completed my residency
had i chose to i could have practiced as
a general orthopedic surgeon
but i wanted to specialize and therefore
that required an additional year
training
and i believe you mentioned this but
your sub specialization was in the hand
is that right that's correct why did you
choose to specialize in the hand
patient population
uh the types of problems we treat uh the
and the anatomy is really the biggest
reason i chose it
um
i mean for lack of a better term it's
really pretty beautiful anatomy
and let's talk about that anatomy
there's there's bones in the hand right
correct and then there's tissue and
blood vessels right objection leading
overruled
i'm sorry you can go ahead and answer
that yep that's correct and what what is
the surgery um
called where you operate on tissues and
blood vessels in the hand
uh
well um
that that would be hand surgery i mean
there are different components of it
there's there's trauma where we do
repairs of tendons or blood vessels
there's a microvascular element where we
repair injured nerves um
in in my practice at duke i was on the
replant team and so we would we would do
replantations when digits were cut off
we would
try to reattach the bones and tendons
and nerves and vessels to
to
reattach the digits
and hopefully i'll survive
and have you performed surgeries of that
nature yes
when you perform surgeries of that
nature what assessment do you make of
the cause of those injuries
so so cause is a is a big element it's a
it's a uh it's an uh an important um
element to appreciate because it can
impact management in a lot of those
settings you know there's a there's a
difference between a laceration caused
by a razor blade
and a laceration called by say a
serrated knife there's a larger zone of
injury so what we anticipate having to
manage is
is based on
on
how the injury was created
there's also other elements
contamination you know farm farm yard
injuries are totally different than
clean injuries and kitchen injuries with
raw chicken are totally different than
than
some other other settings and so it does
play a large role in in management
after your fellowship at duke university
i believe you mentioned you had another
role at duke for a few years is that
right can you tell the jury about that
so i did my fellowship and i joined the
faculty as an assistant professor and uh
so i was in charge of teaching residents
and fellows i was the director of the
orthopedic trauma service
and i
was on the hand
call team
in addition
have you had
academic appointments at any
universities other than duke
i have a
adjunct
assistant
professor
appointment at the university of north
carolina at chapel hill which is
has affiliated training programs in the
center where i practice now
have you held any leadership positions
in your field
i've been the uh
an officer and the past president of the
north carolina society surge of the hand
the duke hand club or society now
um
i'm a member of the american society
surgery the hand of the orthopedic
trauma association of the american
academy of orthopedic surgery and of the
american orthopedic association aoa
are the majority of your surgeries hand
surgeries yes
how many hand surgeries
ballpark would you say you've performed
in your career
over 25 years
thousands
have you seen finger injuries
similar to the ones sustained by mr depp
in australia yes
and have you evaluated injuries like
that yes have you treated injuries like
that
yes have you operated on fingers that
looked like that
yes
how many times
hundreds if not
if not more
what does it mean to be board certified
in your field so uh board certification
is a process that um
that you pursue after you complete
training so at the time there have been
some changes but at the time that i
finished my training
after residency we took a written
examination and if you pass the written
examination you had to practice for two
years at the end of that two years you
submitted a list of cases over six
months to the board and they picked
12 cases and then you gathered up 10
and went to chicago and uh and had an
oral examination based on those cases
um and if you passed the world
examination you were board certified
and your board certification is is in
what
orthopedic surgery
d what is a certificate of added
qualification
so in the in
in the event that you elect to
to do a fellowship and sub-specialize
hand surgery is one of the
specialties that
you can
apply for a certificate of added
qualification and so
once i was board certified i practiced
for an additional year or two had to
resubmit a list of cases and take a
written examination to become certified
in hand surgery
do you teach other surgeons how to do
hand surgery
occasionally on occasion yes when was
the last time you did so
uh
day before yesterday
tell the jury about that
i was
over the weekend i went to
miami to
serve as faculty for a course a
bioskills course we call it on shoulder
and wrist surgery and
surgeons come in and we have case
presentations and panels and then
they had a
cadaver lab and we were able to to
allow them to perform the surgery and
cadavers to become familiar with the
equipment
have you published in your field
i have
in peer-reviewed literature
yes
your honor at this time um
we'd like to offer dr moore as an expert
in the field of orthopedic surgery and
specifically hand surgery and injuries
to the hand all right any objection no
objection so moved yes sir
dr moore
now we we get to talk about this case um
at our request
what have you reviewed just
general categories of information have
you reviewed at our request in this case
so uh
so a tremendous amount of material um
i reviewed the video deposition and and
uh trial testimony of mr depp regarding
the injury um the medical records from
australia the photographs of the injury
from australia and los angeles
texts and emails the deposition of dr
kipper
and i'm sure there's more
and when you review the deposition of mr
depp was that just in paper form it was
a video deposition and so what did you
review of that deposition uh the section
where he describes the injury and did
you see a video of him describing it i
did and you you watched the testimony
from this trial of him describing it yes
and you mentioned that you reviewed some
texts as well what are those
uh
there were there were mult there were
communications amongst um
mr depp and his
physician and and and others
and and what
did you specifically review in those
texts relating to the finger injury well
with the release of the finger there was
a there was a text where he had stated
he cut his finger off
now dr moore i'm going to ask you some
questions about this case regarding the
opinions that you formed
relating to mr depp's finger injury
when i ask you those questions do you
agree to answer my questions to a
reasonable degree of medical probability
yes and do you agree to advise the jury
and the court if you are not answering
any of them to a reasonable degree of
medical probability yes
dr moore based on your analysis did mr
depp's finger injury happen as a result
of a vodka bottle being thrown at him
objection bleeding
overall
i'm sorry
no
and what is the basis for that opinion
well the the
medical data is inconclusive
it's uh not consistent with what we see
in the in the described injury pattern
or in the uh the clinical photographs
and there are there are several elements
there's there's uh you know the
description was of the hand being flat
on a bar and the and the bottle crushing
the finger from the top
but
looking at the images there's really no
no significant injury to the dorsum of
the finger and to create the type of
injury with that with that uh
type of a crush injury we would
anticipate
both injury to the fingernail um and
other parts of the finger
um
okay can i can i stop you there and just
just break down a few things
um you said the hand resting flat on the
bar can you show the jury what direction
the hand was resting based on the
documents you've reviewed i think that
the demonstration was was with the hand
flat
like this um
across and maybe even curled over the
edge of the of the bar like this which
side was facing upward which side of the
back of the hand or that we call the
dorsal surface of the hand was up
if you could get closer to the
microphone
sorry thank you
thank you your honor
so you referred to the back of the hand
as the dorsal side of the hand is that's
correct sort of like a dorsal fin on a
shark
correct there
and
what is the other side of the hand
called the palmer surface palmer okay
so what direction was mr depp's hand
resting on the bar so the dorsal side
was up
which with the descriptive
of injury or the injury the bottle would
have struck the top of the finger at the
fingernail
and you also mentioned a term that i'd
like you to explain to the jury crush
injury please
so so the
with review of of the images and the
x-rays i mean this this was a crush
injury
that's the that would generate the
findings clinically on x-ray that we saw
um the fracture is is a um we call it
comminuted and the and the tip of the
finger is in multiple splinters so there
are multiple fragments and typically you
see that with a with a crush type injury
so a common neuted fracture is one where
there's multiple fragments of bone
that's
correct and
what was the basis other than
what you've read and heard but from the
from the pictures what was the basis um
of your opinion that the
the hand was resting palmer side down
well that was that was the way the the
injury was described
and demonstrated in the videos and so
um in that position where the bottle to
strike the finger the way it was
described it would have it would have
struck on the nail
and and
and the nail was really
not injured and and so that's not
consistent with with that pattern of
injury
michelle could i get you to pull up
exhibit
dx369 page 26
your honor this is admitted
ask for permission to publish
yes sir
thank you your honor
dr moore is this
one of the images that you reviewed yes
what tell us in relation to your expert
opinion on the cause of mr depp's injury
tell us what you see in this picture
please
so so this is a um
it looks like an avulsion type injury
where tissues actually pulled or pinched
away
i think what's important in this picture
is that the tissue loss is
on the palmer aspect from underneath the
finger rather than
then all
transversely in the finger which you
would anticipate if the if the bottle
struck the finger you would expect more
of this this level of injury rather than
isolated to the palmer aspect
and what do you notice about the
condition of the fingernail in this
picture so so from this image the
fingernail appears to be intact
you can't necessarily see the entire
nail but
there there are other images that have a
better uh uh profile of that
um and and the nail is not elevated it's
not there's no um subungal hematoma
beneath it or there's no bruise
underneath anyone that's ever stuck
their finger in a drawer or caught it in
a car door or hit with a hammer knows
that almost immediately there's
typically
bleeding underneath the nail which
creates this hematoma
so
not being a doctor i'm going to try to
to
summarize what you just said are you
saying that in an injury like this
if
something had come from the top that
there would be an immediate impact to
the fingernail bed that's correct
michelle could you please pull up
plaintiff's exhibit 144
your honor this has been admitted as
well
all right
thank you
dr moore i believe you mentioned just a
few minutes ago that there were other
pictures that showed
more of the nail
is this one of those pictures yes
and
explain to the jury
again and i'm sorry for the the graphic
nature of this photo but it's important
that the jury understands the basis for
your opinion
that a bottle couldn't have caused this
coming in from above
yeah so it's so it's
it again the mechanism described would
have
almost certainly led to a severe nail
injury you know i see no subungua
hematoma again it's it's a palmer tissue
loss and the loss is from distal to
proximal which is in which is from the
tip
back far below the nail and so for it to
create
that tissue loss down there there would
almost certainly have to be injury
dorsally with that described mechanism
so what you're saying is that something
coming from the top could not have left
the nail intact and yet caused injury
from the tip of the finger underneath
the nail objection leading
over
you can answer so so uh so i believe
that um
with the mechanism described that if the
if the bottle struck the nail there
would have certainly been an injury to
the nail bed
and in order for the for the
soft tissue
injury to be created by that mechanism
there would have almost certainly been
tissue loss on the top of the finger as
well
does mr depp's description of what
happened line up with the undisputed
photographic evidence that you've
reviewed
no
now we mentioned the term crush injury a
few minutes ago
um
i'd like to show you
dx360 please
and your honor this is um
we won't publish this at this time
um did are these is this a document that
you reviewed in connection with your
expert opinion in this case
yes
and
um
michelle if you can please go to pages i
believe they're five and six you're on
i'd ask for permission to publish these
as a demonstrative
to the jury just page five and um sorry
uh sorry um
oh nine and ten
page two pages
could you go to ten also so clean if you
can see it okay any objection to oh no
objection okay oh 9010 can be
published
dr moore are the what are these pictures
of
so these are x-rays of the injured digit
and what do you observe in these x-rays
so the jury um
what you see
so these are these are
two views so one in the plane looking
through the finger in this direction one
of the plane looking through the finger
sideways and you can see that the the
tuft or the the tip of the
finger
the last bone in the finger called the
distal phalanx is shattered you can see
there's multiple little spicules of bone
and there's also a transverse fracture
at that level
which runs through the bone
so this is this is what we would
describe as a comedy to fracture and
it's commonly associated with crush
injury
in your decades of practice dr moore
have you ever seen a comminuted fracture
like this
result from an object thrown in the way
that mr depp described
well
not in not with the constellation of
findings shown on the x-rays i mean i
think
that could create a fracture but in the
in this setting it wouldn't create a
fracture with the asso without the
associated
um other injuries that we would
anticipate
and in your decades of practice when you
see a common neuted fracture like this
what are some things that have typically
caused it
so crush mechanisms could be
slammed in a drawer caught between two
logs and in the fireplace
car door
um uh sliding glass door those are all
any mechanism that
that squeezes the finger between two
hard opposing surfaces could create this
type injury
in the
statements of mr depth that you reviewed
how did he describe what happened to the
alleged bottle when it hit the bar
i believe um
he said it exploded
chattered if
a bottle had exploded
near his finger
in the way that he alleges what would
you expect to see in the documents that
you have reviewed
uh well i i think that that the
physicians did a good job of documenting
the presentation the appearance of the
wound
they did not document the presence of
any glass yards
um
and there were no other associated
injuries elsewhere on the hand
and
i just want to step back for one minute
michelle can you pull up the next page
of the x-ray here
um
thank you
and dr moore just before we move on from
x-rays um can you i know this when it's
blown up like this it's a little bit
blurry but can you point out
or describe the jury where the where the
multiple bone fragments are in the
finger um so they're in the very tip
you know the
if you see the joint and then there's
the
what we call the transverse fracture
which is across the the
middle of the bone in the in the same
plane as the joint and then the multiple
fragments are in the tuft
um
and and the with a xerox copy the
quality is not as detailed as a true
x-ray
you can take that down please michelle
thank you
so so back to to to the glass in the
records that you reviewed dr moore did
you see
any
adjacent injuries in other words
injuries to any other part of mr depp's
hand other than the tip of his middle
finger no
and
is that observation consistent with the
explosion of glass type phenomenon that
mr depp alleges
well i think in the setting of an of a
glass explosion like that where there's
multiple fragments the tip of the
fingers cut off you would you would
anticipate that there would be other
lacerations did you review the
documentation in the medical records
from the hospital in australia yes
did any of those providers report
retrieving glass from the wound no
what about any glass near the site of
the injury
no
what about any glass in other parts of
the hand
no what about any glass in any of the
other fingers
no
is there any reference at all dr moore
that you've seen to any glass in the
records that you've reviewed
no
and dr maury in your decades of practice
have you ever seen an injury associated
with a glass explosion that was focused
on the end of a single finger in the way
mr depp describes
when not consistent with the with the
clinical images and the findings in this
case no
have you ever seen an injury associated
with an alleged glass explosion where no
other glass was found on any part of the
patient's body or clothing or anything
no
and because there's been talk of a glass
explosion um dr moore there's there's
seems to have been a suggestion that
somehow glass may have sliced off the
end of mr depp's finger is that what's
going on here
this wound doesn't
really appear to be a sharp glass
laceration you referred earlier to an
avulsion
um which is a term i had never heard
before your opinion in this case explain
to the jury what that is so so often
with crush injuries and and um and
we'll see uh tissue loss that we call an
avulsion or uh where the the tissue is
actually um
pinched or or
pulled away uh rather than then sliced
or cut
and and it's not uncommon with crush
injuries to see that
in your decades of practice dr moore
have you ever seen an avulsion injury
with a partial amputation that results
from
an object thrown
from the top of the finger
and the way that mr depp describes
no again i think that the description
differs from the clinical appearance on
the images
michelle can you please pull up exhibit
369 at page 12.
this has been admitted your honor
all right you publish to the jury
dr moore you've you said you've treated
thousands of hand injuries over the
course of your career correct correct
um what is that on mr depp's hand
so we we'd describe that as an objection
culture speculation
the picture just changed sorry page 12
please
okay
thank you thank you
what is that on mr depp's hand so that's
a that's a plaster splint overall okay
sorry thank you
i'm sorry please tell the jury what that
is on mr depp's hand uh so that's a
that's a plaster splint um a half a cast
is is how i sometimes describe to
patients and
it provides stability uh for comfort and
to protect fractures in the course of
treatment is that plaster splint hard or
soft
uh what's plaster paris it's it's uh it
hardens like a cast does
dr moore um
does mr depp's description of how his
finger became injured line up with the
facts that you've seen
no
i have no further questions thank you dr
moore cross examination
good morning dr moore good morning
you said you reviewed mr depp's video
deposition is that correct that's
correct and you said you reviewed mr
depp's testimony at this trial correct
that's correct
and was that also a video of his
testimony yes and you testified that mr
depp demonstrated that his hand was flat
on a surface is that correct that's
correct
that's not entirely accurate is it
though
no his his description was relatively uh
consistent in both um
including turning and resting the hand
on the on the edge
isn't it true dr moore that when mr depp
did the demonstration in his deposition
he showed that his fingers were hanging
over the bar
well
even hanging over the bar it still
leaves the
dorsum of the hand or the nail
vulnerable that's not my question dr
moore my question is isn't it true
that mr depp said his fingers were not
laying flat on a table they were hanging
over the bar
yes okay and in fact you knew that
when you made that opinion isn't that
correct
well
i believe that i uh as i demonstrated
sitting here that i said that you it
said they were slightly or slightly
curled over i think
was the description that i gave
your description in this courtroom was
that it was laying flat and i think
you've done that now twice but in your
deposition you testified that his
fingers were actually hanging over the
bar isn't that correct objection your
honor misstates the witnesses testimony
he clearly indicated they were curled it
could have been overruled
so that's a so so that's a distinction
that that perhaps i um
misstated in one of the two descriptions
however
that does not substantially change my
opinion of the impact it would have on
the mechanism
isn't it true that mr depp also
testified that the bottle came from an
off angle
yes okay and you consider that in
rendering your opinions today correct
yes i believe he stated that uh it came
from between six and ten feet uh i think
it was off to i think he demonstrated
was off to his right i can't recall
specifically but
it was off angle yes okay so it didn't
come from the top as you previously
testified just a few minutes ago correct
well no it would have struck the the
top of the finger but it may have been
slightly off angle in its approach based
on the description
mr depp described it as off angle
correct
correct
dr moore just at the outset your billing
rate for providing deposition
testimonies a thousand dollars per hour
that's correct all right and you were
deposed in this action for several hours
on march 22 2022 that's correct and your
billing rate for providing trial
testimony is five thousand dollars per
day that's correct
you were retained in this case by ms
heard's legal team correct correct
and over the last few years you've
provided expert services for one of ms
heard's law firms on at least two other
cases right
that's correct yes
dr moore is it fair to say that you have
no personal knowledge as to how mr depp
injured his finger in australia correct
no i have no personal knowledge my my
impression is based on his uh his
description of the injury and the
available medical records for review
but you weren't in australia with mr
daphne has heard crime i was
and so therefore you have no personal
knowledge as to how that injury was
sustained
correct all right
you also never personally examined mr
dapp's finger did you
correct
you didn't examine mr depp's finger at
the time he was injured
i did not and you never provided any
medical treatment to mr death in
connection with this finger injury did
you i did not
now you've testified that you identified
mr duff's finger injury as a crush
injury correct correct and a crush
injury is when a body part is crushed or
trapped between two opposing firm
surfaces yes yes
and a crush injury to a finger can occur
when a foreign object
hits the finger
right
yes
and uh based on the pictures that you
reviewed of mr duff's finger injury you
cannot determine what particular object
caused the injury to his finger yes
well i i can't
i can't determine exactly what what
object did it i think that um i can i
can
say
with confidence that the described
mechanism of the bottle hitting and
shattering the finger
was not consistent with the appearance
of the injury my question is just very
specific you can't determine the object
that caused the injury to mr depp's
finger what's it's a little bit more of
a
non-specific answer i mean i you know
again i i can't determine the exact
object but i can determine that that
it's unlikely that it was
sustained in the manner described
a bottle is a foreign object isn't it
yes okay
so you can't rule out that the injury to
mr duff's finger was caused by a vodka
bottle correct
well based on the injury pattern i can
say that the described mechanism of
injury is inconsistent with medical
findings right
but because a vodka bottle is a foreign
object you can't rule out
that a vodka bottle is what caused mr
depp's injury
well i i can't rule out that a vodka
bottle caused the injury but i can rule
out that it was caused in the manner
described in his testimony
you can't rule out the injury was caused
by a knife right
i think it's unlikely that the injury
was caused by a knife but you can't rule
it out
well if a simple knife laceration
wouldn't impart the energy to the distal
phalanx to result in
the comedy fracture
now a a chopping type
but again that would likely come from a
direction that would that would create a
dorsal
injury to create the fracture that was
developed do you remember giving
testimony in this case dr moore
deposition yes yes okay and you were
under oath correct correct all right
and that was on march 22 2022 yes
correct okay
may i approach your honor yes ma'am
thank you
dr gourmet please have you go to page
163
of your deposition
specifically line 17.
163
actually apologies 164.
line four
question but you can't rule it out
completely right answer i can't rule
anything out completely i can't rule out
that he caught it in the door cut it
with a knife or slammed it in the car
door or again as dr gilmer said we can't
definitively say what caused this injury
did i read that correctly you did
your honor i would object as the
incomplete impeachment i think if she's
going to read his answer she also needs
to read or give dr moore the chance to
read the paragraph below
she just picked out half of his answer
you can redirect us yeah
dr moore there's no question pending
thank you though
so you can't rule out the injury was
caused by a car door either is that
right
correct
but it's your testimony sitting here
today that you can rule out that the
injury was caused by a vodka bottle is
that your testimony
my testimony is that i can
rule out the injury
as caused by the mechanism described by
mr depp in his deposition
but you can't definitively say what
caused the injury to mr duff's finger
well the definitive injury was a crush
injury um but i but
again i i
i can't say i mean i think it's i think
that that it's
quite likely that the initial
uh
mechanism described at the time of
presentation of the accordion doors
would would classically create this
injury pattern you know the hand up in
front if you picture accordion doors as
the end as the
edges close if the hands up the palm is
exposed if the door is pushed dr moore
closes about
but my question is i think it's
important that they understand that this
is the time for me to ask you questions
your counsel will have the ability to
rehabilitate you and ask you questions
on redirect right now
let's try my question okay you can't
definitively say what caused the injury
to mr depp's fingers yes or no
no okay
in conducting your analysis of mr duff's
finger injury you did not attempt to
reconstruct the incident is that right
well i think the the incident was
reconstructed do you mean i throw a
vodka bottle at something
no you're no dr moore i mean you didn't
do any type of accident reconstruction
either computerized or any you didn't
conduct any type of accident
reconstruction of the elections that's
correct my opinion is based on the
medical records and the clinical images
and mr depp's description and and your
analysis is based on an understanding of
how mr depp described the exact
positioning of his finger at the time of
the injury yes
yes okay and your analysis is also based
on the assumption that mr depp's hand
remained completely still in the
instance that a vodka bottle was hurled
at him yes
no my assessment is on his description
of the
bottle striking the top of his finger
but his hand stayed still according to
your analysis yes
i guess it was still long enough for the
bottle to hit it but natural reaction
would be to try to pull away
when you perform traumatic finger
surgeries you inquire about the cause of
the injuries correct correct
and your best information on that is
typically just the self report of the
patient yes
correct and your assumption is that the
patient is trying to get care
because the patient is trying to get
care that person that patient is
generally telling the truth right
you would hope so yeah you reviewed dr
kipper's deposition testimony informing
your opinion about mr duck's finger
injury correct correct
informing your opinion did you consider
dr kipper's deposition testimony that
while dr kipper was providing emergency
treatment
okay
so
let's start over
because it's important the jury hears
this so informing your opinion did you
consider dr kipper's deposition
testimony that while dr kipper was
providing emergency treatment for mr
depp's finger injury in australia in the
driveway of the house mr depp told him
that his finger was injured when miss
heard threw a vodka bottle at him
uh i i don't
but i don't recall that from the
deposition i'd be happy to review if you
have the deposition
available
did you consider dr kipper's testimony
that he recalled that mr duff's finger
was found in the kitchen
i do recall that
so you must have also seen dr kipper's
deposition testimony that he wasn't the
one who actually found the finger
correct
that's correct
dr kipper testified that someone he
thought was the chef told him he found
the finger in the kitchen area correct
uh
i'm gonna assume so without reading the
deposition now
did you review uh any testimony from ben
king in rendering your opinions today
uh not to my knowledge no did you see
any of mr king's testimony at this trial
i did not okay so you're not aware that
mr king testified that he is the one who
found mr duff's finger are you
no
and you're not aware that mr king
testified that he found mr dapp's finger
in the bar area
right
correct
and you're not aware that mr king
testified he found mr depp's finger in a
piece of tissue in the bar area either
no
and you're not aware that mr king
testified that multiple broken liquor
bottles were also found in the bar area
right
correct if we could please pull up
defendants exhibit
1817 which is already in evidence
and it may be published please
i just don't have it yet
that would help yes
i just have a blank screen at the mall
there we go
there we go okay
have you ever seen this picture before
dr moore no
so you're not aware that this is the bar
area where mr king testified he found mr
depp's finger
no
okay do you see that broken vodka bottle
in the back corner near the bottom of
the bar
yes
okay
do you see the blood drops on the floor
yes
can we please pull up defendants exhibit
one eight two zero which is already in
evidence
have you seen this picture before dr
moore
i'm not so you're not aware that this is
also a picture from the bar area where
mr king testified he found mr duff's
finger
correct
do you see the bloody tissue on the
ground at the bottom of the bar
yes
do you see the blood drops around that
tissue
yes
so you didn't consider any of this
evidence and rendering your opinion
about how mr depp injured his finger in
australia did you
i did not
nothing further your honor thank you
redirect
yes sir
can you pull up um exhibit 1817 that was
just shown to the witness please
and can you um
blow up that what what miss vasquez
referred to as a broken vodka bottle
michelle please
dr moore what what based on your review
of the documents in this case what did
you understand to be the size of the
bottle of vodka that mr depp alleged
cut off his finger the description was
that it was a uh
a handle a half gallon bottle
and that's bigger than a 750 ml or fifth
of liquor correct yes
and what size bottle if to the extent
that's even a bottle what size does that
appear to be to you calls for
speculation your honor i'll sustain the
objection does that appear to be a
handle
objection calls for speculation
objection
you can take that down
um dr moore miss vasquez just just um
asked you about dr kipper's deposition
testimony
um and she said is that uh
where where she claims that mr depp
allegedly told him that the finger was
severed from a vodka bottle do you
remember that question a few minutes ago
objection leading
over
i didn't remember that question yes
thank you is that consistent that
alleged account is that consistent with
the texts you the texts you reviewed
between mr depp and dr kipper
no and what did those texts say
as i recall
mr depp indicated that he had cut his
finger off
now miss vasquez wouldn't let you finish
when you were trying to explain to the
jury
um
how
mr depp's account of injuring his finger
in an accordion door would be perfectly
consistent with the photographs you saw
could you please explain that to the
jury
well well so
again uh we tend to to try to believe
patients we hope that they come in with
an honest history initially and and
that's a reasonable mechanism for this
to have occurred
and again if you picture your hand up
with a with either a closure of a hinge
or closure of the door the palmer
surface is exposed if it's caught in
that hinge as it closes it could be it
could be slightly off-center it would
pinch that tissue away in a similar
fashion but because it's below the level
of nail bed it could create this injury
with the fracture of the tissue loss
and preserve the nail bed
can you look at page 164 of your
deposition the one that miss vasquez
just showed you
yes objection your honor i'm going to
object on here say grounds
your honor sheep only
thank you
miss vasquez asked you a question and
then she read your answer trying to
impeach you but she only read half of
the answer so i'm gonna read the whole
answer to the jury and i'm gonna ask you
to tell me if i'm reading your answer
right okay
the the question is on page 164 line
four but you can't rule it out
completely right
and you answered i can't rule anything
out completely i can't rule out that he
caught it in the door cut it with a
knife or slammed it in the car door or
again as dr gilmore said we can't
definitively say what caused this injury
and then you go on to say this is where
miss vasquez cut you off and didn't let
you finish
what i i don't think that's in the
transcript objection
i'll sustain that the rest of the rest
of your answer
that she didn't read to you dr moore is
what i the question i can answer is is
that the mechanism that was described by
mr depp and demonstrated by mr depp is
inconsistent with the injury pattern
that's found on the images and the
description
did i read that right yes
and does that remain your opinion today
yes has anything that's been presented
to you on cross-examination changed any
of the opinions that you hold in this
case no
i have nothing further thank you dr
moore thank you all right dr moore
you're free to go or you can stay in the
courtroom it's up to you all right thank
you all right your next witness your
honor we'd
like to call dr david spiegel dr spiegel
all right that's fine yes sir
so
yes
thank you all right
the doctor can be sworn
thank your honor
will you please tell the jury your full
name and business address
david
r spiegel i'm a physician
i work at 825 fairfax avenue in norfolk
virginia
as part of the eastern virginia medical
school
and what is your occupation
i'm a physician psychiatrist
and and where do you work do you work it
i work at eastern virginia i'm employed
by eastern virginia medical school but i
also work at uh norfolk general hospital
which is the teaching hospital in
norfolk
how many years have you been practicing
as a psychiatrist
i entered residency in 1989.
i graduated rednzy in 1993
so from 1993 to today
i've been
in uh
physician practicing
so that's almost that's 30 years yeah
thank you
please describe for the jury the nature
of your clinical practice
so my clinical practice is comprised of
both inpatient care at norfolk general
hospital as well as my outpatient
practice at eastern virginia medical
school
about
85 to 90 percent of my day
is clinical between
the two components
and what is involved in a comprehensive
evaluation
so in a comprehensive evaluation
in addition to reviewing historical
information that you receive from
collateral other sources
you undertake a history from the patient
you get whether it's the history of
current illness the past psychiatric
history
family history social history
legal substance history
then you do what's called a mental
status exam
which is the psychiatric version of the
physical exam they're actually giving a
description of what you see in front of
you
then you can do cognitive testing
which tests the patient memory attention
concentration
etc
then you come up with a working and a
differential diagnosis
describe any other additional testing
you may need or not need
and then you come up with a treatment
plan
how many patients have you treated over
the 30 years
uh
quite a lot
probably in the tens of thousands
and how many patients do you regularly
see
so
inpatient
is generally about five to eight
sometimes more
outpatients probably five to six
sometimes more
i should point out that my inpatient
work is divided between uh consultation
psychiatrically we're going to talk
about that as well as working on the
inpatient service so we'll talk about
that
um what if any differences are there and
how many patients you see on weekends as
opposed to weekdays so when i'm on call
which is uh on either a saturday or
sunday meeting i have to be in the
hospital and around that's probably
additional 35 plus
how frequently do you treat patients who
abuse drugs and alcohol
unfortunately drugs and alcohol are part
of psychiatric practice
uh and so
probably three-fourths of my patients
have substance abuse problems
does this include both legal and illegal
drugs yes
put them both together probably 75
and how frequently do you treat patients
who have suffered from someone in their
lives who abuses alcohol and drugs
on a regular basis like i said on a
daily basis this is part of what
psychiatry is
okay and as part of that treatment of
patients who abuse drugs and alcohol do
you evaluate the impact of the abuse on
their brains and personal interactions
with others
yes
substance of abuse
both in the short term and the long term
can affect the brain in terms of mood
behavior
cognition meaning
attention concentration memory ability
to control your behavior as well as your
overall level of functioning it can
affect it in the short term
such as alcoholic blackouts it can
affect it by causing strokes such as
stimulants can
and so at the end of the day
it's a rather lengthy
list of what substance abuse can do to
the human
brain
dr spiegel how frequently have you
treated patients who have suffered
intimate partner violence
again it's very unfortunate that
probably 50 percent of my patients
suffer from trauma
if i had a guess of those 50 percent
probably 25 percent of my practice is
people who have suffered uh intimate
partner violence
and how consistent is that with the
national average
in america unfortunately uh it's about
20 to 25 percent depending on the study
of uh
women have complained that
reported uh
intimate partner violence
and how frequently have you treated
patients who have perpetrated the
intimate partner violence
so again in the outpatient setting i
don't see it quite as much but in the
inpatient setting again it's a really
relative uh common phenomenon that we'll
see uh perpetrators of it partner
violence
and
you know their patients who need
treatment too
and overall how many patients have you
treated who have been perpetrators of
intimate partner violence
perpetrators yes uh probably five to ten
percent of the patients i do as in
perpetrators
and would you say uh tens of thousands
over the 30 years
yes in leading
overall thank you as part of treating
patients relating to intimate partner
violence do you regularly evaluate these
patients
do i regularly value the patient
evaluate the patients oh yes yes regular
i mean they get the same comprehensive
evaluation
that i described before
are you licensed in virginia yes i am
and when did you first become licensed
in virginia
1993
have you been qualified by courts as an
expert witness
yes i have in how many states have you
been qualified as an expert
three which would be virginia
maryland and south carolina okay
dr spigel can you please review for the
jury your educational background
beginning with your undergraduate
studies
so
i went to duke university undergrad
i went to medical school at the state
university of new york health science
center in brooklyn formerly known as
down state medical center
i did my internship and residency
between dartmouth hitchcock medical
center and penn state hershey medical
center
and
i'm also fellowship
board certified in consultation on
psychiatry okay
and uh
did you so where did you do your
residency and your internships so i did
my residency for penn state and
internship at dartmouth
okay and what is your current title and
position
so i am in the acting chair
uh endowed chair and professor
in the department of psychiatry
behavioral sciences at eastern virginia
medical school
are you board certified yes i am and
what are you board certified in
general adult psychiatry and
consultation ways on psychiatry as a
sub-specialty
okay so you have two board
certifications okay can you explain to
the jury what's involved in board
certifications in those two fields
so board certification is the standard
we strive to
in uh being a physician or any other uh
mental health practitioner
it involves
taking a very comprehensive
test at the beginning of your career to
initiate board certification then you
get tested
again every 10 years
then you have to go through continual
medical education uh throughout
the entire period
you have to do what's called performance
and practice which is basically ways to
improve
things
in your practice
and again this is throughout this occurs
always throughout the years
now are you a member of any professional
organizations
yes i am
a member of the american psychiatric
association
as well as the fellow of the american
psychiatric association
i'm a member of the medical society of
virginia
a member of the
psychiatric side of virginia i'm a
member of the tidewater academy of
psychiatry and i'm a member of the
academy consultation liaison psychiatry
do you have any teaching
responsibilities
teaching responsibility teaching so yes
so teaching is a daily occurrence as
part of my job when i'm in when i do my
inpatient rounds uh residents
medical students physician assistant
students are assigned so we round
together and there's teaching with every
single encounter
uh in addition to that i teach lectures
to the residents
to the
uh third second and first year medical
students
as well as a fourth year medical student
lecture as well
so i'm constantly teaching
have you engaged in any hands-on
training of psychiatrists practicing in
virginia
hands-on training with the residents
with psychiatrists oh yeah so again uh
i'm
teaching at bedside i mean we don't
speak in front of the patient obviously
but i'm teaching at bedside meeting
after we see a patient we discuss uh
important points to to learn and again
that includes residents at every level
that includes medical students third
second and first year physician decision
students so
every day is a teaching explanation
session to the students in residence
what is your role at eastern virginia
medical school as the acting chair
please tell the jury what that means
so as the acting chair you are not only
accountable for your own practice but
you are accountable for your faculty
members practices so i have to make sure
that everyone is treating
seeing evaluating a a certain number of
patients i have responsible for their
academic requirements so in terms of
publishing et cetera i'm responsible for
their uh
teaching assignments to other residents
to other students i'm responsible for
fiscally that they are
accountable to their uh fiscal
productivity
so and a heck of a lot of other
administrative uh meetings that i go to
okay
have you published in your field
uh to the tune of about 80 manuscripts
and i have my own book on catatonia in a
consultation liaison setting i have a
book chapter in on the uh
current and uh tribal con current and
contemporary approaches
temporomandibular disease at least the
psychiatric portion i'm also in a
dissociative identity disorders chapter
on a uh a
wikibook
and have you peer reviewed literature
yes so i'm a i'm a reviewer on i've
served as a viewer on uh
lancet i've served a viewer as uh
innovations in uh clinical neuroscience
i've served on a reviewer for clinical
neuropharmacology and i'm actually
editor-in-chief
of at this point of clinical
neuropharmacology
have you lectured on the effects of
drugs and alcohol on the human brain
yes i teach to the residents i teach a
lecture to the second year medical
students
a third year medical students so i am
fully aware of
not only what i teach but what i see in
the emergency room and the consultation
in patient settings
have you published and lectured on the
causes and effects of intimate partner
abuse yes i punctured i believe two
articles on the effects of trauma and in
that trauma was intimate partner
violence
are you familiar with the hallmarks of
intimate partner violence
yes
are you familiar with what causes
intimate partner violence one more
what causes intimate partner violence
because yes there's a multiple
explanation that caused intimate partner
violence and i kind of just mentioned at
this point too that
when we are discussing intimate partner
violence i think it's imperative for the
jury to know we are talking about
repetitive
behavior over periods of time
and the type of abuse can be any
physical psychological
sexual
but just as important is for somebody
one of the partners to maintain
some uneven element of control
or to maintain
power control or authority so there are
a lot of facets to intimate partner
violence i know people tend to think of
as just the actual
abuse act
but there is more to it than just the
actual abuse act because that's
important but it's not the cell phone
your honor i'd move to qualify dr
spiegel as an expert in the field of
psychiatry and behavioral sciences with
specific emphasis on drug and alcohol
abuse intimate partner violence and the
effect of these as they pertain to the
issues in this case all right any
objection
do you wish to avoid here i do okay
to his qualifications
his wealth okay thank you
sir you talked about two board
certifications
general
adult psychiatry
yes
and
liaison consultation site psychiatry uh
other way around but confrontation
right
now that
is
not
inter partner violence that deals with
with a issue of co-morbidity between
people who have
medical problems
and health problems
so you're saying sub-specialty yes so
consultation lays on psychiatry
does have that but you're also treating
patients who have medical illness who
have co-morbid psychiatric illness or
people who have psychiatric illness that
have comorbid medical illness and many
of the patients that i see on the trauma
service have tried to take their own
life and unfortunately as part of that
intimate partner violence and trauma in
general is part and parcel of that so
it's
very very narrow to say it's just a
medical psychiatric interface it's much
more of psychiatric patients you need
medical help medical patient develops
psychiatric problems but also
that interface
so
as a subset of your trauma patients
which you say are about 50 of your
practice
as a subset of that practice some people
have been involved with intimate partner
violence so as a subset of my overall
practice 50 percent of suffering from
trauma about half of that number has
suffered from i'm sorry about 20 so it's
20 about 20 that suffer from my intimate
partner violence all right you've never
conducted any empirical research
on individuals who experienced intimate
partner violence have you sir
if your definition is trials is that
what you're saying yes like
pharmaceutical trials or what are you
saying
as i was saying because i've done review
articles on
patients who suffer from trauma so the
answer is oh i haven't done any
studies like where you
give them medication for treatment or
try one treatment versus another i've
reviewed the body of literature on
intimate partner violence to get two
review articles yes so you
so you've read about it is what you just
testified i would have to disagree with
you on that sir reading about it and
writing a review article are completely
two different things sir all right you
haven't authorized authored any articles
specifically on ipv have you sir as a
subset of trauma the answer is yes in
terms of in the name of the title of the
article the answer is no
you've never written any books
specifically on ipv
i've never written any books on ipv
although although
temporary mandibular disease
okay in terms of psychiatric issues does
have a higher frequency
in those patients who have suffered from
trauma including
intimate partner violence
you've never and i am part of that book
okay temporal mandibular disease
deals with
problems with the jaw
what is temporal meaning
disease problem with oral issues yet but
there are many patients who complain of
oral issues where the uh where the oral
surgeon cannot find a reason for it and
the reason why they can't is because
people who have suffered from trauma and
intimate partner violence are prone to
increased sensitivity of somatic
sensations which can manifest in
temporal mandibles thank you i
appreciate that nice plug for my book
too thank you
didn't hear it but there we go um
so
you haven't written any chapters of any
books specifically about ipv
again i think i've gone over that i've
written two articles on that and i've
written parts of chapters and
dissociative identity disorder i should
have where i did write a chapter on is
completely based on trauma and intimate
partner violence right i'm not asking
about trauma because you want to talk
about trauma i'm asking you about ipv
specifically
i will reiterate again
you cannot separate
intimate partner violence and say that
is a separate rubric
aside from trauma trauma
is overall
intimate partner violence is part of
trauma and the answer to the question is
any individual who suffers from a
dissociative disorder which i am the
author a chapter of suffers from trauma
whether it be at the hands and childhood
or be the hands of an intimate partner
right but you've already testified that
half your practice is trauma and a
subset of that practice is ipv correct
which is an actually i treat the
national average patients about 20 of
patients suffer from it and that's about
my practice number
that except you're discounting the fact
that half your practice is
not trauma at all so
ten percent of your practice is ipv
i don't know if the numbers add up
exactly i'm just using yours
i don't know if i'm doing uh i don't
know if those numbers add up like that
uh because i'm not sure if that's the
case if you take 25 then maybe 12.5
percent of my practice that's
be rather specific so again a
significant number of my patients have
suffered from intimate partner violence
i see it on a daily basis and i'm not
sure exactly why i'm
getting asked the same question again
so thank you sir
you listed 60 references to articles i
guess you said 80 now and publications
um and i said around so i said around
80. i said around look 60 80 whatever it
is right now 60 and 80 is not if you go
to the pubmed you want you're going to
put men right now and google
put pubmed spiegel dr and you'll find
that number is 72 with two waiting to be
impressed
one submitter so i'll be 75 so it's
around 80. so again what's on my cv is
not necessarily the most updated version
because i still publish
since the cv has been uh
given to you sir
right
and
not one of the 72 80
articles
has ipv in the title right
correct not one of them has ipv does
have trauma but not ipv right
and you've never presented on the topic
of ipv specifically
as a function of trauma as a function of
somatic illness again i would say to you
that it's part and parcel of these
illnesses so the answer is yes i have
okay the answer is yes i have and ipv
doesn't appear in your cv at all
if if you say it's on my cv i will
believe you okay there's a lot of things
i'm not in my cv that i do so
and you're not associated with any
professional literature on ipv
i'm sorry repeat the question sir is
there any professional literature that
you've contributed to relative to ipv
specifically as as opposed to trauma
generally
the answer to the question again sir
is that you cannot separate this
artificial separation you are trying to
do between trauma and intimate partner
violence it is part and parcel of trauma
we don't thread it like that
your honor
plaintiff would accept this witness as
an expert on general psychiatry but and
with respect to the drug usage issues
that mrs bredehoff referenced but not
with respect to ipv all right over
objection he's entered as an expert as
as stated on the record all right you
may continue thank you very much
dr spiegel at our request what have you
reviewed in this case and just go ahead
and give you so
it's a lengthy review but court filings
uh psychological testing that was done
on misheard by both dr hughes and dr
curry
uh
other physicians medical records vicinio
dr kipper
council
counselors and therapists
that both parties and psychiatrists that
they went to
text messages
depositions
snippets of
the uk trial
and i'm sure uh pictures of uh physical
injuries so i've seen a lot
what if anything have you seen in terms
of emails audios videos yes so i've seen
videos
of uh
mr depp i think the video was showing of
mr depp
destroying
slamming cupboards and
breaking glass
and yelling at misheard
while having a wine glass in his uh with
wine in his hands
i've seen videos of
a destruction of property in the house
okay
and what if any review have you
conducted of the deposition and
testimony of mr depp's hired witness dr
curry
objection
approach
do you remember my question
did did you
review the deposition and testimony of
dr curry
dr
curry
yes i've your doctor yes i'm sorry yeah
so every testimony dr curry i reviewed
dr perry's reports i reviewed dr curry's
test
okay and what if did you review the
deposition and trial testimony of dr
hughes
yes objection you're honored beyond the
scope of the disclosure
uh uh i'll allow that thank you
overworld did you interview mr depp no i
did not
did you request
i requested to interview mr depp twice
and both times mr depp and his lawyers
refused
dr spiegel i'm going to ask you some
questions in this case respect in your
opinions and and the opinions you have
formed on the basis for them and i'm
going to ask you to provide me with in a
reasonable degree of medical probability
or certainty can you do that
yes okay
on what were you requested to analyze
and opine in this case
so it's four-fold uh
one i was asked to opine about the risk
factors that are associated with
intimate partner violence
and behaviors that are shown
risk factors that are shown in intimate
partner violence to be consistent with
behaviors that mr depp has demonstrated
two i've been asked to opine about the
acute effects on alcohol
and substance use and i mentioned that
including mood behavior cognition
functional
impairment three
talking about the psychological profile
if you would of
i'm
is there a question i'm sorry oh no okay
of uh psychological and medical sequelae
of patients who have suffered intimate
partner violence and perpetrate intimate
protovilles and whether or not mr
death's behavior is consistent with that
and lastly about uh alcohol and other
substance use disorders
their diagnostic criteria
their medical and psychological effects
psychiatric effects their cognitive
effects and their functional effects
and i think i would like to just just go
with the jury one other thing when we
talk about when we when psychiatry talks
about substance use disorders i it's
imperative to understand we're not
talking about someone who rarely uses
and happens to have a bad night we're
not talking about someone who uses on a
weekly basis and has a bad night we're
talking about repetitive patterns of
behavior that meet a list of 11 criteria
that could be deemed mild moderate or
severe
because i think people get confused when
they hear the word substance abuse that
they think of oh i may have used this
because i use it twice
there is a whole criteria of behavior
and sequelae and consequences that go
with a substance use disorder i'm not
just talking about someone who will
occasionally smoke a joint or smokes a
joint or snorts occasionally coke okay
or has alcohol on weekends so i really
need to reiterate that because i think
when you look at psychiatric behavior
we tend to look people look online and
say my gosh i have all seven of these
right and they they're reading it not
quite the way the psychiatric lyrics are
supposed to go so please when i'm
talking about this i need you to
understand
one that that's what's going on as i
told you about intimate partner violence
it's horrible that anyone would strike
anyone okay but again we're talking
about repetitive behaviors from means of
control
right so that's real important to
understand when you're moving forward
and i may say occasionally substance
abuse but what i'm referring to
is substance objection beyond the scope
of the question
sustained next question okay
dr spiegel could you please just
summarize for the jury the conclusions
you came to with your opinions and then
we'll take you through the specifics
so in my opinion
based on my
review of the evidence
based on my clinical experience based on
my publishing experience based on my
teaching experience
that mr deb has behaviors that are
consistent with both someone who has a
substance use disorder as well as
consistent behaviors for someone who is
a perpetrator of intimate partner
violence
thank you i'm going to start with the
impact of drug and alcohol abuse over
time
first of all based upon your review of
the record evidence what type of drugs
has mr depp used
so mr depp and i will get i'm told by
you we're talking about a substance use
disorder here we're not just talking
about use
okay so we are talking about
alcohol
we are talking about amphetamines
we are talking about marijuana
we are talking about cocaine
we are told by lsd
we are talking about ecstasy we are
talking about opiates
we are talking about prescription
benzodiazepines
and we'll get into a separate thing
about the abusability of seroquel
and or gabapent in iran
and we're talking about much of the time
concurrent use meaning simultaneously
in your practice do some patients
suggest to you that drugs and alcohol
actually help them
so i think it's
patients who
lack insight or are in the very early
stages of recognizing they have a
quote-unquote problem
will sometimes actually say
that
they have
this medication actually calm me down
this medication makes me feel better and
in actuality
they may not acutely feel
anything
but chronic and continual use will take
its toll on the brain so the answer is
yes but again people have substance use
disorders have a very have lack of
insight and lack of judgment about
what's going on the very poor
uh moderates of their own behavior
as mr depp suggested based on your
review of the record evidence that
alcohol and drugs
actually help him yes and in review of
the evidence he has suggested that
alcohol
xanax i'm in the list of medications do
you help
although i will also tell you on review
of the evidence that there was
at least two times i can remember
that uh mr depp was referring to uh at
least short-lived periods of sobriety
and i cannot exactly tell you what that
included
that both times he said that he
functioned better and that he recognized
that alcohol drugs was at the root of
his problems
now
there have been there's been testimony
that mr depp is quite charming both off
and on
the drugs and the alcohol
what is your answer to that so
again
let me
put one thing clear here
i am not here to impeach mr depp's
acting skills
or his persona he has way greater skills
than i do in that
what i'm hearing today is talk about how
drugs and alcohol affect what we all
have in common we're all human beings we
can all only get so much take so much
when something is going to happen
and that's what i see every day
in the emergency room on the council
service in patient psychiatry
bad things happen not because of
anything special except for all human
beings and our brains substance of abuse
are not titrated they are not regulated
by the fda
we don't know what we're getting we
don't know how much we're getting there
is no control over what makes it to our
brain so it is not the actor it is not
the persona
okay
it is a person just like the rest of us
who are human beings
who will have these effects and that's
what we all share in common everyone in
this courtroom shares that in common
when mr depp was in his relationship
with amber hurd was he a poly substance
abuser
was he and what substance abuse poly
substances yes
can you explain
what that is oh overall
i'm sorry get going okay so poly
substance abuse is the use of three or
more substances
and i answered like i said concurrently
um
he was
even while i was getting ready for rehab
on the island he was
so yes he did engage in that
did mr depp's drug and alcohol abuse
affect him cognitively
yes
so
if if nothing else to look at uh dr
blaustein psychiatrist at valley mr depp
did a mental state exam on him and as
part of that mini mental state
examination you're asked to remember
three words and then come back five
minutes later and repeat those three
words and in the meanwhile you're
getting other types of testing for
retention and concentration and visual
spatial and language so other things
that are being tested too
mr depp was unable to recall any of them
and that is
very unusual for a
50-ish year old male i don't remember
how old he was when he took that
generally speaking
that age group should be remembering
two or all three of those words
um
one i do know that
his
lines were also
fed to him by earpiece
again affecting memory i did see in
deposition i'm sorry video deposition
about having to have
uh questions i don't want to say repeat
as much as completely forgotten
so
the answer is yes and and you know any
again
any one of us who use alcohol and
cocaine
to that level of degree and i'm talking
about a severe level of substance use
disorder
are going to have effects it is
inescapable because we all have brains
that are male affected by extensive
substance use and potentially sometimes
less but certainly what we're talking
about hearing extensive
what if any anything did did you observe
from the record evidence about mr depp
having difficulty focusing his attention
span processing whether he could
function as an actor
so electron compound
compound is only if it's overruled thank
you
so again in terms of the acting part we
do know that he needed his lines fed to
him for movies
part of that
could have been also due to
and i don't know which movie and please
forgive me about that that he actually
confessed he did a movie entirely wasted
so i imagine it would be harder to do
that
additionally like i said when i looked
at that position you can tell that the
processing speed was down his thinking
rate was down
if your thinking rate is down and i'm
not talking about again
i'm getting older i'm probably not as
sharp as i was at 25 okay
but i'm talking about it so slow that
when we're trying to move on to other
questions we're still trying to answer
the original data that's presented to us
so attention span
is very much impaired and if your
attention span is impaired
your memory is going to be impaired it
is inescapable that that's going to
happen
so all that
comes into play and that's what i
witnessed in the um
in the uh
video deposition
fortunately for mr depp i do see that
during this trial that's he's uh uh his
cognition has improved some of which
will happen if you are sober
uh so i commend him on that
uh but again i'm specifically
referencing the time with ms hearns and
mr depp's relationship so we're talking
about that
what if any uh
observations from the record evidence
did you have about mr depp having
alcoholic blackouts or foggy mind
again there will report a time where he
would be essentially quote unquote
passed out drawing he saw pictures of
him passed out drunk and not being able
to remember what he did which is again
if you look at the record evidence you
will see that
and this is linking intimate partner
violence and substance use together i
know we're going to get to that which is
basically if you have blackouts
and you're using alcohol or using
cocaine
it's going to be near impossible to
remember
what happened the night for i don't
think i'm the first person that's ever
told you that alcohol can cause
blackouts and basically alcohol
decreases a brain chemical glutamate
which is involved in memory formation
if it blocks that
to an extensive degree the individual
cannot remember what happened because
they didn't have enough time for their
brain to process the memory we need this
brain chemical so does alcohol blackouts
happen every time so no of course not
but are they complication of a use
disorder absolutely yes and
there was record evidence of that dr
spiegel you said at one point alcohol
and cocaine is it possible to have
blackouts with alcohol and different
types of substances yes so
my clinical experience and i'll be i'll
date it back within the last month
we had a patient who was using both
especially cocaine and she had these
kind of stroke-like lesions around the
brain center known as the hippocampus
which is involved in memory formation
objection relevance
just giving an example
combining the two subs together
increases the likelihood even if you
don't get what is a major stroke and
again we think of a major stroke as
someone who has speech difficulties and
movement difficulties there's a lot of
different types of stroke that can just
affect cognition they don't necessarily
have to have
severe movement deficits or severe
language deficits they can solely affect
you in terms of your cognitive symptoms
and actually known as a vascular
neurocognitive disorder so i you need to
understand that's part of the
psychiatric diagnosis you need to
understand that you can have these
insults these lesions these strokes
without demonstrating physical features
and at a minimal
we know that he was using both
substances concurrently and in the
middle we know he had cognitive issues
that we talked about
or at least had some of them
thank you dr spiegel what if any
correlation is there between domestic
abuse heavy alcohol abuse and cognitive
disorders
so
um
the risk factors if you would for
intimate partner violence
okay and there are probably many of them
i don't have time to go all them but the
ones in particular characters in
particular are one
having someone in the relationship who
is jealous or suspicious
two having someone who has
a higher than average acceptance of
violence ideations
three someone who has rapid and extreme
mood shifts
for
someone who has limited self-control
one of the roles of cognition one of the
roles of our brain
is to prevent inappropriate behaviors
and acting out on thoughts we all get
angry at people
that's human we all get angry at people
we all think things about people the
difference is when our brains are intact
and working well
most of us don't act them out
okay most of us do not act them out
so that's
because your frontal lobe and other
parts of the brain are involved in
making sure these negative thoughts
don't get acted on
okay
so when you have the effects of alcohol
acutely
that causes disinhibition
which means you are by definition
losing control and having rapid mood
swings
two you are affecting parts of the brain
that are involved in what we call social
processing clues cues so you no longer
can interpret
what's in front of you that is i would
say right or wrong or what i should act
on and what i shouldn't act on
so we act on them
even though
sober and i've seen it in with mr depp's
mr deputy at record evidence i've seen
it clinically sober
we can contain that we can contain that
but when you have these mixtures
together
knowing by the way that about 40 up to
60 percent of intimate partner violence
is uh
uh done under the influence of alcohol
and those substance use disorders
okay
knowing that treating it gets it better
improves i'm not saying it removes it
but improves it
hearing from mr depp's own uh text to dr
kipper that he was better with that that
things are going better we'll show you
that given those confluence of factors
given them all lining up the risk
factors
combined with something that when any of
us any of us
use to a certain amount if we're not sad
it'll be a lot less
if we're more experienced and more
tolerance dependent it's going to take a
lot more
but inevitably will make us disinhibited
and will make us act out and acting out
could be done in a lot of different ways
an intimate partner violence okay with
also remembering
control is the endgame of it's been part
of violence so that's how they basically
interact in a nutshell
miss brotherhood i assume you have i
have quite a bit more let's go ahead and
take our uh morning recess ladies and
gentlemen just do not discuss the case
and don't do any outside research we'll
be back with you
i'm sorry in 15 minutes we're just all
right
break no no we're taking a break
all right let's just take a break till
11 then we'll come back at 11. okay
thank you
are you ready for the jury yes your
honor we approach before the majority
okay sure
so
so
to
all right
thank you very seated all right your
next question thank you thank you honor
dr spiegel before we took the break you
were talking about the correlation
between domestic abuse heavy alcohol
abuse and cognitive disorders does the
literature support uh your your
testimony on this yes the literature
fully supports everything i just said
i'll do that interaction
thank you um
now you indicated that you reviewed mr
depp's video depositions is that correct
that was from november 10 through 12 of
2020 and december 14 of 2021 is that
correct yes okay
did you reach any conclusions about his
cognitive symptoms insight and judgment
in watching those
so
during the
video deposition
what was readily apparent
was a gentleman who had a significant
delay
in processing speed
and like i said when you have a delay in
processing speed
many other cognitive functions are going
to follow you're going to be impaired
attention
concentration
memory
all that's going to
happen in terms of
having to
the the speech process you heard the
deposition the way the thoughts were
conveyed
were much more in the way of kind of
disconnected disjointed statements it
wasn't that they were not necessarily
understandable
but they didn't have any coherent
pattern until
he was more structured by ms bredehoff
to kind of get to the point of the
question which happened
throughout most of the deposition
um and so
you could see there that there was
obviously some form or cognitive issue
that
should not be happening
in someone in their mid-50s
and
probably due to the alcohol and
substances
what if any observations did you make
about impulse control
so during the deposition or yes
either um
so again i think that
under the
guise of not being acutely intoxicated
i think mr depp was able to
control
much of his behavior much of his
thinking even if it was uh aberrant or
negative he's able to control that
i think that
once you start getting to the point of
adding substances to that
that will set it over
um if you saw the the video i think you
you all did about the uh in the
kitchen where there was smashing of
glasses slamming of cupboards and
yelling at miss her that you don't exist
um
and throughout
the deposition of uh dr kipper
uh
mr deb is firing him and rehiring him
and yelling and screaming and i do
believe that a lot of it had to do with
the interaction of hey
we're trying to help you get sober
okay and it is obviously something you
are
resisting
not ready for not wanting and so you saw
a lot of yelling a lot of uh a lot of
acting out if you would
which
puts you on the state of hey this is a
gentleman who has really significant
trouble
with delaying gratification
okay delay and reward
um and certainly one way to one way to
uh
make that significantly worse
is with substances there's no question
about that
and you may have
subsumed this in but what if anything
did you observe relating to erratic
behavior based on the record yeah i mean
i i think again when you talk about
erratic behavior um
the uh
uh
dr kipper's deposition i believe it was
where uh and i think i made particular
note of this home because i'm i'm a
psychiatrist myself
there was a very
uh
large
ranting about dr cowan who was miss
heard's
psychologist therapist
and the language you can be dissatisfied
with your provider i have no problem
with that you could be dissatisfied and
you have a right to go to wherever you
want to go to
but the
the texting
that it were involved in this in terms
of erratic behavior
um
was
disturbing in terms of the verb you
choose the phrases you say i i'm
am i free to
use some of the language or should i
reserve that your honor
go ahead
okay
believe me the jury's been hearing it
okay all right one mission
i want to take sure okay so there's
something along the line that uh
dr kipper is an effing charlatan
um
objection hearsay
he's entitled to rely on it he's to give
his examples
he can talk about what he
uh developed from the hearsay but not
repeated himself he's entitled to give
examples of it i'll sustain the
objection
without giving the exact words that you
recall without any exact words yeah okay
so i mean without giving the exact words
it was basically
a vulgar language directed towards dr
cowan throughout multiple tests
texts
multiple
things that dr cowan were doing in uh in
therapy
uh uh
uh it was like i said it was without
relaying the exact thing i'm trying to
be as accurate as i can
um
and i think at the end of it i think he
was also talking about that dr cowan was
filling amber with
positive
thoughts of therapeutics objection
hearsay
i think he's keeping it more general and
he's rel he's entitled to rely on him
thank you
so
more along the line of
giving amber psychiatric
uh uh
uh jargon to put on him and and actually
what i read and interpreted what dr
cowan's uh was getting blasted for
was he was
you know kind of teaching amber how he
was heard how to use conflict resolution
in a more appropriate manner and
learning to express things more
rationally
rather than express things as irrational
as they have been expressed
and uh and for that uh there were a lot
of negativity
being sworn out so again erratic
behavior in terms of writing a text but
i have no problem people being angry
okay none whatsoever it's just the
expression of it and the continual
ranting of it
is is was was very uncomfortable for me
to read but regardless i think we have
seen in terms of erratic behavior uh
much of the
psychological and the physical
uh maltreatment we talked about
objection beyond the scope of the
question i i don't agree sustained next
question okay
mr dip is 58 years old are the behaviors
that you have been describing for the
jury are those typical
and age-related
no so while i don't consider 58 years
old i'm 59 okay i will tell you that the
age-related changes that occur in humans
are very they're very um
erratic hit and miss
meaning they'll occasionally bear it be
there you may need a little bit more
time to answer question or pull things
out of memory just you're just a little
bit slow and a lot more inconsistently
slow
you wouldn't describe what uh dr
blasty's changes were or what i saw on
the deposition attributes age
dr
spiegel what is sarah quell
cerebral or occupation is an absolute
atypical antipsychotic
which is indicated for many things
including schizophrenia bipolar disorder
adjunctive treatment for major
depression so it's indicated for a lot
of things
and but what what uh
what effects may it happen this is this
is one of the drugs that that mr deb was
taking correct it was a prescribed drug
yes okay
so what yeah please explain the effect
of cerebrals is is it's very often used
as a sleeping agent
uh because it doesn't have a lot of the
side effects that are associated with
conventional antipsychotics movement
disorders type dyskinesia etc or at
least it's a very low risk for that
so
people have used it off label physicians
have used it off label
to help them sleep
the problem is
the effect is
very
barbiturate-like and it really knocks
people
out or certainly if you use it at high
enough doses it can
okay
and the problem is the problem is it
also has street value
so it's absolutely used on the street
for that down or like effect and
obviously it's a little bit more readily
available because it's prescribed um
so it so it does have that street value
portion of
and dr
spiegel what effect would this have on
mr depp based on the dosages he was
taking
so
i think what you're looking at
is uh objection speculation
what you will see in patients who have
substance use disorders
are people who unfortunately
kind of wake up
and fall asleep only through
pharmacological assistance meaning that
their own circadian rhythms are no
longer in control
of that behavior so you will take
stimulants to quote unquote get you up
in the morning and then you will take
things like quetiapine cerakwell
to knock you out
so basically what these are being used
for is
i'm going to get up
and i'm going to get knocked out and
that's very characteristic of what would
be
actually
legal prescribed substances
that's not illegal at all that's very
legal
and that's the seemingly these what
these medicines affect our on patient
substance use disorder
dr speaker what is neurotin
so neuronal gabapentin
uh is actually an anti-seizure medicine
which is i think is
it's indicated for seizures and it might
be indicated for one chronic pain
condition although i can't swear that to
you
that said that said again in a substance
use disorder population
it has significant street value and
people who misuse opiates
often
supplement that with neuron because it
has this anti-pain
calming effect
so unfortunately it also can cause
respiratory suppression and so when you
use it with opiates they're very there
are people that are lucky enough to
succumb to respiratory suppression as a
result but it has a very additive
calming
effect that people use it for
and what effect would this have on mr
depp in the dosage he was taking
again i was looking for an objection
okay again
what it would do
is have the street value of using it
with
the opiates the advantages you're using
with opiates
and it's making because opiates in
general despite everything else it does
are common
and you use it with it it offers further
calming which is why
doctors have been warned not to
prescribe
medications like gab pen
and opiates together
unless under significant strict
following because it can cause serious
problems
such as death
respiratory suppression and mr depp was
also
taking adderall correct yes can you
please describe to the jury what that
impact would happen particularly in
connection with the dosages so
adderall
is a psychostimulant which is prescribed
relatively regularly for
adhd
the problem comes again when you're you
you
shouldn't be prescribing or receiving
adderall when you're already using
misusing cocaine
okay you're now doubling your stimulant
dosage here and basically what you are
talking about again it comes down to in
the substance use disorder population
you are using it to stay awake have
energy keep yourself going
getting high getting energetic and then
the only way to kind of combat that
because you have this effect is to kind
of
take cut down as during the day and down
as being anything that's calming so
anywhere from opiates prescription
anywhere from new rotten anywhere from
cereal all medications that are
potentially not potential which aren't
usable
and so
that's what this is going on that's what
the substance use disorder patient has
and you you know it can't be given with
someone using cocaine because that's
extreme risk for for death it can't be
getting together
and what if any effect would these drugs
have if they were mixed with mdma or
cocaine
so when you combine the two together
like i talked about before
there are
effects where you are looking at
right the the predisposing traits of
intimate partner violence
so jealousy
rapid mood changes
poor self-control
and to some degree at to some degree
condoning violence to a certain degree
when you combine them all together you
get this disinhibiting euphorian effect
from
cocaine and adderall then when you
combine the two together what happens
you get too much and then you start
getting irritable
you start getting agitated
okay you start becoming suspicious
jealous
potentially
disinhibited
psychotic
and
these are the risks and again we're
talking about not your average everyday
use of these substances we are talking
about chronic use together
and we also know
that alcohol and cocaine use
independently
increased significantly the risk of
intimate partner violence these aren't
statistics i'm coming up with they all
depend anywhere reports up to 7 to 27
fold
so
you are
quote unquote colloquially played with
fire when you are talking about
substances and intimate partner violence
you are playing with fire
and that's all of us
and the substances that mr depp was
taking and the record evidence relating
to those
did you draw any conclusions concerning
whether he met these this criteria or
these risk factors
so in terms of substitute disorder when
you when you look at it
so major role obligations not being
fulfilled
don't have any evidence been operating
under the influence or not
social issues especially disagreements
and arguments with your spouse or family
obviously there was tolerance
independent for the amount he was using
because if anyone is naive to this these
medications most of us will be dead
uh
unsuccessful efforts difficulty cutting
back
using more than intended
giving up social uh occupational
obligations because this i know there
was party entire words right after the
rehab on the island in australia when we
mr deb went out partly with marilyn
manson
um and you know objection beyond the
scope of the question
actually it's asking for the record
evidence
next question um
okay what other record evidence did you
have supporting um
so
uh psychological using despite the fact
you know what causes known
psychological psychiatric or medical
effects and i think that's been pretty
well documented so in this case you're
talking about someone who has a severe
substance use disorder i do want to
emphasize uh letting go them the jury
that intimate partner violence is
substance disorders of two scourges in
this country
there are two plagues
this is very serious stuff we're playing
with and when you are just getting
someone closer and closer to the
threshold objection your honor
relevance
this is highly relevant
i'll overrule as to relevance beyond the
scope
yeah scope of the question yes all right
so saying that objective all right
tell me more about the relationships
between substance abuse and ipv please
yeah so again
that you are talking about this and you
are
you may be able to control
the risk factors for it any of us
may be able to control the risk factors
for ipv any of us might be able to okay
when we're thinking and we're not
disinhibited
not having these hyper intense emotions
from substances once you add that to
this mix
your brain can no longer do what it's
supposed to do and it's supposed to
prevent you
from doing this
quite frankly because it's wrong
did you arrive at any conclusions
concerning substance abuse and potential
self-harm that may have led to mr depp
injuring his finger
so
i think the physician before we
explained that pretty well but i'll tell
you that mr depp has a history of
self-injurious behavior
meaning cutting himself mr depp has a
history of burning himself
i know when the actual event happened
there was uh texting to dr kipper
paraphrasing not saying exactly that
amber and him got into a disagreement
related to her wanting him to be sober
and then as a result of that he said he
got so angry
he uh he cut the tip of his finger off
so if you're asking me can someone who
has or have i seen and can someone who
cuts themselves burns themselves can cut
a tip of their finger off
with or without alcohol or cocaine or
the rest the answer is objection beyond
the scope of the question exactly
that is not a very far jump i've
certainly seen patients do a lot worse
than that who started out with similar
risk factors of you know burning self
and cutting so i'm not going to get into
the descriptions but i've
seen people do a lot worse than that
okay so the answer is yes okay i'm going
to turn now specifically to intimate
partner violence and i know you've
you've talked certainly about it um but
can you tell the jury please uh a little
bit more about intimate partner violence
and and what is included in that
so
the apa task force on violence in the
family
defined
more or less this topic of domestic
abuse intimate partner violence as
recurrent abusive behavior
by means of psychological
sexual
or physical maltreatment
for the purpose of achieving control or
maintaining power
authority and control
can it include threats and intimidation
it includes so in the part of
psychological
abuse which is done essentially as a
means of emotionally and mentally
hurting someone but with the same end
goal to achieve control
it can be
destroying property
it could be financial which is part of
that
verbal abuse verbal outbursts i'm sorry
um
threats intimidation
body language
all of that goes under the concept of
psychological abuse and you may be able
to divide it verbal non-verbal what's
exactly emotional versus verbal but
they're all under that rubric and
they're all under the guise of
maintaining control
do survivors of intimate partner
violence experience mental health issues
can you repeat the question do survivors
of intimate partner violence experience
mental health issues oh yes oh yeah so
survivors of intimate partner violence
and by the way i should start out by
saying
we don't expect in psychiatry we don't
expect our victims to be perfect we
don't expect our victims to be unscathed
by what they've received
so starting with that okay it is not
unusual as survivors
to see substance use substance abuse
substance symptoms
chronic depression
post-traumatic stress disorder or
sub-syndrome some syndrome
post-traumatic stress disorder along the
lives of battered wise syndrome
and some emotional unpredictability
that's and again you are a victim here
you are a victim
do perpetrators typically seek treatment
or counseling
no
perpetrators
are not receiving
counseling
uh treatment one because they're going
to be probably having to tell someone
that they actually struck someone which
is what their thought is about the big
problem that intimate part about it's
just hitting again important but not the
sole part of it so perpetrators very
rarely
will go into any type of formal counsel
victims
go into counseling victims are seeking
actually couples counseling victims are
seeking couples advice to try to repair
what's happening
okay but in terms of actual
perpetrators
no they don't do that
in your review of this case is there
record evidence of physical violence by
mr depp
so objection
no foundation do you want to approach
them
c
so
what have you reviewed
that correlates
with
the risk factors for ipv
that mr
related to mr depp
so risk factor i reviewed that correlate
uh
so starting
uh with the i guess we'll start with the
physical because that was the question
that was put out there what i have
reviewed
has demonstrated uh
shoving
uh
objection
let me let me see if i can
direct this a little differently dr
spiegel
um
rather than
giving the summary of what that was what
did you review that correlates in other
words
did you review
witness statements did you review
depositions
photos yes so what i reviewed was in
terms of like um
witness statements
dr kipper's
notes
very very interestingly actually early
on
in the in i think it was 2012 around
that time circa 2012 2014. um miss heard
was uh shouldn't be on the scope of the
question
what he reviewed is the question
all right let's uh let's see so i viewed
just
so
ms herds
objection there's no question pending if
he's he's answering go ahead and answer
what you reviewed please continue with
what you reviewed therapists notes
counselors notes
text messages
depositions
video
pictures
psychologists
notes
and evaluations
uh and i said physicians
notes that's what i reviewed all right
now you've indicated that uh intimate
partner violence includes physical
violence sexual abuse and psychological
aggression can you please describe for
the jury
what psychological aggression is and
what it entails so
it says psychological aggression
would be
the engaging in behavior for the sole
purpose of emotionally
and or mentally
harming someone
with the main purpose of again to
maintaining control so behaviors that
can occur
with psychological aggression
include
uh insults
intimidation
um
by holding things financially against
someone
um
uh jealousy rants
um
property destruction
so all that
is involved
a non-verbal communication so
threatening looks glances things like
that
all that is involved
in
psychological maltreatment and intimate
partner violence
what if any uh
what if anything would be psychological
aggression if it was trying to control
somebody's career would that be a factor
section leading
so yeah i'm trying to trying to control
someone clear that would be under
financial
the trying to uh to uh mistreat someone
uh especially you know someone wants to
succeed
and try and have a career and you're
preventing them from doing so by
maltreatment that's another example
okay
so i'm going to ask specifically about
the risk factors for intimate partner
violence is substance abuse a risk
factor for intimate partner violence
yes it is a risk factor as well as a
precipitating cause
and
what
record evidence did you review that
correlates to mr depp engaging in
substance abuse
so
the record evidence of
i'll just start with dr kipper
and the the substances that mr depp
was using and misusing both in terms of
prescribed and on your drug screen were
brought out through that
okay
uh is lack of behavioral control and
impulsiveness
risk factors for intimate partner
violence yes they are okay um and
what if any uh record evidence were you
aware of that mr depp
had lack exhibited lack of behavioral
control and impulsiveness
uh again
threatening
uh objection
record evidence
that correlates with and i'm on the risk
factors at this point thank you your
honor
threatening
destroying furniture
property
things
writings on
walls
mirrors
writing in blood and furniture
all that would be go with that
okay
all right
um
and
what if any
risk factor is narcissism for intimate
partner violence
so
a patient before we get into a
narcissistic personality traits or
disorder the overall let's categorize
under what's called cluster b
personality objection your honor beyond
the scope of the question
he's explaining the
narcissism i'll sustain objection okay
can you explain to the jury what's
involved with narcissism as it relates
to the risk factors of intimate partner
violence and what that realm is
so narcissism patients have
again poor self-control
okay
rapid mood shifts
okay
as a result they they have an undue
sense of admiration
they worship power the worship control
they are they have lack of empathy and
people are generally kept around as long
as they're useful to them
a
large sense of entitlement
um
anything else uh
do you need around need for need for
praise
so that would go under narcissistic
personality and ipv
what if any uh
uh require what if any traits would be
requiring admiration would that fit into
it
yeah oh yes requiring admiration need to
be admired part and parcel of uh
narcissistic personality disorder
would be an envious fit within that
fragile self-esteem yes
and
what if any record evidence do you have
that correlates with mr
depp
being narcissistic
why i do think
that
the
fact that
he thought that amber owed him misheard
ode objection your honor
overworld thank you go ahead the fact
that miss heard
owed him and only wanted to be together
with him
because of his
fame
uh is an example of that
um i do think the jealousy aspects
are
uh an example of that
um i do think you know
uh as i think mr
mr tillett had testified that you know
being admired is one thing but then
behind your back saying something else
about people
is another thing
um
and i can probably say with a reasonable
certainty that
to some degree this whole trial
is that objection your honor
what's the objection
that's not record evidence
speculation
please continue
that this whole trial in terms of
narcissism narcissistic insult is what's
going on
i believe that uh mr depp was very much
a mainstay appropriately in hollywood
and then this was pulled the wrong
without objection your honor can we be
able to explain why you sustain that
objection
um
can you explain what you mean by this
whole trial
this procedure
this court case we're going through
right there's an objection sir
well what other
conduct
is in the record evidence that
correlates uh with mr
depp having being narcissistic having
those traits
was the thing about the trial rule i
can't explain you're not allowed to say
not say that okay
um
the the uh the only other thing about
narcissism i think in terms of trial
would be in order to
maintain any sense of control
a narcissistic person
really has to have lack of empathy
because in order to engage in behaviors
that quote unquote are used to keep
individuals in control
you don't really think about the other
person you're not really caring what
happens to that other person so i think
that's
another facet
so
are attitudes accepting or justifying
intimate partner violence a risk factor
for intimate partner violence
yes
um
do some perpetrators and intimate
partner violence try to minimize
the ipv
yes so
it is unfortunately not uncommon
especially during
especially during the calm phases of the
abuse cycle where there is no increased
tension there is no acting out
okay you are talking about more of the
honeymoon
apologetic phase
begging for forgiveness
telling them how you're going to change
maybe giving them gifts and then when
the dust settles
later in the day a day or two later it
is not uncommon for the perpetrator to
kind of switch the blame over
to the victim
saying that hey you know this either
denial this never actually happened and
tried to make me look bad
or an allopathic defense where
you instigated it or an altruistic
effect where i'm doing it for you
transformative effect that society kind
of accepts this so it is very uncommon
for all of a sudden
for that to start shifting during that
time
because it is during the calm phase and
everything is is relatively calm this of
course is when the victim wants to
engage in
in treatment but beyond that
uh the ability to kind of quote unquote
for lack of a better phrase when people
over
family friends
uh
the law i mean the very ability to do
that is part parcel of that calm
charming
phase where it looks like the victim
is you know just fabricating this
okay
um
and is victim blaming uh a
characteristic yes like i said i mean
you blame the victim that one of the
defenses are the allopathic uh defense
uh comes along with victim blaming
that's what the sense you're doing i'm
blaming you
for what you made me do
okay and
is there record evidence that you
reviewed that correlates with mr depp
engaging in this type of behavior
so
i
i think for a lot of the
issues seen
the big precipitant
was going to be the need for sobriety
coming again coming back to that severe
subjection unresponsive
i think he's trying to explain it thank
you please continue
the severe
substance use disorder
and
many
of their arguments but what i reviewed
in the record
stemmed around ms hearn's desire for mr
depp
to maintain sobriety
and that what was happened so as a
result
she was blamed
for
you know bothering him
in a way he didn't want to be bothered
and
that triggered what was going on
are you familiar with the term gas
lighting
um
i'm for bullet trim gaslighting okay
what if any gas lighting
is consistent with intimate partner
violence and the risk factors
so again when you start being able to be
when a
person starts to be able to be
manipulative and charming
you start to be able to win people over
and especially when you see someone
who's a victim who is essentially
vulnerable emotionally
emotionally labile okay you see that
person and then you see this calm
demeanor in front of you
who's very charming very engaging very
personable and then all of a sudden it
starts looking like the victim is just a
a i was
essentially losing it
and
i either make their being gaslighted
is there examples where an intimate
partner
violent uh perpetrator
claims that the victim is the person
who's actually committing the abuse
yeah oh yes oh yes how common is that
very common again that's part of the
that is very common in the occurrence of
the like if the the
honeymoon phase and the calm period of
the abuse cycle very common during that
time where the victim whether they're
shifting the blame or
anything along that line that's very
calm for that to happen and you
indicated that you reviewed some audio
tapes in this case correct yes and what
if any evidence did you review there
that correlates with mr depp
attempting to claim that amber was the
one
well i think that was what was said that
amber
uh was the abusive objection your honor
i don't understand the objection
what record evidence
thank you please please continue
so that claiming that amber was
the abuser in this particular scenario
and what
what i will reiterate again is that
one victims aren't perfect and two
it is not uncommon
in the context of being a victim
when you know that person is about to
proceed or relapsing to a substance or
going to a substance
and anticipating what's going to happen
that you anticipate the next mood and
start initiating self-defense
but
by and large
that's not what's going on here
by and large
mr depp
behavior objection your honor this
behavior was consistent there's a
rejection sir i'm sorry i'll sustain the
objection okay
all right we can we can move on to the
next one is prior victimhood of abuse a
risk factor for intimate partner
violence yes
and
so go ahead there is something known as
intergenerational theory of violence
which is basically along the line of
uh observation imitation reinforcement
so you observe a behavior that occurred
in childhood you imitate it when you see
that there's no significant negative
consequences but you do get the positive
consequence of maintaining control
of a situation solving the conflict in
your way if you would
so
that theory is
interestingly it's it's it applies to
not only the victims i'm sorry not all
the perpetrators but also the victims
because there are many victims who grow
up in a house of
abuse
that
are not abused but they're the victims
of abuse
what are the warning signs of intimate
partner violence
so
warning signs would be
increasing
the tension
escalations of tension so that's when
you start seeing
hey
partners getting angry
okay starting to starting to break down
the communication
starting to engage in verbal
nonverbal threats
victim concedes due to this tension
and that leads you to the actual act so
these acts
are progressively build
and then
they occur
what if anything
have you seen an intimate partner
violence about apologies and promises
so again the apology is part and parcel
of the honeymoon phase and promise is a
part and parcel of the honeymoon phase
and you know the victim
wants to believe it's going to work they
want to believe their spouse is going to
be
faithful to this
and as part of the abuse cycle
um it ends up
as i should say in the calming cycle
like i said the victim tries to get
some help
to try to resolve this
until
the tension buildup phase where
something bothers them so again it could
be
bothering someone about
substance abuse it could be bothering
someone about finance it could be
bothered something about your career
anything is liable to build up tension
when you have this framework of limited
self-control
and erratic
intense
mood shifts
so what if any record evidence did you
review that reflected mr depp engaging
in these warning signs including the
apologies and the promises
i think it's that was almost routine
that after was all said and done
that he would apologize
for
letting this monster out
letting this anger out
almost routinely
and there's very well record evidence of
that starting as
early early on the marriage uh in in one
of in therapy from his heart so
um
that's that's
very common and very much occur
recognizing
what happened
and the other part of this is
again
when you can recognize that when you're
sober
even short-lived sobriety when you could
recognize that
that things are better things are
happening better life is better
then even that should show you
that hey
there's an issue here there are issues
here
that when i don't use
can be resolved
doc thank you dr spiegel i'm going to
now move to the goldwater rule can you
explain the goldwater rule please
uh so the goldwater rule
is when senator goldwater was running
for presidency and i i'm going to be
honest with you i think it was in the
late 60s when he was early 70s because i
was
too young to even follow politics then
so i please don't quote me on exactly
what it was
but basically what's happening is
um
clinicians psychiatrists were making
these quote unquote armchair diagnosis
from their
homes or offices because they saw this
person on tv the way they acted and were
asked to comment about what they think
their diagnoses are
and therefore it was felt that that
should not be done by professionals in
these public
settings does it have any applicability
here
no injection
why not
no foundation
all right
he was explaining what the gold water
approach
okay
dr spiegel do you remember the question
does the goldwater rule have any
applicability
here to your testimony and your
conclusions and opinions
uh no it does not and why multiple
reasons one
the basics of expert witness testimony
would almost be thrown away if you are
not allowed to base things on
what you evaluated of an individual what
you've read about an individual so if
i'm not allowed to comment on
records or
charts or information that i look then
expert witness testimony can't be done
but more specifically for this case
in the goldwater rule the pure version
of it was the armchair diagnosis of
watching someone on tv
just you don't make a diagnosis more
recently i think that's even more recent
bad examples of that so you don't make
diagnoses like that
this is not the case here
because i i said to you at the beginning
i have reviewed
a lot of professional
uh a lot of professionals and their
evaluations and their treatment course
uh
video deposition picture deposition
court filings uh emails i mean i
reviewed
a whole lot of things that directly
describe
uh mr depp and his behavior so i'm not
commenting on a public opinion and i
have absolutely no
knowledge of of uh what's in mr deb's
history um if i was just doing that it'd
be like watching a movie
that's not relevant here
and in fact i think you testified
earlier you invited mr depp too oh yes
forgiven again objectional eating
okay so
to to be fair
uh for and evaluate for my own direct
evaluation again i was offered twice
that i can do an evaluation of mr depp
directly
and both times
mr depp and or his lawyers decided that
that was going to happen okay and and in
fact the court did not require mr depp
too and the court did not require mr
depp to undergo this evaluation okay
dr spiegel these opinions that you have
offered here do you hold them to within
a reasonable degree of medical and
psychiatric probability or certainty
absolutely thank you all right
cross-examination
thank you mr
sir i'm wayne dennison
we haven't met
but
let me ask you let's start with what you
finished with
i'm sorry one more time
let's start with what you finished with
you understand that the court was twice
asked by miss herd's counsel
to order
a medical exam
of mr depp and those motions were denied
well
i think the the
your team
told the court you didn't want to have
them and the court
ruled on it i don't think the court
proactively did it you kind of had a
motion to them right
no
when
miss
herd's lawyers moved for them
and asked for them and did not get them
isn't that right sir
if if you're saying that's what happened
my understanding of was that you all did
not want him to undergo on they
petitioned for it the court said no yes
that's what my understanding of it was
the court said no to ordering mr deb to
do
the medical exam
i said the court did not require it
right and there was one that was ordered
in fact right
there was
all right
all right so
the last thing you talked about
was the goldwater rule
yes sir
been around for almost 50 years right
uh yeah i'm 59 that sounds about right
yeah
and it's been around
as a result of a presidential election
that you referenced yes
and
who has that rule
what organization uh maintains that rule
the american psychiatric association
an association you're a member
associated
of
a member of yes
aren't you a fellow or something yes i
am okay so
and this is an ethical rule right
it is an ethical rule
and yes it's ethical they say rules it's
an ethical guideline yes they're
guidelines
and
you know that over time
the
american psychiatric association has
amended the rules so it's not just about
diagnoses but it's also about
professional opinions
could you be more specifically say about
professional opinion in regard to what
well
let me
let me read this and see if you're
familiar with it
it is unethical for a psychiatrist to
offer a professional opinion
about an individual
based on publicly available information
without conducting an examination that's
the rule right if you're reading it
directly i will believe you okay
however a diagnosis is not required for
an opinion to be professional so my
question is
it's not just diagnosis
that this goldwater rule applies to its
professional opinions
so again i will reiterate that that
would come down to essentially
nullifying witness testimony
expert witness testimony without
direct evaluation
and as we know it didn't happen but
regardless of that the whole expert
witness testimony thing would be
basically rendered null bullet null and
boy
the rule in fact contemplates that issue
doesn't it sir
again i'm just telling you the answer to
the question when you're reading me
those statements
i'm telling you the response by the
other side who was publishes also
is that
if that was the case there could be no
expert witness testimony in the
courtroom
psychiatrists are ethically prohibited
from evaluating individuals
without permit without permission
or
other authorization such as a court
order that's the rule right
again if you're reading that then i have
to believe you're not misrepresenting it
and i would come back to you again then
this whole thing on effort we might as
well get rid of all the expert witnesses
we've had throughout all of time for
court proceedings because that you're
saying is unless a court orders it and
that's what you just said or the ap said
then therefore expert witnesses cannot
do an evaluation based on an observation
of the medical records insurance
companies cannot do evaluations solely
based on medical records with our
doctors rendering professional opinions
so at the end of the day you are
essentially saying that unless someone
has directly evaluated it there this
whole medical system we have this whole
legal system we have is null and void
i'm not saying no yes you are sir i know
you are give me a give me a second and
i'll give you more than a second
what what i'm
saying and what i am reading to you
is a rule
by your organization
that takes into account
that there could be court orders that
would permit the the exact kind of
evaluation that you say i'm eliminate
and i think we're going in circles
because i think i just said that means
expert witness testimony
would not be allowed and the branch of
forensic psychiatry would be especially
hindered and we know the branch of
forensic high does not prohibit that so
i am a member of the apa that doesn't
necessarily mean every single thing they
put in there everybody has to
uncategorically agree with because
clearly that's not the case did you
agree in your deposition that the
the professional opinions who you
rendered were
um
inconsistent with the goldwater rule
my first because in because if we're
saying
that i if the gold rule says and i very
much said that during deposition that
the goldwater rule was made for
presidents
and public figures such as that but
regardless of that because that's what
it was made for it's not made for
hollywood but i'll even take that mr
depp's a public figure
what i'm saying to you is that the gold
motor rules say we cannot do any expert
witness testimony in our field that is
exactly what the goldwater rule is
saying based on exactly what you read
and i'm just telling you
what you are saying that rule
encompasses
what i'm asking you sir
is did you
comply with the ethical requirements of
the apa when ref when rendering the
professional opinions that you've
rendered today it is a it is a
requirement of the ap is not the
requirement of the apa secondarily so
the answer is no secondarily secondarily
secondarily again
in order to not you we we waste our
whole morning because of an expert
witness before me as an expert witness
is everyone brought in so all i'm saying
to you that means the whole field
of medical legal law is corrupt and
unethical for engaging in an act that
the apa clearly says we should not do so
if you're saying that then the answer is
yes i'm agreeing with that statement
you're agreeing that the apa would deem
your
testimony and your professional opinions
rendered unethical
again i am saying you are saying that
the whole i'm an expert witness i'm
saying as an expert witness
and solely as an expert witness
that guideline is permitting that from
occurring
i would say then that the whole field of
expert witness testimony again would be
disavowed by what you are courting in
the gold order and we know that's not
the case because if it was we would not
be allowed to do it and you said the
rule was for presidents right that was
initially used yes
and the name of the rule came from that
but the rule says it is unethical for a
psychiatrist to offer a professional
opinion about an individual
that's right sir it's not just
presidents it's not public figures it's
individuals funny it was named after
according to your logic if you don't put
something in the title it's not true
that's what you told me this morning i
believe about my intimate partner
violence so what i would say to you then
sir
is that
if you say this about an individual
again
any court would have to render an expert
witness testimony invalid any
doctor that reviews charts would have to
render it invalid i can go on the list
of docs that do not see or interview
patients directly and that's a violation
so basically you are saying that unless
you do a direct clinical evaluation then
all of the field of forensic psychiatry
and all of uh managed care
is doing an unethical violation because
we are not seeing the presence we deny
patients medications all the time
without seeing them we deny patients
treatments unfortunately without seeing
them and i'm on the receiving end of
that so the answer your question again
unless you were saying to me that all of
this is unethical which is what you are
saying this is what you are this is how
i'm interpreting what you are saying to
me that unless you do the evaluation
directly yourself
therefore it cannot be considered
ethical and i'm telling you how that
applicable to not just expert law but
also managed care and applicable to
multiple brands of medicine hospital
duration of hospitalization stay they
get evaluated so
tell me tell me where you want me to end
this
well
why don't we why don't we
why don't we talk about
what you just testified to because i
didn't ask you anything about that i
asked you whether
under this rubric under this principle
of medical ethics
have you acted unethically yes or no
no as an expert witness i have not acted
unethically and if you want the jury to
believe that expert witnesses are
unethical then i guess that's for them
yes
no let's go to the next question okay
right
psychiatric diagnosis occurs in the
context of an evaluation based on
thorough history taking examination
and where applicable correlated
or collateral information
you'll agree with that i believe i said
that earlier yes
and it's a departure from the method
from the methods of the profession
to render an opinion without an
examination
and without conducting an evaluation in
accordance with the standards of
psychiatric practice incorrect
well again by the way for the record
intimate partner violence is not a
psychiatric diagnosis i'll start with
that
substance usage by themselves is not a
psychiatric diagnosis if you want to cut
to the chase psyche is not a diagnosis
of that
narcissistic
you are not rendering any diagnosis
whatsoever of mr depp
today or ever
no i probably would say to you that
certainly i would not say narcissistic
personalities i would say traits
certainly from what i have read an
intimate partner violence not a
diagnosis so the answer is no for that
narcissistic personality traits is not a
diagnosis the answer is no but if you
want to tell me that substance use
disorder
is a psychiatric diagnosis
the answer is yes and i but that wasn't
an issue was it whether mr
mr depp used substances
i mean you said you've gone through the
record that that wasn't really an issue
at this trial he's said it from day one
oh she's saying he's already admitted to
the diagnosis he's already admitted to
the use of the substances well again
there's in between admitting to
substance use and substance use disorder
let's go back to uh what you just said
about narcissistic personality traits
yes
narcissistic personality disorder
is a dsm-5
diagnosis correct correct
diagnosis
diagnostic personality and you haven't
testified that mr depp has
a
narcissistic personality disorder had
i would certainly if i didn't i'm
certainly thinking that but at least i'm
going to say he has traits which are
characteristics of provisional diagnosis
of it's a provisional diagnosis probably
narcissistic person but yeah i mean i do
believe that well when you say
provisional diagnosis you know the dsm-5
requires
in order to find that diagnosis
five of the nine factors and you haven't
done that analysis you've never made
that diagnosis
you've just identified certain factors
that are criteria for the diagnosis
right but you need five of nine to get
to the diagnosis you've you've already
told us that you didn't make a diagnosis
you're just i
identifying traits correct
i'm identifying traits that are
consistent with the diagnosis yes
right and you did you testify in
deposition
that the existence of traits as opposed
to the disorder
doesn't have a correlation
with ipv
uh i if i said traits do not have a
correlation with the that's what i said
and i don't remember saying that but
that wouldn't be a correct thing
narcissism has a correlation with the
diagnosis yes that part's true how far
are we going to back this up because
there's a diagnosis of narcissistic
personality disorder right yes sir and
that one is type
it has some correlation with ipv right
narcissism has correlation with ip again
you sir you're not allowed to answer
i'm you're splitting hairs you're
splitting hairs between the traits that
are consistent with which all i'm
commenting on is behaviors and traits
that are consistent with the diagnosis
and mr deb
narcissism absolutely has
uh risk factors associated with ipv
let's go back again
and maybe we can
we can focus on the question i ask you
and we can get an answer that's
addressed to that question
narcissistic personality disorder
is a risk factor for ipv yes or no
yes and you've previously testified
there that there is no
literature at which you are currently
aware that the mere presence of
narcissistic traits is a risk factor for
ipv
am i answering the question yes that's
incorrect clustered
a cluster
cluster b traits
which narcissistic personality sword is
part of
is a huge risk factor for intimate
partner violence which include
cluster b traits include narcissistic
personality disorder anti-social
personnel disorder amongst others so the
answer to the question is
every every
resource on intimate partner violence
will
support
that cluster b traits where narcissistic
personality falls under is a risk factor
for intimate partner violence any single
trait
under
is a risk factor for ipv
again i will repeat
cluster b
traits
i didn't say any trait i said cluster no
let me be more precise then okay
any
narcissistic trait
in and of itself
is a risk factor
for ipv
but you are mischaracterized what i said
what i said i i'm pretty sure i said
cluster if you look at all the intimate
partner violence literature i would
behoove you to do so you will see that
cluster
b
traits
specif i didn't say narcissistic per se
cluster b traits
where narcissistic personnel disorder is
part of
our risk factors for intimate partner
violence part impartial uniformly true
and i'm not sure the thing i don't
understand is i'm not sure why we're
arguing psychiatry because i'm telling
you what it is dr siegel you just need
to answer the questions okay
so you want to talk about uh cluster b
so let's do that for a minute
borderline personality disorder
is a risk fact factor
for ipv
as part of cluster betrays yes
histrionic personality disorder
is a risk factor
for ipv less so
but it less so it's good less so
it's a risk value but less so yes less
significantly less so all right
so
which traits
under narcissistic oh
before i move on there there's only been
one diagnosis
in court
of personality disorders correct
i'm not and so who you're referring to
are you referring to mr depp miss her
who i'm not sure what you were talking
about do you understand that there was a
medical examination done of mishurt
yes i did do you understand that the
testimony
was
ultimately that ms heard suffers from
two personality disorders okay so i'm
just being specific i just wanted to
know if you talk about misheard or mr
depp so that was that's all i was asking
you
yes or no to my question which was his
only one
diagnosis of
ms heard was diagnosed with that yeah
and both of the diagnoses
are in cluster b and both of them
are risk factors for ipv
but both those cluster b things are i'm
not allowed to comment on the testing so
therefore all i could say is that
cluster b traits and i'll tell you what
they are and by the way i guess i
testified this before which was that one
i don't expect perfection for my victims
two absolutely they were clustered
absolutely
given that you've testified to it before
let's move on to a new question okay
all right
you
indicated
in your opinion today that you thought
oh well why don't we
why don't we move a little are you a
member of the american medical
association no
okay so you don't know what the ethical
rule of the american medical association
is
relative to doing
clinical diagnosis about individuals
you've never talked to
so you're saying alternatively doing
expert witness evaluations
under that rubric right
i'm just asking you do you know the
ama's rule
under doing you're saying
ama's ruling under the rubric of not
doing vows with some of you did not see
and i'm i'm questioning i'm asking so
you are talking about expert witness
testimony no i'm talking about do you
know the rule i'm not a member of the
ama so okay
okay move on you don't know the rule
all right
you rendered an opinion about mr
depp's purported cognitive impairment
yes yeah
what to use as a baseline
a baseline for processing speed yeah for
for analyzing mr depp
before you watch this deposition
what is it baseline for that
i mean i guess my baseline would
probably be what i how i've seen him
interact
in public i have seen interact with
others i've seen him in direct in media
i see them interact all and his process
speed is certainly not slow i've seen
him do commercials his process speed was
not slow
a deposition didn't just say that what
you did was compare
mr depp's performance
in
lots of pirate movies
against his deposition testimony
what i said was i've seen mr depp
do
apology ads i did a policy out with bad
dog with no delay on process street i've
seen him interact with the media
regarding to that i saw no delay in
processing speed all i'm saying let me
ask you about pirates though you
compared pirates
to the tech to to the depositions given
and i apologize for what i said that i
misspoke you misspoke you didn't make
the comparison
right now just a second ago
just a second ago i i may have said that
i misspoke i apologize i misspoke okay
because you know you can't compare
pirates to sworn testimony right
yes
okay
but you can but as an aside you can't
judge someone's processing speed
at any time like i'm judging yours right
now you're judging mine we all judge
processing speed as a baseline because
of what we know about each other i would
say your process be right now is not
slow so i mean we're judging processing
fee i'm just saying to you
yeah um
so but no any of mr depp's other
portrayals
in movies did that affect your analysis
of processing speed only i've seen him
interact
on interviews and that was it right when
he wasn't in movies right but willy
wonka doesn't matter to you
you see in that movie charlie chocolate
factory
did you look at that one when you were
comparing his processing speed
is
is that do i have to answer that
question
you have to answer questions yes sir
no you'll be happy no i didn't see willy
wonka as her and i didn't see 21 jump
street when it happened or i was about
no i did not
all right
you'll
you made a very kind admission i think
early on in your deposition
that you're not
claiming to be a better actor than mr
depp
that's correct isn't it
100
all right but with respect to acting
you know that actors actually
rehearse for their parts
and work on the language diction
timing of their dialogue as part of that
rehearsal
if you say that i'm not an actor so i
don't know what goes on i can't tell you
i have no idea what goes on in acting
okay but
you you don't know enough about acting
to know whether
actors rehearse
sir i am not an expert in acting i have
no idea what an actor does
okay
during your deposition
what were the circumstances under which
you decided to call mr depp an idiot
under somebody call me as a deputy idiot
yeah you called mr depp an idiot in your
deposition well i think oh okay so i
think it was in the context i think it
was
probably should read the context of it i
think the context was and i'm trying to
think back and i'm trying to think back
okay and what i thought it was related
to was if you're coming to some
deposition
okay and again i'm thinking back so
i admit you have it in front of you
i don't so i'm thinking back where he's
coming in from
europe for a deposition
uh video deposition that he gave and
he
took it overnight the night before and
what i think i said was that if you're
going to take a
if you're going to do a major thing
toward a trial that you're involved with
i think you'd be an idiot to come in the
night before
all right so i ain't coleman is a deputy
idiot i certainly call that planning
i didn't call him an idiot so the words
so i mean he's an idiot are
mistranscribed no i'm sure again if i
said it in that if you're just reading
one line one snippet i'm sure was in the
context i just said but again you have
it in front of you i don't yeah um
is uh idiot a professional opinion i
wasn't writing professional opinion yeah
is it a psychiatric opinion
and that follows the goldwater rule
how does it follow though i just said
that i'm not rendering a professional
opinion i just said idiot that's not a
so idiot is not a professional opinion
is it your
practice to describe people as idiots
my practice described me in my practice
no i don't describe people clinical my
clinical cases that you know patients as
idiots or victims as idiots no sir but
you stand for a deposition in this case
and and describe the plaintiff as an
idiot correct uh you gave me nine hours
of deposition and if i said the word
idiot it was an idiot in planning it
wasn't making him an idiot i don't know
mr depp's iq i don't know his overall
functioning so therefore if i said it it
was an idiot in planning which is what i
meant to come across as
so you did say you don't know his
overall functioning but you made some
testimony today as to
some evaluations you made relative to
his functioning you would agree with me
that it's
probably a good idea
to think about the questions that are
asked you in a court proceeding before
answering them
am i allowed to answer that question yes
okay so
what i meant by function what i said by
function i believe that his agent
reported how late he was showing up to
every movie while the cast is waiting
for him i believe that would be an
impairment if i showed up late for that
i would not be here right now would not
have a job okay i believe the thing was
in terms of uh
balking out of treatment for substance
rehab that his doctor is prescribing for
him so if you're asking me if that's an
impairment to functioning i would say
i'm very much substantiated in that
i'm trying to understand how you got to
this notion of cognitive decline
and i thought it was based at least in
part on the manner which he testified
i'm sorry what on the manner in which he
testified on the manner i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm not being difficult i can't
hear i'm sorry what
i was asking you about the cognitive
decline yes testimony that you made yes
and it was my understanding that at
least a portion of that testimony that
you'd rendered
was that
you
derived some evidence of cognitive
decline
from the way mr depp testified
yes
okay and that's what i said yes right
and so all i'm asking you is you
don't you think it's a good idea
when you're in the middle of a court
proceeding to answer questions carefully
again professionally we diagnose
patients with a neurocog disorder
by gross evaluation
all the time with cognitive and the
thought that again age normal controls
i'm just saying age normative controls
does not put a 58 year old gentleman at
that processing that's all i'm saying
right all i said
and you derived this
without ever once talking to the man
you need me me directly talking to him
because i heard because we know how i
drive it so you're talking about me
directly talking to him yeah you never
talk no i never no i've never talked to
him right
and this
exam you gave
well you did talk about miss uh dr
blaustein right yes sir
and you understand that the entirety of
dr blaustein's
uh medical records or 12 pages of
handwritten notes
the important part was what i said
for me as an example of cognition which
i'm trying to prove which is what you
asked me the important part was what i
said
and that was
irrefutable
the important part is that he give
he gave the mini mental status exam
yes sir all right let's talk about the
mini mental status exam
scored on a 30-point scale right yes
all right
and it's it's an exam that
basically
is most often used for
what alzheimer's dementia those kind of
testing
it's an exam that tests cognition all
psychiatric illnesses not just
alzheimer's it was made
for dementia for all times but as the
standard
has been the standard for testing
cognition in all psychiatric illness
substance use disorders included
okay now
there is an element of that
exam
that requires
drawing correct yes so
you don't know what drawing mr depp did
or whether the drawing should have been
fully scored i wasn't questioning his
visual spatial perceptual skills which
is what that does right
and you don't
know
what score
mr depp received
on the exam i was very specific i know
three words not remembering at five
minutes that's all i said
three words not remembering five minutes
and he remembered one of them right
from what i understand you remember any
of them
all right
memory on the exam
out of the 30 points what's it worth
three three
three right
memory is three out of those thirty
yeah memory is three okay again the
memory section in and of itself tests
memory
that's the only question that test
memory only section that actually tests
memory so the memory section tests
memory it's the only section you
testified about and for all you know
that with respect to the exam that
you're relying on mr depp scored 27 out
of 30.
and that would be telling though
cognitive score 27 and 30 and you missed
three points on memory that would be
very telling you don't know if mr depp
had been up all night the night before
again you wouldn't expect to not recall
any words at three minutes
unless there's a cognitive issue you
don't know if mr depp was high
and again oh now that's
again that could affect memory but i'm
not i'm not refuting that i'm not
refuting that at all he could have been
high could have been
drunk he could have been using cocaine
and that would absolutely affect his
memory which is what i said yes you're
right
so ultimately you have no idea what
state mr depp was in
at the at the time he took the exam that
you're relying on
short of what you just said about drugs
and alcohol
okay there shouldn't be a reason why 58
year old also with strokes at other
neurocognitive conditions but short of
that there shouldn't be a really good
reason why someone at that age shouldn't
come up with at least one
but but an answer but wait a minute you
you started that question with short of
drugs and alcohol and spent 35 minutes
talking about his use of drugs and
alcohol
isn't that right
oh i'm a great what i thought i agree
with you i think i agreed i said that
drugs and alcohol can absolutely affect
cognition i'm not
sure yeah i agree but i'm not sure if
that's a
problem i agree with you on that all
right so you don't know
one way or the other
how he scored on the exam you don't know
whether he was at the time on drugs and
alcohol but you're going to rely on it
in your testimony to say that he's
cognitively impaired
which is what we do in clinical medicine
sir
okay
you rely on tests that you don't know
the when it was administered you don't
know the score of
of the test and you don't know the state
of the person being tested but you're
gonna rely on it anyway again if we had
to know every test
when people get the midi mental state
exam we have no idea clinically if they
are high
wasted stone
stroke we have no idea so if you're
going to say that that means everybody
needs a drug test before they do a
minimal study and that's not the
standard of care
and i think you know that so
let's talk a little bit
about this word you kept using
correlation
you know the word right
yes
correlation and causation aren't the
same thing are they sir
no they're not same thing no how are
they different
correlation is consistent with causation
is direct link
can you say that again
so fast i didn't hear it oh sorry about
that
correlation
is
a risk
for something happening
causation is a direct link right
so
just because something's correlated
doesn't mean it's going to happen
100
right lung cancer for instance smoking
is
very highly correlated with lung cancer
right
yeah and certainly and there's certainly
a link right to lung cancer and smoking
right but but not all smokers get lung
kids
no no not all smokers do no one like i
said no one fits the curve perfectly
right
and
you've made repeated testimony and to to
all of us all of us do this all of us do
that
your
your suggestion about all of us is
you're just looking at the world as a
sample
and not at any particular individual
correct
what i'm looking at is
that
i'm not talking about an individual how
they can or cannot be resistant what i'm
saying is invariably when use substances
this is going to happen now is there a
0.05 chance that someone who does
absolutely there is but is that medical
degree of certainty absolutely not
a 0.05 percent chance of what sir
of developing eventually developing
symptoms of using excessively eventually
you're going to develop symptoms right
but risk factors tell us nothing about
any one particular individual do they
sir
no they work done again risk factors
tell us nothing except that they have it
they're at a higher likelihood of
developing it that's what tells them
but you did a whole litany of
risk factors relative to ipv
yes right and none of those risk factors
tell us anything specifically about an
individual
other right other than they're at higher
risk right right
so someone could have every single risk
factor for ipv
and never commit ipv right
it would be again if you're going to say
medical degree or probability the answer
is they will but if you're saying
uniformly the answer is no right
ipv can occur without substance abuse
oh sure
someone can abuse substances without
ever perpetrating ipv
again
absolutely but
again you are saying
different than what i said
i did not say abusing substances i said
substance use disorder
you aren't there's a two different
things because there are surely people
who use substances that do not engage in
any violence do not become psychotic
nothing at all so that's equally true of
people who have substance abuse disorder
there are certainly people
who
have substance abuse disorder
who don't commit ipv correct they are
saying people have substance use
disorders
the majority of them over 50 percent do
so open centers so that's medicine
the answer is
yes
as you said not everyone who smokes gets
lung cancer
so
there are
significant numbers of people you you
said it was over 50 so so you'd say 40
percent of the people who have
substitute substance abuse disorder
don't commit ipv
and those are the ones that do not have
ipv risk factors though right so we're
told by people
it
substance abuse disorder and ipv risk
factors yeah these are other people that
have don't have other risk factors right
right
but again we're talking about people in
general you don't know anything about
any particular individual as to whether
anybody's going to commit ipv
if statistics follow through all we can
say is more than 50 percent 70 percent
will if you combine
more risk factors you have
the more likely you're going to develop
the illness if you smoke cigarettes once
that might not correlate to lung cancer
if you smoke it chronically
that might
so that's why we're talking about
individuals here you either have lung
cancer or you don't right
if you're smoking right right
you either commit ipv or you didn't
oh i mean yeah you either did it or
didn't yes right
so you
took some issue with me because i was
asking about substance abuse generally
and you wanted me to talk about the
the disorder
i'm
i asked you earlier about narcissistic
personality disorder and you you haven't
made that diagnosis you've just talked
about the traits right yes
and
anybody somebody can have
these narcissistic personality traits
and substance abuse disorder
and never commit ipv right
so
along that line right about about
80 to 90 percent of people who commit
ipv
have a personality disorder so the
answer is less than about 10 percent
obviously do not
there are more
close links with ipv
for borderline personality disorder
than narcissistic personality disorder
correct sir i'm
not going to agree with that no i'm not
saying there are more links i would say
to you there are absolute if you're
asking me there are links the answer is
absolutely if you're saying to me more i
can show studies say yes so study say
that that has not been absolutely
definitely correlated no
no absolutely not
mdma
what is it
uh
ecstasy
yeah
and
what's the normal dosage of ecstasy for
people who use ecstasy
again i couldn't tell you the
quote-unquote normal dose because
honestly speaking no one no one knows
what they're getting when they're using
it right it's not regulated so but
the effects of ecstasy
enhanced sense of well-being
at low doses
the answer is yes
i'm going to gather when you're using it
at higher doses and develop tolerance
you develop the sympathomimetic effects
which are not so enhanced wellbeing
increased extraversion
again
at lower dose you are 100 right at low
amounts you are 100 right it is an
antaction we feel closer to people
that's what people use it say they feel
close to people warmth to people uh 100
but
with continual use and higher doses
it could be fatal
right so that's not that's not well b i
don't know if i call that well-being
so continued use at higher doses
mdma can be fatal correct
correct what if you took eight to ten
tablets of mtm mdma
if what if you took n h again you don't
know what it's it's very hard to say
that you don't know what it's uh uh uh
what's the worm look for contaminated
with
okay you can't just say hey let me just
take eight to ten pure ecstasy and see
what happens that's that's not gonna
happen so what i would say to you again
because substance of abuse are
unpredictable they are not regulated
no one knows what they're going to no
one asks us any idea whether it's going
to cause this empathic and tactician
effect at very low doses
or is it going to cause the
sympathomimetic i'm sorry increase um uh
uh consists like a stimulant like
cocaine cell we talk about like that no
one knows what's going to happen it's
not regulated and no one knows if you're
using with other substances either
like
other stimulus
or if you mix it with alcohol or mix
with alcohol
no one knows if it's going to be
potentially worse
right but if this is a potentially
lethal combination eight to ten mdma
this is a potentially toxic combination
right can it kill you yeah i mean it is
a potentially toxic combination that's
true
ever heard of someone cutting off their
own finger on mdma
have i ever heard of it yeah uh no i
only give you one example i hadn't seen
that one before oh
so
sarah quill
that one
puts you to sleep right
uh if you want a phrase a barbiturate
putting you to sleep then the answer is
yes yeah you heard mr mr depp talking
about sometimes being on the nod right
and again i think i i think i explained
seroquel very well this morning
good i'm going to ask a few more
questions okay okay
all right
you kept making references to street
value why were you doing that
because that's why people are
substituted to sort of use quetiapped in
cerewel
that's why people who use quetiapeed and
or slash cerakwell
can get has it sells on the street
because it's so barbiturate-like in
effect right but you said that mr depp
had a prescription
oh there are many supplements used to
sort of patients who have prescriptions
for adderall and quatit from their
doctor and that doesn't mean they're not
getting high out of it that doesn't take
much doctors like to believe what
patients have to say they're not going
to go in there being
expert witness testimony all i'm telling
you is that in people who have substance
disorder it is not uncommon and the
thought was initially that because
quetiapine was not addicting that it's
safe to give in people with substance
use disorders when in fact we absolutely
know it has to revalue absolutely know
that for a fact
right but my point about this is you
made it a bunch of testimony about
street value
but you knew at the time you made the
testimony that mr depp in fact
had a prescription he also had a
prescription for oxycodone and oxycodone
is that does that count
because that's also probably not a good
thing
it's just because you're a prescription
doesn't it
because i would agree with you it wasn't
a good thing just because you have a
prescription doesn't mean you can't
abuse it no i'm not suggesting you
you're abusing it i'm just wondering why
your testimony was in any way tied to
street value when every single drug you
referenced mr depp had legally
again you can have prescription
substance abuse and we know that correct
i shouldn't be asking that we can have
prescription substance use disorders and
that's not uncommon if you look at the
opiate epidemic that we're living in
right now we can have that that's not an
uncommon thing
unfortunate but uncommon not uncommon so
sarah quill i think you described as a
sleeping agent when used off label
when i saw what
sleeping agent seroquel when used off
label
when you use off labels you use that can
be used sleeping yes
right
so
mr depp's use of seroquel
could account for some of the photos we
saw in this pic
in this trial where he's asleep in a
chair again what i would say to you is
that
if you have a substance use disorder you
are using it to be knocked out yes i
agree and i'm but i'm not sure at the
end of the day if she had vomited us
over you either because i've never seen
sarah well do that
so when he was passed out in the chair
he also vomited us over him i've never
seen cerebral do that ever what
neurotin is another one of the
drugs you testified about
that one's
also
prescribed right
yes it is
and what's the prescription for that
what's it used for
and what's its indication or what's it
what's its indication i mean syndication
is for seizures it may have one paid
indication again i'm not a neurologist
so i can't tell you exactly if it does
but but it's chronically used off label
for pain it's used off label for anxiety
right
and what's its effect
that's another that's another one
that'll put you to sleep right
uh
well yeah i mean sure 100 right
and
you made reference to a picture
that
there's been testimony around the
around that picture that mr depp fell
asleep with
ice cream in his hand that's not
vomitous right i i was told it was
vomitous okay
um
talked about the fact that mr depp uh
indicates that from time to time
he uses an earpiece
i was yeah i mean i i read that yes
okay um did you
read the testimony of mr wyatt who told
you what was being pumped into that
earpiece yeah i mean if i if i remember
right i mean it was i think it was lines
right
no it was music it was music not
inclined yeah okay so if
if mr depp was listening to music
rather than being fed his lines does
that change your opinion as to his
cognitive function
if he was never fed his lines through
the earpiece which i
know he was
but read he was
and that may have been that example mr
white may have said that it was music i
guess the question is were you having
the music
during the during the actual talking of
your line is that what you're saying to
me
well you know if if you can do two
things at once that's a pretty high
cognitive function isn't it sir you know
it's very good point actually divided
attention is something humans have a lot
of trouble in so for instance we have
trouble driving and putting on the you
know using our uh cell phones and direct
so divided attention humans actually are
not very good at i'll put that out there
but mr in general not just mr deputy but
but mr depp is pretty good at acting you
you you acknowledge that early on
absolutely better than me so i know that
because you don't act in fact you don't
know about acting
you're right i have no idea about that
and you don't know how prevalent the use
of ear pieces are in acting
again i do i i know nothing about acting
irrespective of the fact you know
nothing about acting you've testified
that mr depp's use of an earpiece
is somehow a cognitive deficit
so if i was giving a lecture and i was
fed my lines i would think there's a
cognitive deficit so i'm and maybe i'm
wrong i said maybe i could be wrong
maybe hollywood stars get
lines fed to them through earpieces all
the time and i i don't know
that could be it sounded to me to be
unusual if you're doing a movie and you
don't know the lines but like you said
i'm just judging into what i do with
lectures and that would never happen
if you gave lectures you wouldn't use an
earpiece but you're not going to tell
anybody how to act
i'm sorry what was the question
i said if you gave lectures you wouldn't
use an earpiece
but you're not telling anybody how to
act right i would not use an earpiece
during lectures right but i again i
don't know what the standard for care of
how standard is hollywood is for that i
have no idea
your use your testimony about the use of
an earpiece
as um
maybe you were wrong
you're comfortable with the fact that
you may have made a mistake there
no because i think in the basis of what
i've read about it i'm comfortable that
i i don't believe that
actors are routinely given their entire
script through earpieces i find that
hard to believe yeah but but not one
word of evidence that this ever happened
i hear i guess what i said i just said i
find it hard to believe i didn't say it
i said i find it hard to believe that's
all i said oh yeah but what you found
hard to believe sir was that every
every line of the script was was pumped
through an earpiece where did you ever
get the idea that ever that occurred
that's what i have been that's what i
read and the court review the court
evidence that's where i got it right
and um
you know whether marlon brando used an
earpiece
whether isn't he dead
yeah
so the answer is no he does not use one
now oh no i i use the past tense oh i'm
sorry uh
again i know nothing i will concede to
you i know nothing about acting
i will concede to you 100 if that is the
standard and people have done that
facting then i apologize and that was
wrong on my part
if that's the standard i'm wrong i don't
know
okay
let's go with that no further questions
all right how long is your return a
little bit you may want to take all
right let's go ahead and break for lunch
then ladies and gentlemen again do not
do any outside research do not discuss
your testimony with anybody okay
all right
so let's come back at 155 then all right
uh
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you very much
[Music]
they're very
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
get back sweet
foreign
foreign
yes
uh
so
all right may be seated
your next question redirect thank you
dr spiegel
you were asked about whether you
were able to examine mr depp do you
recall those questions back and forth
yes and so if i understand your
testimony you asked twice for mr depp to
be interviewed by you correct yes
objection leading and
and then in addition to that ms heard
requested twice of the court for mr depp
to be submitting to an examination of
you correct yes and those were denied
correct yes and now mr depp is
contending that it's unethical for you
to provide an uh an opinion in this case
because you didn't get an opportunity to
interview him do you think that makes
sense objection your honor
i'll sustain the objection all right
is that your understanding that is my
understanding of it okay um now
when counsel for mr depp was reading to
you the goldwater rule there were two
words that he kind of went over pretty
quickly and i'm going to go over them
again with you a little bit slower and
that was that the goldwater rule
was that you cannot make an armchair
diagnosis right
objection based on
quote okay publicly
available
records do you recall that yes okay now
the records that you reviewed
in this case
were private were they not yes and in
fact
dr blaustein's records were marked
confidential correct yes and his
deposition was marked confidential yes
okay and uh dr kipper's records were all
marked confidential objection leading
and uh
sustainable okay what what if any
labeling was there on dr kipper's
deposition ev all the documents i
reviewed were confidential and also
signed the confidentiality agreement so
everything i looked at was confidential
okay so that in fact does not even
comport that doesn't meet the uh
restrictions objection leading i mean
so would it be fair to say that you have
not have you rendered any
opinions in this case as an expert
witness based on publicly available
records i have not rented any opinion
based on any publicly available records
thank you
now you were asked a number of questions
about narcissistic traits and your diet
your diagnosis or findings that mr depp
exhibited narcissistic traits or had
that disorder do you recall that
testimony yes all right and
uh the question was asked of you of the
uh whether if you have five of nine
narcissistic traits do you remember that
testimony yes okay now one of the ones
you testified before
was in for narcissism it requires
admiration correct yes
what if any record evidence was there
that mr depp requires admiration
the
the very people that surround him
need to admire him or they're no longer
in his employment or his uh working
circle okay the second one that you
discussed was sense of entitlement do
you recall that testimony yes all right
what record evidence is there that mr
depp exhibited exhibits behavior of
needing a sense of entitlement
so again thinking that uh ms heard
was marrying him solely for his money
and his influence and that that was the
case was in my opinion very entitled
all right and the third one you
discussed was exploitative do you recall
that
yes okay and what is the record evidence
that mr depp exhibits behaviors of ex
that are exploitative again i think the
whole concept of abuse is exploitative
okay
on the fourth one was lacks empathy do
you recall that yes and what is the
record evidence that mr depp exhibits
lacking empathy to be able to
commit intimate partner violence and the
control you have over someone
i'm sorry
can i be heard okay
i'm just going to ask you to
give the record evidence of
mr depp's uh lacking empathy that you
know of yes
my lap am i a lot elaborate yes just
just a little different than what you
said before okay
um
so
if
if one does so i'll make it more direct
so if you're not agreeing
with what mr depp has to say
you are no longer useful okay therefore
you don't really care about others for
others you care about others for your
benefit so
off and on dismissing dr kipper
for dr kipper setting some boundaries on
substance use protocol substance detox
is an example of lacking empathy and not
really caring what other people have to
say
all right another one of the
characteristics that you cited was
envious do you recall that testimony yes
what is the record evidence that mr depp
exhibits envy
i think jealousy is a good start for
that i i think that miss her wanting to
have a career start with that beyond
what she has uh and the the jealousy
parts of with mr franco and
um
and i think others uh comment this week
was bursting sorry last week ms burstin
commented about things about jealousy so
i think it's pretty apparent
okay
and
the next one you listed was fragile
self-esteem do you recall that
yeah and what is the record evidence of
mr dev exhibiting that so fragile
self-esteem would be more along the line
of a cluster b trait i should put that
as not necessarily the criteria for
narcissism so it's a trait um and
basically what that means will be that
the combination of
poor self-control and rapid mood states
is fragile
self-esteem fragile personality though
traits so go into line of cluster b
rather than per se narcissistic
all right now we've seen mr depp during
this trial doodling and eating candy
what if any uh evidence would that
suggest that he has narcissistic traits
objection you're wrong no foundation
i'll sustain the objection
okay
now
you
were asked
about the cluster b
and council for mr depp came back and
said
uh are you aware ms hurt has been
diagnosed with borderline personality
disorder or histrionic personality
disorder
now you reviewed
you i think you testified the beginning
you reviewed the therapy and counseling
and medical records for ms heard correct
correct what if any uh evidence was
there that bonnie jacobs diagnosed amber
heard with either borderline personality
or a histrionic personality disorder
objection
that's fair cross he he asked the
question that's fair redirect
beyond the scope
it's not overruled thank you
so if i could start miss jacobs uh
demonstrated no
type of personality sort of borderline
or otherwise and on a review of uh dr uh
yeah dr karine's rep rejection is beyond
the scope of the question it is i'll
i'll ask each of them separately and you
you also reviewed the medical the
therapy records for ms heard for connell
cowan correct
yes what what if any evidence was there
at any time that he diagnosed and were
heard with borderline personality
disorder or histrionic personality
disorder not only did he not he referred
to mr depp as a narcissist
okay
now you also re reviewed all of don
hughes records and her testing correct
yes and what if any evidence did you
find in any of that extensive testing
and note-taking uh that she had found
that amber heard had borderline
personality disorder or histrionic
personality disorder objection leading
what a world
none
okay and you also reviewed dr curry's
notes and her testing correct yes all
right and what if any evidence did you
find in any of dr curry's testing that
amber heard had either borderline
personality disorder or histrionic
personality disorder she had traits she
did not meet the font herds her own
evaluations you did not have the full
endorse enough criteria to meet the
criteria for borderline personality
disorder
and or history historic personalities or
she definitely had traits she did not
have the disorder by going by the strict
number of uh criteria
all right now you mentioned in response
to mr depp's council's questions you
started to talk about battered wife's
syndrome
what is your experience with battered
wife syndrome sometimes
being mistaken with borderline
personality disorder or histrionic
personality disorder objection compound
and leading
overworld
um so battle y syndrome which is
more sub-syndromal or not quite ptsd has
70 symptoms of ptsd and if you hear some
of them you'll see why someone might
think that
they do have reliving experiences is it
feeling as if the abuse is happening
even if it's not
upon reminders of
via upon reminds of abuse such as
getting ready to use something going to
reuse a substance or something along the
line they do have hyperarousal they do
have hypervigilance which is very easily
mistaken for the emotional reactivity of
borderline personality disorder they do
have avoiding symptoms so they avoid but
emotions
activities people and if that can't be
happening they start becoming much more
anxious much more hyper-aroused
they have inter disturbances in our
relationships which clearly can be an
issue
intimacy uh problems again which could
also resemble borderline personality
disorder so
those description and traits that were
there
uh
a did not meet the full criteria for
borderline and b could easily be
explained by battered wives syndrome a
form of ptsd
thank you now you also indicated earlier
that you reviewed the deposition of amy
banks correct yes
and what if any uh
determinations did you make based on her
deposition
from her meetings with mr depp and ms
hurd
so
dr banks is a professor who
at harvard the leading institution in
america for medical schools who's an
expert on intimate partner violence she
had a chance to meet them in a
relationship uh counseling uh
question you're on an unresponsive
that's that number i said what if
anything did she find sustained all
right tell the jury about amy banks the
significance of amy so what ms dr banks
found was that she fully believed uh
miss heard's version of what was going
on objection hearsay
i i i reversed those let me let me do it
again please tell the jury
please let me please tell the jury
what about the qualifications of dr amy
banks this is the one who saw both hurt
and mr deb dr banks is a uh
professor at uh i don't know whether
assistant associate professor at harvard
uh university medical school one if not
one of the two top medical schools in
the world
who specialize in intimate partner
violence she is above all people who
understand if someone is victim
perpetrator because she does this
researches this for a living every day
and that's that's her qualifications
can i say what she reported that i'm
going to ask you what if anything did
did dr banks indicate relating to
histrionic personality disorder or
borderline personality disorder from his
heart
dr banks didn't mention anything about
personal disorder at all what she did
mention was whom she felt gave a more
accurate version
of objection
what's the objection
that's a credibility testimony i i think
he can testify to that i'll sustain the
objection next question
what if anything did dr banks report not
saying what the ultimate conclusion was
what if anything did dr banks say about
what was reported to her by
ms hurd and mr depp and how they
responded
so
ms heard discussed the um
in trying to again as a victim trying to
save the relationship uh discuss with dr
banks
these accusations these these these are
facts of intimate partner violence
um mr depp
objection hearsay
i i think he's he's entitled to rely on
here saying he's not giving what
ultimately was he's entitled to it
that's why you can rely on hearsay but
you just can't
state the hearsay so you can rely on it
all right
what if anything did mr depp do in
response
mr deb said nothing when miss heard
accused him of intimate partner violence
mr depp said nothing and what is the
significance objection here safety
unsustained objection all right and what
is the significance of that
the significant of that is with
objection no foundation
sustained right we'll move on um you
were asked about mdma
and what the impact could potentially
uh be
of taking eight to ten of these pills do
you recall yes okay and
now i'm going to take you to australia
2015.
you've reviewed testimony over that
right from mr deb ms heard and the
number okay um
were you do you recall that ms hurd also
said that she found dime bags of cocaine
in drawers at the end of that three days
yes okay i'm going to ask you michelle
can you bring up
1828 it's already in evidence
and if we can publish that okay we can
thank you
i'm going to this is one of the pictures
that was taken in australia and the
testimonies been that these two canvases
of miss herds were painted completely
over is that something that could be the
impact of having eight to ten
tablets of mdma and combining that with
cocaine and alcohol objection no
foundation
speculation
the foundation's already been laid your
honor that's
sustained the objection next question
what if anything if you look at the
painted canvases on this one
what if any
uh
evidence is that that reflecting
behaviors
indicative of taking a lot of mdma
cocaine and alcohol objection
speculation no foundation same question
sustained
you testified earlier
about
property destruction of property do you
recall that yes okay could you tell the
jury what
uh
what how that relates to the correlating
factors of risk factors for ipv
again destruction of property is a form
of psychological uh abuse psychological
uh mistreatment and so destruction of
properties used as intimidation and as
needs of control
okay
michelle can you bring up 1829
and this has already been admitted yes
thank you your honor
and what if any evidence
does this
reflect as correlating behavior to risk
factors of ipv
i would say that one that demonstrates a
good deal of violence and psychological
uh
abuse uh
i think it's pretty clear that they're
trying to be intimidating
i i don't think objection your honor
thank you please continue
it would be it would people who would
misuse
ecstasy
with without coke without cocaine
are prone to agitation
suspicion jealousy violence
what we're seeing there would be very
consistent
with that presentation okay thank you
michelle can you now bring up 18 30
30 i guess
and that's already been admitted into
evidence as well your honor it asked
that it be published
and what if any evidence
does this
correlate with behavior indicative of
ipv perpetration again this is
intimidation psychological abuse where
you're solely trying to emotionally
objection around can we be heard
okay
dr spiegel if you uh if you can answer
the question
what if any evidence is this
correlating to the risk factors for ipv
perpetrator
again i i think the the violence comes
through
the objection
just the evidence of risk factors
evidence i'm sorry the evidence of risk
factor would be
accepting and more than average
a degree of violence as well as
psychological
abuse
okay
are you aware of any uh
record evidence of miss heard writing on
walls mirrors counter tops or painting
canvases
no okay
thank you michelle you could take that
down now now you were also asked about
cerakwell
and
some of the other prescription
medications
um
did you during the course of your review
of evidence see the lists of medications
that mr depp was on at one point yes i
read admit michelle i'm going to ask you
to bring up defendants exhibit 301
and dr spiegel it's not into evidence
yet i'm going to ask you to take a look
at this is this one of the documents
that you had that reflected
uh the amount of medication that mr depp
was on as of october 26 2014 yes
okay
um
and
this was an email from debbie lloyd to
dr blaustein his treating psychiatrist
correct yes okay
now can you tell the jury
that we've got seroquel 50 mg objection
hearsay
can you just tell the truth i mean i
haven't finished asking the question
yeah
so bill's perch
okay
michelle can you scroll up just so i can
see all of them at the same time
thank you
so
dr
siegel if
someone was taking
50 mega meg
i thought is that
milligrams milligrams of seroquel 25
milligrams of seroquel
and 50 milligrams of seroquel and 50 all
in one day
how would that impact them
so
obviously this is not for sleep
because um
presuming you're not wanting to sleep in
the morning
noon and from four to six although
you're sleeping at night
what i would say is he's using it for
one purpose as i say with substance use
disorder they're using it to calm down
using it just as a downer to relax
and
given that you're taking 45 milligrams
of adderall a day
uh to stay awake and
i'm
that's more than the uh prescribed for
adults and children for that matter
um
uh the combination makes very little
sense
at all to me
if a person was taking 300 milligrams of
neurotin i'm going to pronounce that
wrong again
four times a day and 600 later in the
day how would that impact
again you're looking at medications that
are there solely for a substance use
disorder patient to get them up and to
calm them down
that's all this is this regimen is about
uh
deb penn doesn't have a psychiatric
indication other than actually doesn't
have psychiatric indication although it
does calm you down and uh as i may have
been to bed before
similar adderall
uh gab uh cab pen is also abusable
symmetrical type pincer well is also
abusable so you're getting these kind of
unusually calming effects
from these medicines while at the same
time getting what's called a super
therapeutic dose or an excessive amount
of adderall
and for the record book
adults are only indicated with adderall
for the extended release not the
immediate release preparation and why
that's relevant is the media release
preparation is more abusable you get
more high quicker extended release goes
out throughout the day
the immediate release gets you up right
away and then down now in adhd
this medicine is very effective
for what this is being used for clearly
based on the combination
no
all right do addicts lie
yes
all right
now you were asked about mr depp passing
out do you recall reading testimony of
mr depp
passing out in the bathroom in his vomit
yes okay was that does that help refresh
your recollection of what you recall
i mean for the record book i don't think
that falling asleep with ice cream on
you is a objection beyond the scope of
the question
keep going i don't think sarah taking
sarah well at night
and falling asleep with ice cream on you
is not what seroquel is indicated for
what's not meant to put you out in the
state where you don't even be able to
stay awake to put ice cream away
all right michelle if you can pull up
defendants 109-0
that's already into evidence
if we can publish that to the directory
your honor
dr spiegel uh does this look like uh i
mean would this be evidence correlating
with uh
behaviors consistent with ipv
perpetrator risk factors this would be
carly a person who is completely
knocked out of this usually only one way
someone gets knocked out that badly and
that's with pharmacological assistance
whether it be illegal or illegal they
make it to the bed they don't sleep with
their head
on a game box in a
furniture
that that doesn't happen to people who
sleep no matter how tired you are
about how i've been a resident in the
past and
i i was up for
40 45 hours objection beyond the scope
it's just explained and done
all right
michelle can you pull up 109.5 please
and this has been i'm going to ask you
the same question dr spiegel uh what if
anything does this indicate relating to
risk factors for ipv perpetrators again
you know colloquially passed out and
there's very few ways to get like that
without pharmacological assistance
illegal or illegal and or illegal
and then let's pull up 1094 please
michelle
defense and that's also been admitted
and now we have the ice cream picture
and
what if any indication does this have
probably could see how i could
speculation no foundation what if any uh
correlation
what if any evidence does this indicate
correlative with the risk factors for
ipv again this proves one of the major
risk factors and precipitating factors
for
intimate partner violence objection you
are moved to strike all right sustained
i'll strike it from the record next
question
all right we'll we'll just move on okay
um
you were asked about earpieces did you
do you recall reviewing tracy jacobs and
joel mandel's depositions yes all right
and do you recall them both testifying
that mr depp had someone on salary to
feed him his lines yes okay
now
you've testified that you reviewed a
substantial amount of evidence in this
case did you find any evidence that
amber heard exhibited conduct or
behaviors indicative or consistent with
any of the risk factors for perpetrators
of ipv objection beyond the scope
well it was suggested with the
borderline personality
okay
but you did find that for mr depp
correct yes okay
and did you find
record evidence that mr deb had a
substance abuse disorder severe
substance use disorder
did any of the questions asked by mr
depp's council change any of your
opinions in this case
nothing there no not my opinion has not
been swayed in iota okay do you hold
them all still within a reasonable
degree of medical and psychiatric
probability or certainty absolutely yes
thank you very much dr spiegel all right
thank you sir you can have a seated in
the courtroom or you're free to go thank
you all right your next witness
my next witness is catherine arnold
catherine arnold
thank you will you please state your
name for the record
catherine arnold all right
and what is your profession
i am a entertainment industry consultant
and i also serve as an expert witness
okay and can you please tell the jury
your educational background
yes
so
i was in the end i've been in the
entertainment industry for
over 20 plus years i started
as an assistant at icm which is one of
those largest talent agencies in los
angeles that represents actors writers
and directors and i worked with the
talent agent there and then i also
worked at william morris uh for william
morris as a script reader so i was
working on scripts that they were
delivered uh and submitted to for their
actors writer's directors uh after that
i went into
development of
film and television projects for a
company based in new york called the
maltese company which
actually produced animated
television shows and feature films based
on wall street you know animated product
you know like toys
and then i went to work uh
with a company called the guber peters
company and goober peters was at the
time one of the largest production
companies in los angeles they did films
like batman and rain man
and tango and cash they did tv shows
like witches of eastwick and there i was
involved in the development of scripps
we worked with the studio directly in
terms of what cast would be attached to
the scripts and and brought directors
and talent to those projects
i then went on to
uh
work
in
um
there's a lot i went on to work
in the independent film world as a film
producer
so i found the material i would get the
financing i would get the cast and the
director attached to the project we call
that packaging and then we would go and
and obtain financing for that either
through equity sources or international
sales and financing and bank financing
and then i also
went on after that
i produced
five or six films with actors that you
may know including salma hayek vincent
d'onofrio kirsty alley thomas jane ethan
hawk
and then i worked with a
international sales and production
company where i was the head of
production and i worked again on the
development of scripts and the
procurement of financing so i worked in
both the independent world and the
studio world meaning independently
financed or financed by the big studios
like warner brothers and disney and
paramount and such as that
that's it that's the bulk of my work in
the entertainment industry any of your
films win awards
a couple of them did so a couple of the
independent films that i uh produced one
of them one called the coriolis effect
won the
venice film festival in its category
and then i also produced another film
that won the heartland film festival
award it's called crystal award
all right
and what other video production projects
have you been involved in
so throughout that time in between those
jobs i also worked in the corporate
world so
large studios like warner brothers and
disney and cbs would need corporate
videos for their live events so i would
interview executives and interview their
talent and then edit the piece together
to create
video and media for their live sales
conferences that they had at that time
and then i also produced some
commercials all right and what if any
experience did you have in corporate
relations and licensing
so early on in my career i worked at the
los angeles olympic organizing committee
and i worked in the licensing department
where we handled the licensing of the
olympic logo and we also worked with
sponsors and suppliers who were funding
those olympic games so it was a lot of
contractual negotiations with the use of
the likes of the logo
as well as
raising money for the games and working
with those uh corporate sponsors
throughout
the two years prior to the games and
then during the games themselves
and what if any experience do you have
working on film festivals
uh well i've had films and festivals
i've actually been very lucky to travel
the world and gone to a lot of festivals
with my films both here in the united
states and elsewhere and at one point i
was also hired to raise sponsorship
funds for the sundance film uh sunday's
film festival they had a new program
that they were uh starting to do online
festivals and so i raised about a half
million dollars for him in about a month
all right and
do you have a degree a college degree
yes i graduated from ucla with a
bachelor's degree in economics
what does your current consulting
practice entail
so as an entertainment consultant having
been in the business in both the
independent and the studio worlds as
both a producer and an executive
i work with investment companies and
production companies who are looking to
navigate
the various inroads of hollywood it's a
pretty
uh it's a business is very different and
unlike anything else and very
relationship based so i use my 20 years
of experience to help them
get cast get financing understand the
distribution process marketing process
and get them set up
to be able to produce their films
have you ever testified as an expert
witness in the field of entertainment
industry yes okay approximately how many
times have you served as an expert
i've been involved in somewhere between
85 and 100 cases as an expert from
beginning stages to testifying the court
and have you ever testified as an expert
on damages and defamation cases
yes i have okay and approximately how
many times have you qualified as an
expert on that on defamation yes i
believe
three or four times okay and have you
ever
been admitted to testify as an expert on
damages
yes okay and how many times have you
qualified as an expert on damages
almost all my cases have some form of
damage uh
relation you know economic damage
related to the case so i would say in
all of the cases that i've testified in
i have been qualified in damages okay
have you ever served as an expert for
both have you served as an expert for
both plaintiffs and defendants
yes i have okay
how much of your current practice
involves consulting as opposed to
serving as an expert witness
so over the last 10 or 12 years it's
been about 50 50 so i spent half my time
working as a consultant and the other
half working with lawyers on their cases
your honor i'm going to move to qualify
catherine arnold as expert in the
entertainment industry standards and
practices and related economic damages
all right any objection
all right so moved
thank you
now you have a dual role here as an
expert correct
yes
you're going to be testifying with
respect to mr
depp's challenges to or claims of uh
damages and you're also going to be
testifying to amber herds damages
correct yes all right well i'm going to
start you with mr depp's claims for
damages okay
with respect to mr depp's claim damages
on what subject have you been asked to
offer your opinion
so i was asked to assess the any alleged
damages that the op-ed piece in the
washington post that ms hurt wrote
whether that impacted his
career in any way particularly did he
lose any income or any economic
opportunities because of the op-ed b
specifically all right and
have you been asked to limit that to the
period of december 18 2018
with the date of the op-ed through
november 2 2020
yes okay
now what materials did you review in
making your analysis
there were a lot of documents
i reviewed the pleadings of the case the
complaints the discovery items the
responses to what they call
interrogatories which are the questions
that the lawyers ask both sides i
reviewed mr depp's test
deposition testimony which there were
volumes of that as well as miss herds
i also reviewed the deposition testimony
of of the experts that
uh
were proffered that had to do with the
entertainment industry you know the
agents and the management teams of both
both sides
ron schnell the data expert i also
reviewed
emails and texts between the parties
between their families between the
management teams the audio
recordings the visual recordings that
have been presented in this case and the
previous cases that have been involved
in the last couple of years
i also did my own independent research
from
general publicity and press and
investigative articles as well as those
that are specific to the entertainment
industry and utilize some entertainment
industry specific sources to get some
information that was helpful to my k to
our to that case thank you ms arnold
please describe for the jury your uh
observations with respect to mr depp's
career trajectory
well mr mr depp has had an extraordinary
career over many years so it's it's a
it's a long one to look at
obviously he was a rising star in the
late 80s and in the 90s starting with 21
jump street and you've heard you know
all the films that i'm sure he's been in
um he
he really started to break through when
he worked with tim burton the director
and and of course his character jack
sparrow in pirates of the caribbean was
you know world-renowned
um and probably um his biggest role
and he was a you know a well-liked um
both critically and within the industry
and within the public as a movie star
and at the same time
his behavior and
both on and off the set in his personal
life and in his professional life
start to interfere
with
uh
what we would say what everybody saw was
his great talent and it
started
you know there's some stories of of
issues that started back in the 80s and
the 90s but i would say really in the
mid 2000s between 2006 and 10
is when the behavior started affecting
his work to a certain extent in terms of
lateness on set
and then as ms jacobs his talent agent
discussed with you in her deposition
it really started affect
her ability to get roles and and the
industry's willingness to work with him
given the issues that he was having with
both behavior tardiness
drinks drinking and the drug abuse
and you know other issues in his
personal life so it got more complicated
for her to find him work and i think he
got harder for production companies
and studios to hire him due to the
challenges that that would put on a
production
and when did mr depp's career downturn
begin based on your review of all the
record evidence
well again
according to miss jacobs his agent she
mentioned that it started getting more
challenging for her around 2010 the
lateness
on set
was being made she was being made aware
of that more and more often from
production executives and the producers
that she was working with on the pirates
movie and not only pirates it continued
on
on the other films including mordecai
and
murder on the orienta express
and
in around 2014
when he had the appearance uh it was
presumed that he was under the effects
of alcohol at the hollywood film awards
in 2000 objection your honor
non-responsive
she's answering the career downturn
overworld
please continue thank you um
in 2014
uh
when mr depp appeared in the hollywood
film awards miss jacobs received many
phone calls from both producers casting
directors and production executives
asking her what is going on with your
client why you know what's going on with
his behavior can we get him under
control and then i think it really
started to shift around the pirates five
movie in australia with again the
lateness and the
uh issues uh with the finger that
stopped production and and things of
that nature and then it just it got
harder and harder
now based on your analysis what's has
caused mr depp's career
downturn objection
no foundation
can you please repeat the question
based on your analysis what has caused
mr depp's career downturn
and i realize you've said a number of
those so is there anything else sure uh
well
we talked about the erratic behavior the
tardiness the drugs and alcohol abuse
and
the lawsuits have had a really big
impact not just this lawsuit but
previous lawsuits that mr depp has
been involved with because there's a lot
of publicity around anything that he
does
and
every time he has filed a lawsuit it is
brought to light various issues with
respect to whatever that lawsuit was
about whether it was about
you know erratic behavior or domestic
abuse
or drugs and alcohol and even spending
habits so every time a lawsuit has been
filed
the press and the publicity has just
been charged up and brought everything
back to light and it's
it's been an unfortunate
problem for for on that level for the
industry to continue to work with him
even though all this is out in the in
the public
for the films that were shortly before
pirates five how successful were they
we're talking mordecai
alice through the looking glass uh
i think you testified to some of those
the lone ranger tonto
right injection compound
uh
of course mr depp has had some extremely
obviously extremely successful films but
also in the you know the
four or five years prior and you know
through pirates there were films that
didn't do well at all and were
considered what the industry calls a
bomb which could have been
uh alice for the looking glass the
transcendence um
the the lone ranger
uh and mordecai were films that just
didn't perform although they were
valued in their financing based on mr
depp's star quality and acting ability
unfortunately they just didn't perform
so as many hits as he's had he's also
had a lot of recent what they call
failures in the business
and
what if anything did mr depp do with
respect to showing up for a press
conference in japan for mordecai
miss jacobs mentioned in her deposition
testimony that mr depp didn't show up
for the press conference in mordecai
which he was not only an actor for he
was also producer and he didn't show up
apparently he was sleeping so he wasn't
able to make it okay
now
what if any uh
impact did the brooks litigation have on
mr depp's career
is the jury familiar with this already
or
well i i think you could i mean okay so
the brooks litigation was uh
it was um
there was a litigation around uh mr deb
had punched someone on one of the i
think it was a location manager on the
set of a film called city of lies um i i
don't know exactly what happened to that
litigation however of course again it
was written a lot about in the press and
unfortunately came to the forefront that
he had you know violent behavior yet
again
so in
2018 and i'm going to say before the op
ed on december 18 2018 right were there
was there any negative articles negative
press about mr depp
for quite a while when you're a
celebrity such as mr depp you're in the
limelight and everybody wants to look at
everything that happens so
after every movie or eve after every
incident there was usually press but the
the ones that were more significant were
the ones in the hollywood a couple of
them in the hollywood reporter
and uh one of the rolling stones so in
2017
there was an article in the hollywood
reporter
where the journalists discussed i think
the article was called pirates of the
caribbean the diminishing returns of
johnny depp and
that pirates the one with the last one
was five right and that one didn't
perform nearly as well as the other
previous uh pirates of the caribbean
films and there was some discussion that
the character objection hearsay your
honor
i think she could explain generally
that's sustained okay um
let me let me ask you this when was that
hollywood reporter article on
diminishing returns of johnny depp that
was in this spring of 2017. okay and you
said uh and i just want to make sure we
understand how well did pirates five do
compared to one through four it
performed less well by over 200 million
dollars okay
um
what if any other negative press was
there in this time frame we'll take 2017
2018 before the op-ed so in 2018 there
was the rolling stones article that was
an in-depth expose on mr depp's life um
again his erratic behavior
the money he was spending on on why
objection your honor hearsay i i think
she can give generally your honor the
negative state
all right
um
what if any
knowledge do you have of
how whether disney
saw the rolling stone article
there were emails
between
the publicity department and the
co-chairs and some of the senior
executive disney that they would forward
the articles as they came out both the
hollywood reporter article
and the
rolling stones article
and they would make commentary and
alan horn who is the uh one of the
co-chairs of disney used the word sad
and i think one of the other executives
used depressing that their film star was
now being shown in this light to the
public in a rolling stones action
hearsay
sustains all right um
was there any more articles about the
pirates of the caribbean prior to the
op-ed in december of 2018.
there was an article in october 28th uh
the hollywood reporter october 28 2018
where the journalists had spoken to two
writers of the film and they were
talking about objection
she's entitled to rely on hearsay and
she's just giving the general she's not
approached
so without saying what the article said
say what it's about
okay so in october 28th the article was
it was called the article was about
whether the pirates of the caribbean
rebooted
please continue the part where in the
article in october 2018 was about
whether or not the pirates franchise was
going to be what they call reboot you
know redefined without johnny depp and
that was in
regarding two writers that were on the
project okay uh
and there was one other one i'd like
okay go ahead please so there was
another article uh there was an expose
on the president and production it was
also in the hollywood reporter
and this is the one that mr marx mr
depp's expert pointed to
um
regarding the op-ed's impact on mr
depp's career and
the online article was as mr marks
pointed out published on december 20th
of 2018 but the same article was in
print
on the morning of december 18 2018 which
is the same morning of the op-ed so that
hollywood reporter article that mr
marx used to objection no foundation oh
overall please continue
the uh mr marks had used that article to
show that disney
wanted to let go of mr depp because of
the op-ed but it was actually printed in
the reporter the same morning that the
washington post article was printed so
there's no way that the washington post
article had any impact
on what the hollywood reporter
journalist wrote
so they were on the same morning they
were at least simultaneously
interestingly enough
and and the one that was two days later
was the same article just online same
article just online yeah okay thank you
now what if anything was there about
press in 2018 relating to the sun
and dan wooten and any litigation that
mr deputy
so a lot of press was about the uk trial
in the lawsuit that mr deb brought
against the uh the son in the uk about
the wife beater um title that they used
so there was a ton of press around that
both at the time that it was filed and
throughout as documents were being
shared with the public and then of
course during the trial itself okay
and
what is your understanding of when the
fir the article the wife beater article
first appeared
i believe it was in july of 2018 about
six months before the op-ed piece what
is your understanding of when mr depp
filed suit against the sun and mr wooten
again in 2018 i believe okay
june would it be
would that
would would it refresh would it refresh
your life it was in the spring or summer
it was fairly shortly after the article
so it was
long before the op-ed piece was out okay
and what if any impact did mr depp's
litigation in the sun case have on his
career
that was a really tough one on mr deck's
career because everything every
allegation of abuse and every text every
email all the audio all the visual stuff
was brought to light and made public and
so not only did the public get get to
see it but the industry was watching
closely and it's hard for
studios especially a studio like disney
who's family oriented
be connected to a star that has
texts about burnt corpses and violent
behavior in in in video so it was a it
was a big conflict for a lot of the
people in the industry to how to
navigate that if they're going to work
with star
and what if any impacted mr depp's other
litigation against mandel and bloom have
during that time period
as i was trying to say earlier every
time mr depp brings a lawsuit because
he's such a well-known public figure the
spotlight goes on him so every time a
lawsuit was filed whether it was to his
business against his business manager
against his former lawyer even when he
fired his talent agent it becomes news
and then everybody talks about what
could have preceded that why
would that lawsuit have happened and
then they look at the details so again
the erratic behavior and the financial
issues and the uh
drinking and drug abuse was all part and
parcel of every one of those and it was
brought to light yet again each time
what is your understanding of mr depp's
claims regarding pirates of the
caribbean six
and how that impacted
well
mr depp is claiming that he's lost many
on pirate six but pirate six hasn't even
been made yet nor is there even a script
that has been what we call greenlit move
towards production so i don't know how
you lose something that hasn't happened
so
i think that's what you're looking for
me too and in fact since mr depp's
damages are limited november 22 2020 and
nothing since
and that hasn't happened
uh is there any way he could claim
damages for pirate six
objection
overall
again you can't claim damages for
something that hasn't even happened
whether he was in it or not in it or was
going to be in it or might have been in
it whether it was 2018 or now
there just is no pirate six
um not only did he not have a contract
even back in the day
2018 or after that no contract had been
signed for a pirate six
it doesn't exist as we objection legal
conclusion
i
i sustain
at the last part
how do you know he doesn't have a legal
contract
well
miss jacob said he didn't have a legal
contract and also his agents at caa said
he had not
had not yet negotiated a contract for
pirate six
uh and again there is no
script so they haven't greenlit as we
say they don't have have it caster with
the director yet okay
based on your analysis what if any
impact did miss herds op ed have on
whether mr depp uh could claim a loss
for pirate six
zero okay
and why do you say that
again well
many things
the movie doesn't exist yet so that's
one but
even as important is that disney
in their file for this trial did not
have the op-ed piece as part of all of
the information they had read and looked
about and discussed
the uh conversations of mr depp not
being in whatever new version of pirates
the franchise that goes forward those
weren't discussions long before the
op-ed piece even came out
and
uh
there are other factors that disney was
considering the lateness on set
the cost overruns at that cost which can
go from hundreds of thousands of dollars
to millions of dollars when you have
crews sitting around for
two to four hours eight hours or even
several weeks to a month when the finger
incident happened so
on top of that mr depp is an expensive
actor um he can earn between 20 and 25
million dollars per movie plus back end
so it's very expensive so when you put
that all together the rising cost of mr
jeff's talent the challenges that they
had to keep it on budget because of his
lateness and his tardiness and all the
other allegations that would affect a
brand such as disney right
someone talks about a burnt corpse does
not necessarily coincide with the brand
of disney so there were many problems
and interestingly enough
there was a lot of conversation in uh
uh internally in the industry or
something
she's entitled to rely on hearsay your
honor sustain that you can't say it's
hearsay all right um
please
please continue without saying what the
discussion in the industry was
the jack sparrow character had
been
exhausted in terms of where it could go
creatively and i think the studio is
looking for
a way for it to renew the franchise but
not necessarily base it entirely on the
jack sparrow character which is where it
ended up the last couple of years okay
and and evidenced by the the lesser uh
box office of pirates five compared to
the earlier ones
and and
was there any article that came out on
november 5 2020 three days after the
damages are cut off relating to pirates
of the caribbean and mr depp's chances
of being jack sparrow
i think they reiterated the fact that he
was probably not going to be in
the movie okay
now
what impact has the op-ed had on mr
depp's career
very little hardly anybody even knew the
op-ed existed before he filed suit
okay if anybody that i know but
certainly not disney okay
and um
what impact has the op head add on mr
depp's q scores
according to what i read of mr allen
jacobs
an expert in uh
statistical analysis and from my own
research
on websites that are available to us
mr depp's q score or if you're familiar
with imdb which is uh
internet movie database which is
available to public and to the
professional side
his q score did not change
dramatically it was kind of in the
middle of exactly the high and low of
his q scores overall it was in the
middle it was at like 113 which is where
it was a couple weeks before and a
couple weeks after so the op-ed didn't
have any effect
uh on his q score and that was
reiterated by mr jacobs in his
deposition testimony and then you
testified in response to an earlier
question i had that
that people or that nobody seemed to
notice the op-ed until mr depp filed
suit now that was on march 1 2019 do you
recall
yes that's when the lawsuit was filed
and why why do you say that they didn't
notice until then
because the op-ed
piece for most people in the industry
kind of came and went without much
fanfare or much conversation it was much
more about the
i don't think very many people even know
it was written until the allegations
were made by mr depp in the lawsuit
it kind of
came in and out of the radar very
quickly if anybody even saw it at all
all right
between december 18 2018 and november
2020
november 2 2020 our window here has mr
depp continued to star in films
so mr depp so the article came the op-ed
piece came out december
20 18 and 20 of 2018 in december i'm
sorry in january and february of 2019
he shot a film called minamata which was
an independent film that he is what we
call a passion project he loved the
script and wanted to do it so he was
able to film that after the op-ed piece
and then the dior campaign sauvage uh i
don't know the exact dates of filming
but i know that it did air throughout
2019
and uh it's my understanding that he he
still may have that contract with dior
so he continued that product endorsement
and then in uh april or sorry in the
spring
and the fall i believe it was uh mr depp
was able to do press
uh for the film waiting for the
barbarians he went to the dauville film
festival he went to the venice film
festival he was well received at the
press conferences
you know life was at the same level for
him in terms of his popularity over in
europe they were
still uh he was still working on press
for the films and then of course he was
scheduled to film uh fantastic beasts in
in early uh november of 2020
and
that's no longer the case is that
rejection your honor
what's the objection
can we approach okay
and that's no longer the case correct on
fantastic beasts i don't want you to say
anything more than that that's no longer
it's no longer the case correct he's no
longer in that film correct he was paid
for it but he does not star in the film
okay thank you now
what if any effect did the op-ed have on
mr depp's fan following
i don't know if i don't think it had any
effect on his fan following again his q
scores didn't shift and
he
clearly has a strong fan base
in your opinion what or who has caused
the damage if there is any to mr depp
on his career and reputation between
december 18 2018 and november 2 2020.
objection speculation overall
mr depp
and why do you say that
well again
filing the lawsuits bringing to light
the issues is mr depp doing that on his
own accord
uh
and
any statements that were made
uh
by his team mr waldman or anyone else is
associated with mr depp and those
statements that came out the defamatory
statements which we'll talk about in a
minute
uh were also
put out by mr depp's team so
in actuality he's causing his own demise
by bringing these lawsuits forward and
continuing to kind of ignite the fire of
negative publicity around both of them
okay
are all of your opinions to within a
reasonable degree of probability or
certainty
with respect to mr deb's damages yes
okay thank you
now i'm going to move you to
amber herd's damages
with respect to amber herd's claims for
damages on what subject have you been
asked to offer your opinion
so i was asked to look at the
reputational harm and economic loss that
mis
heard incurred due to the defamatory
statements that mr waldman
on behalf of mr depp made in april of
2020 and again in june in
2020 and what materials did you review
in forming your opinions
again many of the same materials that i
reviewed
for mr depp's case which was the
deposition testimony the pleadings the
discovery all of that was included
as well as
expert testimony that was based on
statistical analysis of
negative social media campaigns that
were created
as well as what happened i talked to ms
heard's agents i read their depositions
i talked to her publicist i read her
deposition
i talked to miss hurd herself to get a
first person accounting of what happened
from her perspective after those
defamatory statements were made
and then i looked at the you know again
uh emails back and forth and text back
and forth
with
the studio warner brothers and other
producers that the management team is
working with to get ms heard more work
okay
now before i go into the questions that
i'm going to ask i'm going to go ahead
and just kind of define this so that
that we're all on the same page going
through it we've the jury has seen the
three defamatory statements their
defendants 12 45 1246 a and 1247
um and i'm just going to refer to them
as the dep
waldman statements in asking you all
these questions will you understand what
i'm talking about yes okay good um
please describe amber hurd's career
prior to the publication of the deb
waldman statements
so amber's had a
a long career for someone who is not you
know is fairly young still she was in
over 50 productions
i believe including aquaman and justice
league but let's just say close to 50
productions uh well certainly 50
productions before the uh defamatory
statements were made
she had you know a consistent
working actor's career her agents were
strategic
as she started getting more work that
they wanted her to work with better and
better directors to have you know the
danish danish girl is a film that had a
strong director and a strong critical
acclaim
and then she went from that to getting
justice league which is on the bigger
budget is the bigger scale movie and
then of course aquaman and aquaman two
so her career was following a very nice
steady rise
and she was on the precipice of a
meteoric rise with the you know with
aquaman and aquaman too prior to the
statements
was aquaman a successful film in terms
of box office sales
aquaman was an extremely successful film
it made over a billion dollars and i
believe it is the
highest grossing dc
comic film ever
now
what if any
accolades did amber receive for her role
in aquaman and i'm gonna call it
sometimes i'll call it aquaman one just
to make sure we don't get confused right
so in aquaman one there were many emails
from the director
and the producer and objection hearsay
she's just characterizing your owner
she's not quoting them
well i don't know where it's going i'll
overrule at the moment thank you
she got
emails from the director and the
producer
stating that they'd love to perform
anywhere
you can't say what the emails say but
you can summarize them or characterize
them can you do that accolading emails
emails of accolade from her uh from the
director and the producers objection
hearsay overruled
thank you
okay
um
what type of press opportunities did
amber have prior to the debt baldwin
statements
so the the press really
loved working with amber she was on the
cover of many magazines after the danish
girl after justice league after aquaman
she was the cover girl
i think it was of um marie claire or l
in in the uk
she had a cover story of a big magazine
in mexico in australia they were you
know some magazine one magazine called
her woman of the year another one called
her role model of the year so she got a
lot of press
you know she did a lot of press both in
magazines but also on the press tours
and the press junkets that she did for
the films
and and were some of those california
style marie claire l
and there was a lot of them so i mean
you know don't remember all of them but
it was you know gql marie claire you
know the big magazines both here the uk
um east europe eastern europe in latin
america and in australia and what about
after the release of aquaman
which was december 2018
how was her press then
well the press tour was doing well and
they wanted to give her a lot more press
and i think up until the defamatory
statements came out she was on deck to
do a lot of press
and then
objection no foundation overrule
please continue so the press and the
request for press went silent after the
defamatory statements were made and
which then the negative social media
campaign ensued after that
now
what factors relating to social media
does the enter entertainment industry
rely on when considering an actor for a
role
social media becomes a big part of how
studios decide to use an actor and
actress in a film because they want to
know how the general public feels about
them they want to know what the consumer
feels about that actor so when there's
positive social media that's a good
thing for the actor when there's
negative social media it can be
very bad because not only can social
media be directed at the actor or the
actors themselves but it can also be
directed towards
the movie towards the movie company
towards the product that the actor actor
is working with so it becomes very
complicated and it can get very messy
to continue working with an actor or an
actress if there's a lot of negative
social media around them okay
and after the deb waldman statements
what happened on social media
after the deb wellman statement social
media blew up with negative tweets and
instagram posts and you know facebook
posts and snapchat and trolling as we
call it it was just negative
uh according to mr schnell there was
over 1.2 million negative tweets about
amber using
hashtags that use the words and the
statement of the deb wald statements
uh
deb waldman statements excuse me um
that 1.2 million negative statements
between
april of 2020 and november or january of
21.
it's a lot of negative publicity and it
and there was just a lot of what we call
noise
around um misheard and her work of any
kind can you please describe to the jury
what negative what a negative social
campaign is
so
a negative social campaign would be when
a a
fan base or in this case according to
both
the forensic statistical analyst as well
as ms heard's agents and pro the product
that she was working with l'oreal and
her publicist it was a campaign that
included both
live
uh
accounts live twitter you know people
that actually have our individuals as
well as what we call objection
maybe heard all right
all right
other than the bots please describe the
rest of the social media the negative
social media comm campaign
the fan base was very energized by
mr is it
the depth wall
yeah let me let me just step waldman i'm
i'm i'm sorry i got a lot of my brain
right now that doesn't matter why don't
i do this let me formulate a different
question how has the negative social
media campaign been used against amber
heard since the debt waldman statements
great so the negative campaign has been
used both to
you know let's fire amber off of aquaman
to
the product that she was had an
endorsement contract with with l'oreal
the makeup and every time that l'oreal
mentioned amber heard and the product
together they would get harassed her
publicist company was harassed
any kind of movie that she was related
to or television project that she was
related to got negative attention from
the social media world even the uh
the charities that she was involved with
were getting
hammered if you will or bombarded by
negative social media which made it
difficult to work with amber on any
level because negativity was brought to
their product service or
uh film
okay and
is that negative social media campaign
ongoing to this day
yes okay and you were talking a little
bit before i think about uh
remove amber heard from aquaman two what
were your observations with respect to
that in connection to the waldman depths
the depth waldman statements
again the the statements i'm sorry the
social media campaign whether called you
know remove amber from aquaman or you
know
negativity for her relationship in that
film
it always tended to use words that were
inside the defamatory statements they
became hashtags right so
you know if it was said in this in the
in the defamatory statement they were
often reiterated in the tweets and the
posts okay
how difficult is it for an actor to
repair this type of negative social
media
well first of all has to stop
okay so once it stops then an actor and
their team
can work slowly and patiently
in both
maybe its press interviews maybe its
relationship with charity maybe it's a
small role in a movie and they do well
and they they kind of rebuild their
career but it can take
two three four five years or more to
rehabilitate your career but first and
foremost it needs to stop
you know it just needs to stop so that
they can
the consumer can get beyond it and then
they can reactivate their career
by doing their work again
describe amber heard's reputation after
the deb waldman statements
well the reputation i guess depends on
who who you're talking to but in the
public it's been very negative
um in the industry they like her work
but it's very they can't work with her
right now again because every time her
name is mentioned the negativity flares
up again so it doesn't make sense for
them to try to make a movie which costs
millions of dollars and then have a lot
of negativity towards the film or the tv
show or the product so her world has
been
silent in terms of opportunities and
even things that
that she wanted to work on are no longer
available to her
has ever been able to obtain roles after
the deb waldman statements
for a long time no very recently she was
able to do a small independent film
um
from some people out of um who get their
financing out of europe
but up until that no she has not worked
now
based on the fact that amber came out of
aquaman
what should her opportunity what would
you have expected
following the release of aquaman
december 2018
uh up to what's going on now
i like to call aquaman really
you know amber heard star stars born
moment it was that moment where not only
was she a good actor but she was now
world renowned because she was in the
most successful film
almost of all time if not all time and
certainly for dc comics she was on the
poster with the very handsome jason
momoa and they were this couple and she
was strong and beautiful and it was just
this extraordinary moment for her for
her career to take off right
you know her agents were excited the
producers were excited uh everybody just
wanted to hit the ground running and
let's do more let's do more work
what if anything happened to amber's
participation in aquaman 2
so for a moment in time in february 2021
there were conversations that amber's
i'm gonna be technical with you her
option for employment was not going to
be exercised so they may not have hired
her again even though she had a contract
for it there was some question as to
whether she was going to be hired again
on aquaman two
all right and did ultimately then she
still get hired for aquaman too
she did her management team fought very
hard and they ultimately ended up hiring
her but also not only because of what
her management team did but jason mamoa
the star and james wong the director
committed to her in an email saying if
we are involved in this movie objection
no foundation hearsay no sustain don't
say what the email said just
summarize it or describe it okay i'm
sorry i'm just trying to understand this
world um
so
her management team worked hard
and jason mamoa and the director
were adamant that she was in the
objection here
she has to be able to say that what
sustain is to hear say
next question so
what if any uh assurances did
mr momoa and mr juan give amber
that she would be an aquaman too
objection hearsay sustained
uh
what if any uh are you aware of any
chemistry issues uh between amber and
jason mamoa from aquaman
according to the fact that they did a
chemistry test with miss heard misheard
and jason mamoa in order for it to be
hired that is a good indication that
they thought the two of them had good
chemistry
obviously when you look at the movie
they have good chemistry and the poster
they have good chemistry so i think it's
general awareness that they had great
chemistry
all right and what if anything uh
would also suggest uh with respect to
aquaman two
uh that jason momoa believed they had
good chemistry
he wanted her in the movie okay
i think she she has to be able to rely
on sustained
i'll strike it from the record
uh in your review of all of the record
evidence what if anything did you say
see in writing anywhere that there was
ever any chemistry or creative issue
with amber hurd and jason momoa from
aquaman won
there were no communications whatsoever
that there was no chemistry between the
two and and what if anything did you in
all the record evidence did you see
that the producer or jason momoa did not
want amber heard in aquaman two
i did not see any evidence of that okay
in fact the opposite correct correct
again
i overruled thank you your honor
now what if any leverage did amber heard
have to renegotiate her salary under the
circumstances of
the discussions you were talking about
with not exercising her option
she had zero leverage she was fighting
for her life to stay in the film okay
now
is it typical for an actor to be able to
negotiate an increase in their salary
after a successful franchise
so you may know this already and so i
apologize if you've heard it before i
don't know what's been brought to your
attention but in a franchise such as
potential franchises justice league and
aquaman
the
customs and practice is that the
studio will make a
an agreement with the actor that
incorporates potential future films so
if justice league does well they want to
know what they're going to pay the actor
for the next one and the next one and
the next one and in those
successive terms in the contract
the
fee for that actor
customarily goes up it can go up by 10
20 100
you could double
what have you
and
in the case as um uh miss uh kovacevic
stated in her testimony
that
in a successful franchise that a movie
that's made a billion dollars the actors
agents will go back and try to
renegotiate that upcoming price tag so
if it was going to be x they might want
it to be 2x or 3x and that's very
standard in the industry to renegotiate
your contracts when there's
many films in one single contract that
each have their own price points
what if any other actors in aquaman one
were able to renegotiate their contracts
uh jason moa we could negotiate his
contract very significantly from aquaman
one tackleman too do you know roughly
how much more uh it went up from the you
know let's somewhere between three and
four million to 15 million
did amber have a contract for aquaman
one
yes how much was she paid for aquaman
one aquaman won she was paid two million
dollars okay and if
and did that same contract uh provide
for if she was in aquaman two
i'm sorry i apologize aquaman one i
believe she got one million dollars
aquaman two she was supposed to get two
million dollars i apologize the numbers
there were a lot of numbers in that one
contract so aquaman won it was one
million all command two is gonna be two
million
all right now based on your experience
uh and knowledge in the industry
how much would amber hurt have been able
to negotiate
her contract but for the deb waldman
statements
for aquaman too i'm asking right well as
you can see from mr mimo's contract that
went up exponentially up to 15 million
dollars
misheard i don't know if she would have
gotten 15 million dollars for the movie
but she certainly could have increased
it by one or two million dollars or even
doubled it so if it was two it could
have been four
or even five or six depending on the
enthusiasm if had it just rolled from
aquaman juan to auckland to without any
of this
negativity that was created by the
walmart the deb waldman statements
what if anything happened to amber's
role in aquaman 2 after the depth
waldman statements
it was diminished
now why would amber have been featured
more prominently in aquaman too
objection no foundation
it's only a foundation okay
um
what usually determines or uh
are you able to
speak to
whether amber should have been or would
have been more prominently featured in
aquaman too
well a couple of things
i'm trying to get your foundation are
you able to speak to that
yes okay
and
please tell the basis of that and then
your opinion
so there's two things when two actors do
well in a romantic relationship and you
know they get married or they're gonna
have a baby you know you want to follow
that through because part of what did
well in aquaman was not know the action
sequences but to have a strong female
character
having a relationship with a strong male
character it's very empowering right so
that was working for them in the first
place the poster of aquaman that went
around the world was
one of the main posters was of the two
of them together standing proud and
strong right being that couple and so
naturally as you go and develop scripts
in the industry you want to follow on
the things that are working and
according to miss heard when she read
the first script for aquaman 2 she had a
strong romantic arc of the entire film
and then she also got to do some great
action sequences at the end of that
storyline and that script so she was
featured predominantly throughout the
script of aquaman 2 when she first read
it
and then what happened
well she didn't hear anything so she
wasn't getting the scripts whenever when
her colleagues were getting the scripts
she heard that through her agents and
then when she got the script um
it was pared down from the first script
dramatically they had her in the
hospital very shortly in the in the
first part of the movie called act one
they had her in the hospital and they
pretty much had her in the hospital and
then she was going to do this
action sequence in the end she trained
five hours a day for several months for
the trainer to do this big action
sequence and then when she got to set
two things happened one the costume
designer said i don't know what happened
to your role it got
diminished objection hearsay sustained
greater the second thing
more importantly though this big action
sequence that she was gonna do in at the
end of the movie and the third act was
cut out
and they took it away from her so it was
radically reduced from what it was in
the script and what she even trained for
uh while she was preparing for the movie
and what if any changes were made to the
storyline
i haven't seen the movie yet
specifically so i can't really speak to
that yet all right and when you say she
was in the hospital what do you mean by
was she injured in the first scene i
believe that in the in the first act of
the movie she was injured somehow or has
something to do with the baby i don't
know exactly i'm just going with what
miss her told me about was that she ends
up in in the hospital early in this new
aquaman 2 movie it doesn't really come
out until the end to kind of wrap things
up but all of the interactions with you
know mimo's character
and the certainly the action scenes were
taken out okay
how has amber typically been involved in
promotions for her films
as we talked about earlier actively
involved in the press and the promotion
whether that was on the press junkets
what we call when they tour the world
and they and the actors tour together
and and answer questions from the press
at various screenings and film festivals
and then also she was you know on a
cover of magazines usually after her
movies especially after justice league
and how was the promotion of aquaman 2
affected by the dep waldman statements
amber has not been involved in any of
the promotion that's been done to date
or very little particularly in a teasers
that i've seen we call you know short
little films about the making of and so
forth she's not featured in them and
also very specifically there was a big
event that warner brothers um put on
during the fandom i think it's a dc
fandom event which is a big kind of like
comic-con style event and they invited
all of the actors of the majority of the
actors that have strong roles in film to
participate both in the posters and the
artwork and also participate at at dc
fandom and ms heard was not invited to
either be in the poster or be at the
event and in fact they told her she
cannot come
now can can this hurt amber's career not
being allowed to be in any of the
promotional materials
absolutely i it means that nobody knows
about her she doesn't have the same part
in the film it's not going to take her
on to her next movie
she's not being associated with the
tremendous amount of promotion that's
going to be made for this
you know
movie that everybody's looking forward
to see so she's not a part of it because
of this negative campaign
how have the depth waldman statements
affected any other films or tv project
promotions for amber
so uh
prior to the defamatory statements but
either around it you know after or
around the time that aquaman won
came out she was in the tv show called
the stand it was based on a stephen king
novel so
big book
you know going to be a big tv show
and again uh mr didn't do any press or
promotion for that for the same reasons
and what if any plans were there to have
amber heard on that cover of l.a style
of relating to stan before the dev
baldwin statements
right so ms heard was in and uh they had
done an article about her participation
in this tv show the stand the stephen
king novel uh related uh tv show and
they were gonna give her the cover
picture and cover story and they took
that away i don't know if they've even
if the article existed but they
certainly took away the cover picture in
the cover story okay how have the deb
waldman statements affected press
requests for amber
there aren't any
so so yes they affected it because there
used to be a lot of press requests and
now there are aren't any
has ever heard obtained any roles since
the deaf worldwide statement
again
for many years now for a good period of
time a year and a half two years until
she got this small movie called the
indepen into the fire
has ever obtained any studio movie roles
since the depth waldman statements
now
how if at all have amber's philanthropic
opportunities been affected by debt
worldwide statements
again she had some passion projects she
was invited to do some charity work and
she also had her own passion projects
that she you know loved and wanted to be
involved with and even travel for uh but
they decided it wasn't going to be a
good idea because every time she appears
anywhere the social media negativity cam
you know campaign starts up again so she
hasn't been able to do any for charity
work
what is an endorsement
so an endorsement is when an actor
associates themselves with a product
either for
print promotion or commercials you know
like
jennifer aniston doing the water you
know or
uh matt mcconaughey doing the car
commercial that's a product endorsement
he's paid to say that the product is
good and be associated with the product
how how important are those endorsements
to the actors in the entertainment
industry
well very very important on two levels
one they
bring a good amount of income to them
when they're not shooting a movie so
it's a good way to make money in between
film roles and then also
it shows the studios and the production
executives and the financiers that the
actor is relevant in the community
because they're being associated with a
product so if it's a well-known product
that's really great if it's a medium
product that's great and so forth and so
on so you want to be if you can and if
that's something that you like to do not
everybody does but if they like to do
that then they can get a lot of um value
out of those product endorsements
because then the studio see that there's
a connection with the consumer not just
on the film but also with product did
amber have any endorsement activities
prior to the publication of the dep
waldman statements
yes
please explain
so amber was hired by uh l'oreal to be a
product and
endorsed their product the makeup line
and she had a 1.5 million contract for
two years
um and they were able to
uh work they had 20 days of her work you
know they had the right to to work with
her for 20 days
and she started the work and then when
the defamatory statements came out they
essentially put a pause on working with
her so they no longer brought her to
photo shoots they no longer had her do
public events for the product and
basically said we love you but we can't
work with you right now because it's
just objection hearsay all right i
i'll sustain the objection okay question
um
have mr have the default statements
affected that deal in any way
with l'oreal well a they put it on pause
and haven't done any of the work so
she's not out there in the public eye
related to the product and they uh have
decided to continue working with her at
some point once as i said this all
quiets down this trial is over and
hopefully the negative campaigns will
stop uh so they extended her contract
but they did not pay her for that
extension
and has ever been hired for any other
endorsement deals since the deb waldman
statements
no
now did you assess amber's losses as a
result of the deb waldman statements
yes what did you do to assess those well
first of all i looked at amber's career
directly so i wanted to see you know as
i said earlier she worked consistently
and then she was on this kind of
very large upswing with the big movies
justice league and aquaman and and all
of that in the stand with the stephen
king project
um and then it stopped
right so her work
stopped and then i looked at other
actors that kind of grew up at the same
time frame grew up meaning
they started their career and had the
same time frame to start going from the
smaller projects to the well-known
director projects to the big movie
projects and i looked at those actors
and i then saw after they had their
stars for a moment if you will i wanted
to see where their careers went so i
looked at several actors to see
including jason momoa
her co-star to see what happened in
their careers after such a successful
film as aquaman
came out why did you use that method of
analysis it's a very common methodology
in the entertainment industry to work
with what we call comps i think miss
vacherville to even use that word comp
um for say you you know with films you
try to find comparable films with actors
you look to see comparable actors so you
can kind of it's not a distinct actual
this is going to happen but this is the
probability with a reasonable certainty
that with the right management team that
she had and her acting ability and her
looks and the press that she was getting
and should have continued to get that
her career would have been similar to
these other actors
have you used that method in other cases
in which you've been an expert on
damages yes and
who did you select as comparable actors
for your comparison
well i wanted to look at actors that
were in superhero films that had done
really well at the box office so i i
looked at jason lamoa her co-star i
looked at gal gadot who was is in wonder
woman
i looked at
anna de armas who was in
[Music]
blade runner thank you blade runner
i looked at zendaya who was in spiderman
and i looked at chris pine who was in
star trek and also wonder woman about
the you know similar age range
all attractive actors all with good
acting skills all able to do stunts so i
was it's not they're not that many
actors to look at who do super hero
characters so it was a small pool to
work from but i took a wide range from
those actors both men and women to see
what was what could potentially happen
to mrs hurd's career do you consider all
of them to be identical for purposes of
measurement well absolutely not i mean
no two actors are identical you can only
look with that within a range of
characteristics and
uh work history management team and so
forth
and we've heard from mr banya uh did you
review mr banya's q score analysis
regarding the comparables you used yes i
did and what if any opinions have you
formed and reviewing mr banya's analysis
regarding the comparables you selected
so mr bandy looked at
calendar years to assess so what
happened in december of you know 2017 or
18 or 19 what happened in june what
happened in a very specific time frame
which works on some statistical analysis
but when you're talking about actors and
their relationships to q scores q scores
are related to the actors viability in
the consumer's
mind if you will how well known or how
much they're coming up in conversation
and so mr benny did not look at time
periods of the actors that i compare
them with to the film when it came out
so like right after the success of their
big film what was their q score but
moreover he just
looked at them in a year range so
it doesn't coincide from actor to actor
just because you look at it over time
you have to look at it specifically
after each of those
individuals
box office success with a particular
film you look at the q score higher low
during that and then you look at how low
it drops
say a couple months afterwards and then
if it comes back up if they have another
film or another event that brings them
into the the
limelight again so it's not about time
it's a related to a specific activity or
event and he did not do that okay what
did your comparison show in terms of
films that those actors had been in
since their breakout roles
i'm talking about the comparables
in terms of their
i'm not quite sure i understand uh
well
what
what happened with these other actors
after they had their s
so unrelated to q scores right right
okay sorry so all those actors careers
the ones i mentioned they all either
were a steady rise or even a meteoric
rise in in terms of where their career
went after their stars born moment then
they got some other good films and maybe
they got another film that performed
extremely well so it was a range but
they all were on an upward trajectory
without a doubt
and what does this mean for amber
with a reason i mean the way that the
the kind of industry works is usually
unless there is an uh force measure or
some really negative event
her career should have followed that
same upward swing and in about the same
time frame it give or take six months to
a year
but you it would be very reasonable to
to believe that her career would have
been on an upward trajectory
within the range
of those other actors what if any
comparisons did you make respecting
endorsement deals of these actors with
amber
you know again all those actors that
we've talked about all did multiple
endorsement deals after their big movies
or after their big series of movies you
know jason mamoa is on you know rocket
mortgage and harley-davidson as well as
you know five or six other companies
zendaya is lancome and fashion and water
and jewelry and gal gadot and chris pine
and and and and and hamas they've all
done either a couple or many and all of
them have associated with a large brand
uh unlike amber who hasn't done even
been able to work on the one contract
that she had she certainly didn't get
any others
so what did your analysis show with
respect to amber heard's losses but for
the deb waldman statements
they were significant
if if we follow the trajectory of her
you know colleagues but let's start with
at aquaman two
what would she have realized there
well as i stated earlier so um
from aquaman one to two it went from a
million dollars to two million dollars
right so that was a pre-written contract
it doubled so the agents
were very excited after the success of
aquaman to go and negotiate a much
higher
uh fee like they did for jason mamoa
they weren't able to do that so in that
instance alone it was more than likely a
two million dollar loss just from that
movie alone
so two to four you'd said before it
could have been foreign
okay um what about other films
so once as as amber's agent
okay
i was doing okay uh mr
said that once you get that quote of the
two million dollars from aquaman 2 that
kind of was like the baseline for any
other movie she would have done so any
other studio movie would have started
from there and depending on
the success of aquaman and how much
press she did maybe she worked on
another
great director independent film whatever
that two million dollars for a studio
film
and had it jumped to four million uh
with the renegotiation that then would
have been the basis so any future studio
film
uh
that she would have done any big budget
film would have been the basis at four
million and then most likely have gone
up from there if she was able to get
others which she should have just like
the other actors
let's talk about tv for a minute what
would those losses have included
well on the stand which was you know
about the same time as aquaman but got
the press and the promotion got cut off
because of the defamatory statements of
the negative campaign she got paid 200
000 an episode on the stand so on a tv
series of nine episodes
it's 1.8 million dollars so if she had
again done other tv shows it's very
likely that whether she worked with a
streamer or with one of the networks
that that fee would have gone up from
there her agents would have been able to
use the leverage of the success of
aquaman 2
to put her if she had done another
television show
given rise to even a higher episodic fee
some actors go up to one million dollars
an episode jason the mo is uh in the in
his tv show got one million dollars so
there's a you know an exponential range
of where she could have gone
all right what about endorsements
same thing you know all the other actors
were doing
over the course of a couple years period
you know anywhere from
five six seven other endorsement deals
and misheard
realistically
should have gotten endorsement deals and
other categories l'oreal is makeup so
probably not in makeup but maybe water
or clothing or jewelry or
wellness or it could have been anything
else and so she too should have
with a reasonable degree of certainty
gotten other contract deals based on the
success of the films that she's been
associated with and the tv shows she's
been what would that have translated
into in terms of so in terms of dollars
okay so if it was 1.5 million dollars
for l'oreal for a two-year contract
and let's give her four other 1.5 or 2
million dollar deals which all those
other actors you know especially the
ladies have gotten
then you're looking at an additional
eight million dollars of income over
time i'm not saying this is in one
period we're looking at as far back as
the defamatory statements of 2020 to now
which is almost two years and again as i
said earlier even when this is quiet it
will take three to five years for her to
rehabilitate her career if she can
so we have to look at it as a period of
a minimum of five years so when i say
eight million dollars for endorsement
contracts it would have been over time
okay
uh what if any losses relating to
production or film activities
well again
these other actors that we looked at and
there's a wide range of them some of
them did bigger films and some of them
did gigantic films but
it is very reasonable to assume that
once you are in
an aquaman style film you'll either
continue to do those right some of these
franchises as we know go four five six
films or she would probably have been in
another studio film that had nothing to
do with aquaman but again
so over the course of five years it's
very reasonable to consider that she
would have been in at least one film a
year
at a minimum of four million dollars
because that's
what her president would have been had
she renegotiated and it's important to
note that in her inner justice league
contract
had their if there is a aquaman
three
her price is set at four million dollars
so it's very reasonable to assume
and to believe
that
if she did a film a year
for five years at a minimum of four
million dollars a year without any
negotiation which probably would have
happened but let's just say that
baseline that would be another 20
million dollars over that time frame
what if any opinions do you have about
amber heard's earning power over time
that it would continue to rise it's it's
customary in the industry as i've talked
about earlier that the negotiations um
especially with her agents at william
morris her fees would have gone higher
so i'm just using the baseline without
any ability to foresee in the future but
i already know she got negotiated for
four million dollars from aquaman three
so for we use that as a baseline
minimum but it very well would have gone
up had her agents done the work that
they wanted to do
so combining all of these opinions and
calculations that you've had what if any
range are the losses you are estimating
for amber heard but for the deb waldman
statements
right so again it's really important
that i looked at and hopefully you
understand this that it's over time
right so let's just say a minimum of
five years that we're going to talk
about these losses and it could be more
but at minimum if you look at the
film
the television
and the endorsement contracts
it's very likely that ms heard should
have earned between 45 and 50 million
dollars over that time period
all right
are all your opinions to within a
reasonable degree of probability or
certainty
yes all right thank you very much all
right let's go ahead and take our
afternoon recess ladies and gentlemen do
not do any outside research and do not
discuss this case with anybody
yeah you can see you can step down
that's fine i'm sorry
no that's okay that's all right i
appreciate it ma'am
this reminder court is still in session
please
all right so let's come back at four
o'clock we can do that all right thank
you
um
right
okay sure while we do that can we have
the witness take this
your sound mixer
excuse me you're a sound mixer yes
all right ready for jury
do i stand
it's up to you
so
so
all right you can be seated all right
cross-examination
good afternoon miss arnold hello how are
you
so you've repeatedly testified about
what
you were asked as the dep waldman
statements
miss you don't have any knowledge
whether mr depp
knew of the statements that mr waldman
made do you only with association with
mr weldman correct
you don't know when the first time mr
depp learned about those statements
i don't know no
and the association you're talking about
is that mr waldman worked from time to
time as mr depp's attorney correct
connection your honor may we approach
okay
all right i understand that you're uh
testifying as a damages expert and we're
two hats
talking both about mr depp's damages and
about
uh miss herd's purported damages
um
let's talk about mrs hur miss herd's
damages first
you understand
that
you have to testify as to damages
that resulted from the waldman
statements correct
that was my analysis
most of your testimony however was just
simply testimony about things that
occurred after the waldman statements
that's what i was tasked with yes
the mere fact that
the mere fact that there were activities
after the waldman statements
doesn't establish
that the waldman statements
caused any damages does it
when you look at the time frame of when
the waldman statements came out and you
look at what was going on with ms
heard's career prior to the statements
and what happened after the statements
it's very clear to make that correlation
that they were caused by those
statements and the campaign that
followed afterwards in terms of the
negative social media well eric that's
an interesting thing because the witness
this morning
actually described the the uh
the notion of what's correlation and
what's causation
and
correlation does not imply causation
does it man
i'm not an expert in semantics
okay
but you're an expert who is purporting
to say that i misheard lost between 45
and 50 million dollars and i'm trying to
understand
where you
put the link
between the waldman statements and
all the other activity that occurred
since then
as i stated and very clearly wanted to
make sure that that everybody understood
was that it was a time frame under you
know between which the waldman
statements were made
and the negative decline in her career
started happening and and
in discussions with her agents and her
publicist there was a very tight
timeline and a very close link to when
those statements came out and when
everything started pulling away from his
heart
right but the what you're talking about
is it is just
a link in time you do not
put any causal connection between what
mr waldman purportedly said
and the damages that that misheard
purportedly suffered you have no idea
whether mr waldman's statements
caused any damage to misheard do you
well actually
both the words in the statements were
used as hashtags in the campaign
as well as when the statistical and the
investigative analysis was done
on the social media campaign it turned
out that one in four of the statements
were had wald
men or waldminion in them so that was
another connection that i was able to
make between the defamatory statements
and these negative negativity that the
studios and the product endorsements and
the television and the press connected
as well all right let's start with first
principles if they're true they're not
defamatory correct
again that's outside the scope of my
expertise
all right
let's then go back to what you just
testified to and i think you said the
waldman statements appeared in hashtags
i said words from the waldman statements
appeared in hashtags right and the
hashtags that were analyzed however
don't have the waldman statements
in the hashtag
i've also seen them online myself
well but the the analysis that mr uh
still did
he looked at four right
that was schnell's analysis and i do
believe i remember reading that yes all
right and the 25 that you just raised
that's mr schnell's analysis you didn't
do that he did it correct all right so
you know what mr schnell did
and he didn't look
at hashtags that contained the waldman
statement words he looked at justice for
johnny depp right
that's one of them yes
one of them
of the 1.2 million hits that we that you
talked about
that was
hundred and 900
four thousand
well also in my conversations with mr
shnow we talked about all the words that
were in the statement that also appeared
so what he wrote in his port and what i
had in my conversation may not have been
the same thing ma'am i don't want to
hear about conversation with mr schnell
it's part of what i relied on and i'm
allowed to talk about that all right so
your conversation
uh with mr schnell let's move beyond
that let's talk about
what the other hashtags were
amber hurd is an abuser that's not in
the waldman statement is it
the fact that she was called the hoax
can be related to amber abuser but no
those words were not used correct right
and
we don't we just don't like amber that's
not the waldman statement
correct
and amber turd is not in the waldman
statement
correct right none of those things are
and in terms of the use of the words
fraud and hoax
that appeared in only
six and a half percent
of the uh millions
of
of uh tweets that mr schnell analyzed
right
i don't have the definition or is the
report in front of me but we can look at
it together if you'd like to right
and uh and you said waldman appears in
25 percent waldman or walt minion
according to mr show yes all right
but you st
if that's your only evidence however
that
any of this activity
has any link
to mr waldman
is that correct
well no we also look at the timeline
because those those campaigns were not
active prior to the weldment statements
and then they started appearing so
there's some connectivity there as well
mr depp bears no responsibility for for
the social media campaigns he doesn't
if the social media campaigns caused
misheard to lose her
ability to
generate income that's not the waldman
statement that's a social media case i'm
going to object your honor may we
approach okay
all right so i'm i'm just looking for
all evidence
of the causal connection that you claim
exists
between
the 45 million dollars in damages that
you assert
and the three statements made my
made by mr waldman
well you also wanted i also looked at
ms heard's career
after
the divorce proceedings and other
lawsuits that she was either involved
with or was discussed and her career
might have had a pause but she was able
to overcome that when she did aquaman
and she did the stand both very
prominent productions
and
there was no dramatic downturn in her
career after any publicity name i don't
mean to interrupt you but do you have
notes with you
no i there's dust oh okay it's just dust
and i'm just
distracting myself but i guess i'm sorry
it's just
nerves it's really just that i just yeah
that's okay dust sorry so you looked at
her career but
and you looked at the way her career was
moving right so as i was saying her
career was moving forward and even she
had been able to overcome the negative
publicity uh surrounding the divorce or
the initial filing of the uk lawsuit and
the other lawsuits anything that she was
associated she overcame that
she did justice league and she did
aquaman and she did the stand and she
got the l'oreal contract all after that
the only time her career slowed down and
stopped
was at the same time that those
defamatory statements came out so
but there was a lot of other activity
that happened following the defamatory
statements you said every time mr
depp files a lawsuit
it ignites the fire around the both of
them right no i actually said it it
ignites the fire mostly around mr depp
that was in contact excuse me please i'm
sorry that was in context of when i was
asked about mr depp's career i was not
in context of when i was asked about
miss heard's career
it's not the same fire
it isn't isn't who's the protagonist in
the case in the uk was mr depp ms heard
was a witness to that case she was not a
part of the case so most of the negative
press went there was enormous amounts of
negative activity around ms heard as a
result of the uk case isn't that true
there was negativity yes about it
remember them in the case yes right
substantial amounts of negativity
right
and
so you can't tell me
that that negativity isn't the thing
that keeps your or misheard from
working well again it was a close time
frame the negative statements for a much
closer time frame to the press and
publicity around aquaman and the stand
than the uk case which was months later
so again i will look at the defamatory
statements is kind of the igniting force
and it was promoted and and kind of more
oxygen was uh
put on the fire when the uk's came out
so it kind of became a snowball effect
of you know the match was lit and it
kept getting stronger and stronger right
but but ms heard isn't claiming a causal
connection between the uk case in her
damages right
yeah
all right and you can't distinguish
between
the uk
bad
publicity
and the
bad publicity that derived after the
waldman statements what time frame are
you talking about with the bad publicity
from the uk so we can at least be
specific on time frames well you talked
about a five-year time window
a five-year time window from 2020 to the
two years that we're at now plus the
three years moving forward is what i
talked about in terms of the time frame
that it would take someone who's been
under this much duress to kind of
rehabilitate their career that's when we
talked about the five years right that's
when you talked about the five years so
you look over this five year window
and during the period that precedes this
window there's
lots and lots of negative press about
misheard
irrespective
of the waldman statements correct before
the weldment statements as i said she
was able to overcome that and she got
great jobs and was getting endorsement
contracts
right but after the waldman statements
there is more
activity
in the press there's more social media
activity
and you cannot put a causal connection
between
that activity and what mr waldman said
it can be the instigating event if you
want me to call it that we'll call the
waldman statements the instigating event
of a torrential reign of social media
tactics that went on has gone on for
years yeah
the instigating event
and and therefore
you your damage analysis with a degree
some degree i guess
of reasonable certainty is that once
there's an insta instigating event
um everything that happens thereafter
is fair game for damages
well it's like a fire if one tree burns
and then more air or wind is added to it
then the next three burns and the whole
forest burns but if that first fire
hadn't started with the one tree there
would have been no loss of acreage so
you can look at it with that same
analogy
trees burn one at a time don't they man
you know i'm not a firefighter i'm not
gonna go there with you but obviously we
know that a single match can cause
thousands of acres to burn so
we can leave it at that
i think i went there with you
is there a single one who has had
any press
suggesting that they defecated in the
marital bed
i don't know
i have no idea
you would agree with me
that that is a negative
influence
with respect to hollywood
if one believed it yes
if one believed it
you know it was reported
it it certainly has been discussed we
don't have any proof or video of of
anybody defecating on the bed
i certainly do not have proof or i mean
a video of anybody defecating in a bed
i'll give you that that's a good thing
yeah
so
but what you
what you know is that mr waldman didn't
say anything about defecating in a bed
correct right so
all of the bad publicity around that
activity
has nothing to do with waldman right
waldman as you said didn't talk about
defecation okay
and you haven't considered
how that
story
has
adversely impacted ms heard's career
that story you're gonna ask me for a
causational link between that poop story
and her demise of her career i can't no
i'm not gonna do that nor can i
you couldn't do it
can i make it no i can't
and you can't do it with waldman
statements either can you
well again i did and i have and i stand
by them so
you you did by just pointing out the
time frames are relatively close
the time frame and the instigation and
and if you will the rallying of the
forces again
it's like a lit tree it's gonna ignite
everything it's like free game
afterwards so it was the instigating
event if you will it you know and that's
what i looked at yes
all right so
from your perspective
anything that happened after waldman
that was negative to your client
is attributable to waldman and therefore
attributable to the damage analysis you
made i was tasked with looking at that
specifically and that's what i was asked
to limit it to i was not asked to look
at anything else
all right
um
jason momoa
that's one of your comparables right
yes
he's been
prominent since 1999.
he was in baywatch in 99
44 episodes on baywatch do you know that
you can look it up if you did i i'll
i'll go with that right
but you remember my maywatch
actually didn't watch baywatch but he
certainly had the physique for it so
stargate
atlantis
he was on that
many episodes
right
did you know that
yes okay
he played conan the barbarian
in tv or film film okay
i don't i don't have mr mamoa's uh
resume memorized so
no i'm just trying to understand how you
came to the conclusion they're they're
comparable because i'm just want to
spend a few times a few minutes talking
about mr momoa's career
um
game of thrones was one of the most
popular things on tv
for a period of three years correct yes
he was and he was in game of thrones yes
he was yep
and
he's aquaman right
yes he is right he's the title character
in aquaman
yes yeah and he was
actually aquaman in a movie
before
the aquaman movie started
you mean justice league and other things
like that yeah
batman versus superman
dawn of justice what wasn't he in that
as aquaman i didn't see that one didn't
see it no
miss heard wasn't in that movie was she
not that i know of now no
and he was in both justice league movies
correct yeah
uh
and he's in aquaman two
yes
they used him in the second lego movie
right yes
um
he's one of the most heroic characters
in the recent dune blockbuster
which happened post aquaman
right
in fact
likely he's curious he's not the lean
though
no
and doom no he's not the lead jeffrey
dune
did you ever read dune i know but i've
seen the movie yeah
do you understand whether his character
will come back from the dead in the
third movie
as again i didn't read the book so he
might i don't know we're just talking
about that one movie that might be a bit
of a spoiler
oh
man
dude
he's one of the principal leads in the
new fast and furious franchise movie
fast axe right
i i don't know that for sure now okay
um
but that's not the career path that
that miss heard has had she's never been
the title character in a movie she
hasn't spent
uh years on television she did what
eight tv shows eight
single episodes of tv
again i don't have her resume if you
want to show to me we can count them
together
um
mr mimo
remains
well liked even though he's engaged in a
recent divorce from
another actor
that's correct right
i don't know i don't follow his fan base
you don't follow jason momoa but you use
him as a comparable to to come up with a
45
i said i don't follow his fan base i i
understand him as a prominent actor in
the business but i don't follow his fan
base
isn't fanbase one of the things that you
analyze of course you can look at
numbers but i don't keep a watch on his
social media feeds all right
are you
indicated that uh
gal gadot is in wonder woman
yes she's a star she's in fact wonder
woman
you know she's good too yep all right
she's the title character and there's
been now multiple wonder woman movies
right
yes yeah and even before that she was in
franchise films
which one are you referring to fast and
furious oh excuse me i honestly don't
don't remember her being that as that
one of the main characters i know it's
the rock and yeah you didn't even know
she was in the fast and furious
franchise i've seen it on her resume but
i didn't i again i'm not a fan of the
past and furious
yo
agree with me that wonder woman is a
more prominent role than mira
if you're going to talk about apple's
apples in that exact movie yes
what about
does meera have any
you know self-titled franchise films
not yet no
and miss goodell played a much bigger
role in the movie they were in together
the justice league movie
in what movie they were in together oh
and justice league yeah
i haven't encountered the screen time so
i can't really say
okay
you indicated
that another person that you
uh compared miss heard with is uh
zendaya
same day yeah
person so famous she goes by one name
i guess when you have a name it's a z it
works i guess
yeah
she's
she's been on the disney channel since
she's 13 years old right right
she won an m
yes she did right
she
was singing and dancing and swimming
from trapezes in the greatest show right
yes yeah
she dubbed it in multiple spiderman
movies
yes she's ten years younger than your
client
right yeah
but this is a person that you deemed a
comparable
well as i i was explaining to you how i
chose them when you look at superhero
characters there's not that many to pull
from so i just tried i worked on pulling
characters that were in superhero movies
that were about the same age range
within
10 years as you've
noted to me thank you uh and also just
where her career would have gone i said
that they were comparable they're not
identical so you can just
look at what their career has done
either before that superhero movie then
in others or the one they were in and
then you look at where her career should
have gone
even though she may not have been at the
stature of zendaya at that time you can
still look at it as a comparable
trajectory of what happens when you're
in a blockbuster movie it's just a
reference point it's not meant to be
identical they're not meant to be the
same people are not even have the exact
same career it's meant to be a reference
point simple as that
so far everybody we've looked at
have been in more blockbuster movies
than miss her but miss heard was also in
the biggest blockbuster movie and the
light that shines on jason mamoe will
also shine on her so you have to look at
it in context of the biggest movie that
dude
and also one of the biggest
box office films ever probably within
the top 10 because i've looked at it
right so that light was going to shine
brighter on her
than someone who wasn't in that movie
and again it would have just helped her
in her career move forward not stalled
it and be
in her world be silent
afterwards
for the jury to accept your damage
analysis
they would have to agree with you that
misheard was on the precipice
of a meteoric rise that's the word you
used right actually no i didn't i did
use meteor with someone like let's say
gal gadot or zendaya but i i actually
gave you a range and gave the jury
arranged that they weren't all going to
have a meteorite price some of them
would be smaller right
and so i what the numbers that i gave
you do not represent a meteoric rise a
meteoric rise is when jason mamoa goes
from i don't know 4 million 5 million to
a 50 million dollar payday that's a
that's a meteoric shift in our business
but when someone has contracts that
actually go from one million to the
first one two million and then four
million
that is standard for a franchise that is
perceived to do well and so i based
those calculations on very specific
numbers that were already contracted i
wanted to stay within reality and look
at the numbers that were already
contracted for ms heard and just move
out forward on one film a year
maybe a tv show here or there and some
endorsement contracts which was very
typical
for an actor in our business to make
that kind of money it just is what
happens
so
the example you just used is somebody
went from one million to two million to
four million
your client has never had a contract
that exceeds two million dollars correct
incorrect right
and the aquaman just isn't it's actually
the justice league contract because
they're associated so justice league
aquaman she was paid 1 million
then in aquaman 2 it was written that
she was going to earn 2 million and if
there's another one it was written in
the terms that she would get 4 million
so it actually was a contract that
misheard signed with the studio right
but the movie hasn't been made
aquaman 2 hasn't come out yet so the
third one is still on deck as they say
yeah
um
okay
let's put it differently your client's
never been paid two million dollars for
a movie she she she appeared in
she was paid two million dollars proper
man two aquaman two and she's never been
paid four million dollars
she was contracted to be paid and when
the movie goes that's what she will be
paid so that's what i said she was just
considered
right but if if aquaman ii does even
nearly as well as aquaman one there's
going to most likely be a third one so
we can look at that as a precedent that
was set
in writ in writing actually
if a movie makes
795 million dollars you think there's
likely to be a next one
um
if it was the first or the second one
but if it's the fifth in the series i
assume that you're referring to pirates
five it performed well at the box office
yes but certainly not in comparison to
some of the other ones and that's what a
studio like disney will look at to say
has that franchise had its run
or do we need a studio like disney
wants to walk away from an 800 million
dollar payday
well an 800 million payday has to be put
into context to the budget that it cost
to get that movie and then the marketing
thereafter and with the increasing costs
and not only mr depp's fee or any of the
and plus the other actors fees plus
general production costs that are
getting more expensive then you put in
the marketing costs which are sometimes
one two or three times the budget of the
film a film like that a studio can spend
six eight hundred million just making
and marketing the film so it 795 million
dollars is a lot of money and it seems
like a really good box office but you
have to put into perspective of what's
spent on production marketing and the
overhead cost that the studio takes so
you have again it's all in context
of what the budget of the film and the
marketing of the film is all right let's
put some more things in context anna
armis
that's another one you used yes all
right
she's um
most recently i guess in deep water with
ben affleck
i i don't again i know some of the
movies that she's been and i don't
remember about deep water i don't
is that i don't even know if that's out
yet okay
um
she was in the last james bond movie yes
she was yeah they were talking about
making her the next
female bond right right after her big
star of moment star's born moment yeah
she's gotten a lot more um big roles
which is what we have from his heart
yeah um
and she said that her breakout role was
blade runner
it was it was like the first big you
know studio movie that got a lot of
attention i believe that was the one
that we can look at as a as a marker for
her sure
did you watch blade runner 2049
i did
do you know what she did in the movie
it was years ago i don't remember
exactly what she was at what what role
she played but she was in that movie and
from that her agents use that his
leverage to get her more movies
you have no knowledge that her principal
role in that movie was it's a gigantic
naked billboard
are you saying that's the only thing she
was she was a gigantic naked billboard
she wasn't that's the principal role in
that movie i i don't i don't remember
the movie well enough to know okay
um
and
did you know that she was we i talked a
little bit about ben affleck right right
uh
he's an interesting example because
it
he's been in a role
that's been recast
multiple times
you know that role we heard about batman
yeah yeah batman sure
all right
so
the title character in that dc series
has seen how many actors
several right
michael keaton
he was batman
val kilmer you're a movie buff yeah
yeah
christian bale was batman
i think he was you're right george
clooney was batman definitely yeah
i guess robert pattinson is now batman
don't know
okay
um
but you're taking an absolutely iconic
role
that the dc universe has recast
four five six times correct
correct so that just because you have
the role in the first movie or the
second movie doesn't mean it you get it
in the third movie or the fourth movie
unless it's contractual
right
unless it's contractual
so
now
let's look oh
anna armas
she's like the new marilyn monroe on
netflix too right
i believe so she was also in knives out
which is probably even a bigger breakout
role for her but again i chose blade
runner because it's a similar thing you
have to start somewhere but knives out
probably was her big moment in time
yeah
all right
the other person you picked was chris
pine
chris pine is in a superhero movie
wonder woman
he is in wonder woman he's also well
star trek being a blockbuster but not an
essay superhero right yeah um
he was in both wonder woman movies right
uh yes he plays the love interest to gel
goddamn yeah yeah um
on star trek in in the star trek
franchise
he plays captain kirk
right
i don't remember exactly role that he
played i didn't see it in the movie i
just know from his resume to be honest
do you know who captain kirk is
yes i do
well
but you didn't know that chris pine is
is captain kirk in star trek
i hate to say i'm not a star trek fan
okay
but you used mr pine as an example
irrespective of the fact you didn't even
know he starred
in this franchise film i didn't know
that he started that's why he used it
again
we can go over i we can go over this a
couple more times and i'm happy to do so
all i wanted to do was look at from a
small pool of people that have been in
huge franchise movies or or superhero
movies
and and give you a sense of what the
range is or what summon trajectory can
be again they're they they are not
apples and apples they're not both green
apples they're both red apples i just
was looking at a range it's what we do
it's what we do in the industry it's
it's what you do to kind of
get a sense of how much you're going to
pay an actor what they're worth in the
foreign markets and the domestic my
question was did you know whether he was
in star trek yes and you were asking me
why i chose him is which is what this
conversation is about and again i chose
him because he was part of star trek and
wonder woman but mostly because he was
in wonder woman
and i don't know the exact time frame of
which came first but the fact that he's
in both of them is consistent with what
actors of this ilk tend to do once
they're in a movie like this
but
you you talk about breakout roles but
you don't know which which was his
breakout role
chris pine's been an actor he's been a
well-liked actor he was in both star
trek and in
wonder woman and star trek
did a movie with denzel washington
he's had a good career yeah great career
yeah yeah much longer career than than
miss hurt right she was on the precipice
of a great career yeah she hasn't had
the chance to negotiate that for that
yet or be in those movies yet so we
don't know we're getting back to
precipice didn't you just deny precipice
a few minutes ago i said
i thought your testimony was she was on
the precipice of meteoric rise you said
i guess
i i didn't say meteoric i said
consistent i don't know she could have a
meteoric rise but i was talking about
consistent with miss heard
all right um
so because of the actors you selected
two of them are the title characters in
their dc movies
one one is aquaman who's the other title
character
gal gadot wonder woman right right she's
wonder woman and oh and you mean jason
memo sure yeah
yeah
so you get two title characters
you got james kirk
and those are the people that you
thought were most representative
of misheard
again
there are not that many in the pool to
pick from i'm not to put comparable
actors that haven't been in either large
what we call tentpole movies or
franchise movies or superhero movies so
i i wanted to work within those
parameters and that's what i did so
those are the actors i chose yes and to
show what type of work happens when
you're in a big movie and what happens
afterwards when you say comparable
um
every one of the actors you chose had a
much longer tv career than you than her
again they were all in superhero or or
franchise movies that did very very well
the box office and there are tons of
actors and actresses who are in
superhero movies that don't have meteor
meteoric rises thereafter correct not
when they're the lead character with
jason mamoa but to your point there are
many actors that have no career prior to
a breakout role and then have a meteoric
career and have had no career prior so
you don't always just look at the past
it's helpful and with miss heard she had
good reviews so that's what i looked at
but if you look at other actors and they
have their first role and all of a
sudden they become a superstar
from one role so that happens in our
business it just does
all right
with respect to your
comparable actors
you
have no personal knowledge
as to how much any of them were
compensated
over the period you reviewed incorrect
you have personal knowledge as to who
jason mamawa
and you derive that personal knowledge
from talking to somebody yes he didn't
tell you
his agent did okay
so
what you will rely on what mr momoa's
agent told you but you have no no you
didn't see the contract
no his agent is at william morris as
well so they told me that
right and you've never seen anybody
else's contracts as to what they were
making no but in 25 years of being in
this business i understand the basis of
which actors are paid when they're in
blockbuster films and then they're in
large budgeted studio films so
it's it's not a leap to kind of
understand where where the actor's
making and again
i really didn't want to try to be
speculative in my analysis i wanted to
work with the numbers that amber had
contracted for already and just take it
from there and said if she had done one
movie a year and one series and done
product endorsement that's how it got to
the number so i wasn't looking to take
her on a meteoric rise i wasn't looking
to give her the same career as jace
mamoa i took her numbers that her agents
had actually negotiated and worked from
there when you say you weren't
trying to give her the same career as
jason mama
the
the tv
program that she most recently did the
stand
she made 200 000 an episode that's what
you testify to correct
and in your damage analysis
you give her a million dollars an
episode had the waldman statements not
occurred and you do it only because you
believe mr mamoa has gotten that in in
in something that he's in right so you
are giving her the same career as jason
mama well again with someone like
uh
ms hurd who is in a blockbuster film
with the team at william morris in my
discussions with william morris that's
what they were looking to negotiate for
her on other projects so i got some of
that information from her management
team directly
so her agents were looking to get her as
much money as possible
i think that's the job of an agent they
usually try to get the most money as
possible your testimony is they were
looking to get the money for it but
you need somebody willing to pay on the
other side of that deal don't you
right but agents are working with people
in the industry and have a pulse on what
have a finger on a pulse of what's going
on so they know who's marketable and
what the prices that all the streamers
are paying these days
you haven't seen a single one of the
endorsement contracts that you
referenced other than miss hurts no
other than again what i was talking i
was talking to william morris in terms
of the pricing that they are aware of
not only for their own clients but
what's out in the marketplace and it's
pretty consistent and i've also worked
with other actors on other cases that
have gotten similar contracts so i'm
familiar with the rates of endorsement
contracts
you you haven't made any reference to
the actual earnings of any of these
actors
again as you do an analysis you put
together the numbers that you know from
both your experience and the marketplace
and the agents that are working in the
marketplace so together that's how i
created those numbers and mostly using
ms heard's numbers specifically and
giving her a very steady career which is
what she had had prior to
aquaman
yeah
and you don't have the prior earnings of
any of the actors you looked at other
than miss hurts
i don't have all the contracts now you
don't have any of that information i'm
sorry you don't have any of that
information no
okay
in fact that information
i guess aside from mr mamawa's
is confidential right
usually it is yes yeah
and the only reason you know anything
about mr momoa is that
um ms heard shares an agent
or anything right but i look i've also
been in the industry for many years and
i know what actors get paid i talk about
budgets constantly so it's not a
secret within the industry the amount
that actors are in those types of movies
are paid very very well
you're not currently working as an agent
for anyone are you
no
all right
so
the salaries of these comparable actors
did they form
some basis for your opinion
no
okay
so your opinion as i understand it is
that
ms heard
should have been able
to
renegotiate an existing contract
which is standard in the industry as
well as
with her
you know if it's standard with warner
brothers
i'm sorry do you know if it's standard
with warner brothers
i don't know if it's standard at any of
the studios but it is standard for
agents to renegotiate and oftentimes are
successful when the film is done so well
right but what you're talking about is
there's an existing contract
where miss heard has made
a promise that she will do the next
movie for in this instance two million
dollars right
right
and
what you the agent is trying to do is to
get warner brothers to say
hey
you should pay her more
than your contract says
because
you like her what
well as miss kosov
kovacevic said also it's standard in the
industry as again i've been in the
industry i've worked with agents and
i've worked with lots of lawyers and you
know we have conversations about what is
an actor getting or what can they do or
what are they going to do the next time
so again it's the standard of practice
in the industry especially when a film
is as successful as aquaman that the
agents will go back and renegotiate uh
in fact that was conversation standard
practices that they would try to
renegotiate but it's up to the studio
sure but oftentimes in a movie such as
the nature of aquaman if they're very
successful usually but the entirety of
your analysis
assumes a renegotiation
with a studio for terms that are double
what
the studio had already got a promise
from miss heard she would work for
correct
have you
talked
to walter hamada
have i spoken to him no do you know who
he is
yes
who is he he's a senior executive at
warner brothers or yeah i think he still
is there but certainly
at the time of the renegotiation was a
senior executive
do you know whether he's the president
of dc based film productions i think
that's exactly his title yeah yeah
who's in a better position
to determine whether warren warner
brothers would
renegotiate you or mr hamada as again i
based this on on the agents that were
talking to warner brothers about mr
momoa and they were wanting to talk to
them about misheard as well
so they i based my information on them
so you the the connection should be mr
hamada or the agents not mr mata and me
all right
who's in a better
uh position to to know whether warner
brothers would renegotiate objection
calls for speculation
just asking
i'll sustain the objection next question
do you review any testimony from mr
hamada
i did
did you understand that mr hamada says
that they don't
that they want to hold the lawyers i
mean hold the actors to their deals
that was a philosophy that he said
warner brothers had yes
did you understand that mr hamada said
that nothing mr depp did
impacted her compensation i don't
remember that part of the testimony do
you have it available for me to read
you don't know whether mr hamada
testified did anything mr dip mr depp
said about amber heard affect her
compensation
again i don't i don't remember i don't i
don't recall that just right now
do you know whether mr hamada indicated
whether he even knew who adam waldman
was
again i i don't remember the
conversation about hamada and waldman or
deb
and you don't remember whether mr hamada
made any statements as to whether
anything mr waldman said affected miss
hurt's compensation
in my experience studios don't talk
about what how or why they make
decisions based on publicity or
conversations they're not going to try
they're going to be very protective of
all the relationships so that's just
natural
yeah unless you can get them to testify
under oath at a deposition right
well even so they're not gonna say
anything negative they may bypass it by
being positive but they're not gonna
do anything that could potentially
damage a relationship that may change or
be worthwhile in the future so that's
just what a studio person does
it mr hamad is in the best position to
determine whether there were chemistry
issues with miss heard objection you're
on calls for speculation he's the
president of the company
overall
i don't know how involved mr hermoda was
on a daily basis in terms of chemistry
but i do know that warner brothers did a
chemistry test with uh
miss heard and mr mimo before they even
she even got the role she went in and
did what they call a chemistry test so
that was to actually see whether there
was good chemistry between them and
evidently there was good chemistry
because she was then hired to be the
romantic interest so
whatever mr hamada said during his
deposition i look at what actually
happened in real life which is she got
the chemistry test and then she got the
job
yeah let's look what happened in real
life
she went in before and took the test
then she made a movie
then it was an existing movie under
which
warner brothers they could then decide
whether there was chemistry right
the movie worked it made over a billion
dollars and they're all over the poster
if they didn't think that there was
chemistry they wouldn't have put miss
hurt on the poster
next to mr momoa so
you know there were multiple posters for
the aquaman movie yes there always are
that's that's that's standard and that
three out of the four posters the
standard posters for aquaman
didn't even feature misheard right so
when you when you make a poster at the
studio it's normal to have three or four
variations because you want to appeal
the different
people's perspectives so you want the
romantic poster you want the action
poster you want the superhero poster so
it's normal for them to have many
posters but the romantic poster was of
misheard and mr memoa right and everyone
and all the others are just of mr momoa
like we talked about it's aquaman but
she was prominent in the ones that she
that warner brothers wanted to appeal to
women and to the romantic is host of the
consumer
what
movies
would ms heard have gotten
absent mr waldman's statements
well the ones we know about specifically
that she was in conversations with was a
movie with um
gail garcelle bernal i believe that's
how you say his name at uh amazon which
is what miss kavachu said and she was
also in consideration for a movie called
ambulance
with michael bay um but again
after the waldman statements nobody
would talk to the agents and so they
weren't able to garner more oh she also
had a movie that she was interested in
producing that a good friend of hers
or a friend of hers or colleague was was
doing so um there was at least those
three
um
those were three movies that she was
being considered for but you don't know
what movie she would
she was going to be in
well again they stopped the conversation
after the statement so we don't know
where they would have gone of course but
they were she was in consideration for
all of them and given her favorite man
she would have con that would have
helped all those movies so it would have
made a lot of sense you're projecting
movies way out into the future that you
have no knowledge would ever have gotten
made well that's what we do when you
talk about comparables and and economic
damages you talk about the future that's
standard in our industry as as a
forensic expert and in the industry
how movies are finances a matter of fact
is by forecasting what happens in the
future
what
connection do you draw
between
mr waldman's statements
and
the
reported reduction in ms heard's aquaman
ii role
again it's just it's a it's the timing
of it all was the timing and also they
were going to take her out of the movie
after the statements and then they put
her back in and then
there i i
can i talk about the emails that i read
i'm not sure at this point but
so
when you say they're going to take her
out of the movie
when you have an option
you literally have the option whether to
include
the actress right that's that's what it
means
correct
so
they can choose to exercise the option
or not exercise the option entirely up
to them
correct and they have
that particular studio
to your knowledge has re repeatedly
recast even major
figures
in their dc movies
we talked about batman what about
superman
you know i'm not i i think i'm more
familiar with the batman actors i think
that have been a couple actors of
superman but depending on how the movie
performed if a movie doesn't perform
they'll look for other actors or if they
want to go a different direction or
reboot a franchise they will look at
different actors so
they'll be successful they're not likely
to change the actors especially not in
the second one or the third one another
reason they'll look for a different
actor or actress
if the actor actresses
are asking too much money to play the
role again correct
uh yes not not in figures under 10
million dollars but yes
if you're asking for too much money
you might not get your role again
and
your analysis assumes
that ms heard could double her money
well her contracts doubled her money
from each one to the next so it wasn't
that large a leap to do that especially
when the agents had told me that that
was what had been they were considering
and what they'd been discussing
yeah
you seen the script of aquaman 2
personally
yeah
uh i did see a draft i don't know what
the date was or when it was or where in
the succession of the rewrites it was i
did see one draft yes you don't know
what
warner brothers has in mind for that
movie in terms of the kind of movie it's
going to be
it's a superhero movie right um it's
supposed to be like a buddy comedy right
i i don't know i don't know about a
buddy comedy it's an action movie
superhero movie who's patrick wilson
patrick wilson
i i've heard that name in terms of an
actor but i don't know mr wilson
do you know if he appears
in aquaman
again i don't i don't know him by name
if you want to show me a picture i can a
clip from the movie all right
do you know if mr wilson appears
more frequently in aquaman than
than your client does
i don't i didn't count the screen time
when i watched the movie it was a long
you know even when i watched it again i
didn't count the screen time of anybody
else
you did you read the testimony of mr
hamada we discussed that yes
you disregarded all of it in your
analysis as to
her ability to renegotiate correct
well i remember the part where mr hamada
said that from time to time they will
break their philosophy and renegotiate
it's what they did with jason mamoa and
with gal gadot so
you know
it's it that just goes it coincides with
what we know in the industry which is it
can be done it's what they did with the
two title characters
in
the dc universe
again i've worked in the business for a
long time and i've seen a lot of actors
uh renegotiate their careers it's i'm
sorry not their careers renegotiate
their uh
their fees it's it's common practice
and it's certainly what the agent will
think about first when a movie makes a
billion plus dollars right again
focused on the agent but it's the studio
that
pays the bills yes right
all right
the honor i have a fair amount more to
do is to continue i'm sorry continue
okay i didn't know if we're going to 5
30 today or not
every day is 5 30 today
okay
we may not even need to get there every
day is 5 30. perfect
all right
you talked about ms herb's endorsement
deal with l'oreal
yes
and that
l'oreal has concerns about using her
because every time they try to use her
people respond negatively to her
people don't the the debt fan base has
responded
have posted negative things about ms
heard
on their campaigns
so
did you say the depth fan base
well people that were using the hashtags
that were consistent with the rest of
the the depth fan base yeah but
there are people posting negative things
that other than things that came from mr
waldman correct
i haven't seen all the i haven't seen
all them that was i was just looking at
what l'oreal what l'oreal discussed and
what l'oreal said in in
their communications
all right
they made
do you see l'oreal make a word cloud of
the words that were most uh commonly
associated with with misheard in its
uh marketing campaigns i knew they did
that i didn't see it myself actually
do you know what words there were
again no okay
you didn't talk much about this but in
order to get to the damage analysis that
you got
the 45 million dollars
i think at least in
initially you suggested that ms heard
would have a role
producing and starring in a movie
and that she would make 12 million
dollars
i i've talked about that but in the in
the latest calculation i'd that was
really less what i considered and more
about what films and tv and endorsement
deals that which she would do the
producing was something that she had
wanted to do and again mr mamoa got that
so that's where the agents were
discussing those figures with me
the last movie that she has a production
credit for is in 2013 right
again i don't i haven't memorized
terrorism
there's a movie called syrup
do you ever hear of it
no
aside from having probably seen it on
her imdb and soon the darkness that's
her other production credit right
i'll
if you say so if you're reading it off
of her resume i will believe you yes
2010
okay
12 years ago
but you at least at some portion of the
at some point in this uh analysis
were of the mind that
she would
recover 12 million dollars
with a producing
role and a starring role in a movie
because that's what mr momoa got again
the agents were just saying that those
were the kinds of numbers they were
looking at to help her as she moved
forward in her producing career
those are the kind of the numbers the
agents would like her to get right but
again i didn't use that in the final
analysis of my 45 million so
it was just a discussion point because
that's what the agents wanted me to
consider
all right
you
have testified that the breakout rule
for miss heard
was aquaman right
i i didn't say the breakout role but i
used it as this you know a movie that it
was a superhero kind of super
box office success um i think that you
know some of her other critically
acclaimed movies probably helped her
break into that role which would have
been the danish girl and then her work
in justice league which was a natural
progression to getting to star in
aquaman
all right
but
i used breakout perhaps you didn't but
this is the movie that springboards her
to the kind of money that you are
suggesting she should earn
it should have yes
and
either i mean
other than aquaman
which was released in 2018
how many
movies has she booked
well she booked
aquaman 2
and she did the stand which was a
significant television show
right
but
outside of the aquaman franchise she
obtained only one role
movie role
since
2018 right
right the industry also knows that she's
planned to be on that next move and they
understand her production schedule so
she's not going to go after films that
would conflict with a mega box office
movie so there's scheduling and conflict
issues as well that her she and her team
would consider
so from
when was aquaman released in 2018
it's december i it was either december
2018 and and then it depends on where it
was in the world it was started in
december 2018 and then it it moved out
you know into 2018.
how many months between december 2018
and the waldman statements went by
12
15 or 16 if my mouth is correct
she got one roll during that
that 15 or 16 month period
during the entirety of the post aquaman
boost right
she got stand
and then she was in discussions for the
films as they were getting ready to go
but she didn't get another role
for 16 months
between the release of aquaman
and
what you say are the waldman statements
well she got the stand right she got one
tv role
a pretty significant tv role yes for a
stephen king novel right
she was in a movie though
she was in a movie that was released
after aquaman
what movie are you referring to gully
well i don't know when that was shot so
you'd have to tell me when it was shot
movies get released at different time
frames like they can be shot in 2016 and
not get released till 2018. so you'd
have to tell me we'd have to look at you
know the actual filming dates of of the
goalie didn't to for me to talk to you
about that she wasn't initially casting
gully was she
i i'm not familiar with the casting
process of gully
um
do you know who else eve is
who alice eve
alice eve
sounds familiar but i'm not i'm not
recalling who she she is she's an
actress been in
any number of movies you don't know who
she is
again i know her name but i don't know
her resume she's in star trek
great right
um
she was in one of those breakout roles
star trek
but you don't you don't even know who
she is
i i talked to you about star trek before
i'm not a big star trucking
okay
ms heard replaced alice eve in the movie
gully right
i don't know the passing process i don't
know who's starting that movie you know
what she was paid
who ms hurt
uh for gully yeah can you tell me when
that was in no no i don't but what was
the filming date of and what was the
start date of gully
do you you didn't look at the gully
contract when you were making analysis
of
ms hurt's damages
i don't recall whether i looked at it or
not
did you understand that she was making
and ninety 2190 per week for gully
can you tell me when it was shot
when does that contract get negotiated
it's relevant
the contract is negotiated prior to the
release of aquaman
okay
so she signs this contract
for 21.90
is there a
do you know what
the screen actors guild low budget
agreement minimum scale is
it changes from year to year it depends
on what year and what the size of the
budget there's actually three or four
different scale
num uh you know benchmarks so when
there's a low budget it can be a micro
budget it can be a minimum budget low
budget it there's there's like four or
five different scales that they use when
it gets to anything other than a studio
film
and oftentimes actors do passion
projects and that has nothing to do with
or something that they really love to do
or they think that would be good for the
career does anything to do with the the
fee made on the on the film
all right
what's a loan out
a loan out a loan out is the corporation
that a an actor will use so that their
money comes in through a corporation
and then that corporation technically
loans out the actor services
uh to the production so they the low net
is the corporation that the actor uses
and then they loan out the services to
the you know production company it's
just a really for tax purposes
do you know of any movie
that ms heard
booked
immediately prior
to
aquaman
other than gully
well i know she did justice league
i i don't remember the dates and times
of the filming of the other ones
you always have to look at the filming
dates
um
you talked about mr schnell
gully was in his
chart right
i don't i don't remember where goalie
was right
did you look closely at his chart
did you look closely at his chart
at mr schnell's chart yeah
um
i looked at the numbers with respect to
the social media campaigns is what i was
looking at mr schnell for
okay
um
do you know whether any of the dates of
the waldman statements even appear in mr
schnell's chart
i don't remember okay
you talked a little bit about
q scores
and mr bonya do you remember that
yes
for miss heard mr banya use q scores
from immediately after awkward right
again if you want to show me something i
can i can answer i don't remember every
word of mr barnes but i remember talking
about the dates with you earlier all
right but do you you don't know as you
sit here today whether the q scores that
mr banya used
were but were after aquaman but before
the waldman statements he used a couple
different scores based on dates he
didn't i don't remember if they were uh
correlated to the statements or not i
remember
years more than anything else again i
looked at thousands and thousands of
pages of documents so i don't remember
exactly what has said even before the
waldman statements ms heard had very
high negative q scores isn't that
correct
very negative high q scores no very high
negative cues as i said very high
negative case scores
um
we i remember discussions of a lot of q
scores i i don't remember exactly what
what or when which score or whether it
was
so in your analysis you didn't consider
ms heard's
negative q scores
as
a restraint on what she might earn on a
going forward basis
no q scores change all the time mr
excuse misuse miss heard's imdb score
has been one
and it's been 300 mr depp's q score has
been won and it's been 253
you know q scores change all the time
scores change all the time they're based
on current events and and movie releases
you talked a little bit about
mr depp's damages
um
did you talk who's jerry brockheimer
who's jerry bruckheimer the producer of
the pirates franchise well he's a huge
producer of a lot of movies but he
happens to be the producer of the
pirates franchise you didn't talk to him
prior to your testimony
personally no no and you didn't
you didn't have other people talk to him
on your behalf did you
i i
me personally no i did not talk to mr
buckhamer and you've never spoken with
mr bruckheimer about why mr depp has not
appeared in a six pirate movie
there has been no sixth pirate movie
there is not a pirates movie titled
pirate six yet
wherever but you haven't talked to mr
bruckheimer as to whether mr
depp was going to appear in the movie
mr from things that i've read in uh
newspaper publications and emails i read
that mr brookheimer was uncertain
whether mr depp was star in
right but you haven't talked
and you've never spoken with sean bailey
about this right
no
or anyone at disney
i actually spoke i actually put a call
into something disney and they didn't
want to talk in the record all right
you called somebody at disney and they
didn't want they didn't want to talk to
you
no again as i said studios don't want to
talk about their stars whether they want
to preserve a relationship that may or
may not be used in the future so it's
it's their tendency not to talk
about people they are in business with
so you have no personal knowledge why mr
depp
hasn't made a six pirate movie
well as i said there is no six pirate
movie right you but you don't know why
you have no personal knowledge why
i don't work at disney now okay
did you listen to mr wigman wiggum's
testimony in this trial
i read mr wickham's testimony
and mr williams said mr depp had a deal
for the movie right
i i i think mr wiggum did the other
agent mr carino said he did not and as
there is no uh as there is no pirates
movie there have been no deals
negotiated and that's what miss jacobs
also testified to
but mr wiggum testified to something
else
it's it doesn't it doesn't uh
correlate as we say to the other two
agents testimony
you've indicated that a portion of the
reason
that
mr depp
has get has received negative
has received a variety
of negative uh comments in hollywood
is that
he
engages in lawsuits
one of the one of the uh
elements that has contributed to
a lot of negative
press and attention is due to the
lawsuits and the activity and the
behaviors that we talked about earlier
have been brought into the limelight
mr depp's lawsuit here
has generated negative publicity
for ms hurt correct
yes
that lawsuit
until she's filed a counter claim
didn't relate to the wallman statements
did it
mr depp's lawsuits yeah
no
we talked about that it was pertaining
to the uh her op-ed piece
it related to what
ms heard said
i'm sorry
this
mr depp's lawsuit relates to what ms
heard said and and not to what mr
waldman said
that would well it related to the op-ed
piece that ms heard wrote
right
so mr waldman's statements
have no connection
to the negative
publicity
that ms heard
has
received relative to this trial correct
objection calls for speculation
foundation here say and outside the
scope
any response
we're looking for a causal connection
here sustain objection next question
when was the last time
you met with miss her
i only met miss hurt at lunch today
okay that's the first time you talked to
her first time i met her okay
um
what's your compensation for testifying
here today
uh for for a testimony at 650 an hour
what what has been your compensation to
date for providing
the assistance that you have in this
case
i've been working on the case for about
three years
and
over the three years
i believe it's around sixty thousand
dollars
you said sixty yeah over three years all
right
i have no further questions all right
redirect
i think your honor and i'm gonna make it
definitely fit within that 5 30. okay um
ms arnold you were asked a number of
questions about
the different social media the negative
and how do you know that it relates to
the waldman deb statements do you recall
all those questions yes okay
the
the social media that was connected and
some of that was your testimony some
jessica kova vachovich and some of it
was mr schnell actually tracked the
language from the three statements from
waldman correct objection leading
sustained okay
what if any
uh
efforts were made to track the negative
social media
that caused the damages that you've
attributed objection leading
overall
so l'oreal did a lot of research
william morris did a lot of research mr
schnell did a lot of research and in
those conversations those were also
connective tissues to the
negative social media campaign and the
waldman statements all right and they
connected back to those three statements
yes objection leading
and what if any connection did they have
to those three statements
again they we talked about this earlier
we talked about some of the hashtags
being similar we talked about the wald
or waldman or the waldminion so there
were a lot of connective tissues between
the
negative social committee the social
media campaigns
and the weldment statements
okay and i'm going to jump because i
think this is part of this so you were
asked some questions about mr hamada do
you recall that
yes and asked whether he testified that
um
whether anything mr depp said or
anything mr waldman's head had anything
to do with
their initial decision not to exercise
the option to aquaman two do you recall
that testimony for that question those
questions the question yes okay now
the testimony from mr schnell
tracked the 1.2 million um
tracers to january 2021 correct
objection leading
do you remember what month that was
until right so when mr schnell did his
analysis it was from april of 2020 to
january 2021 and when did warner
brothers tell amber herd and her agents
they were not exercising her aquaman 2
contract it was in february 2021 all
right and what if anything did mr hamada
say about whether the reason they did
that was because of the 1.2 million uh
negative social media tweets and
instagrams and and other communications
objection no foundation had any impact
sustained right next question
are you aware of whether he said
anything about that
i recall the warner brothers objection
hearsay
do you know whether that had any impact
objection hearsay
i'm asking now she's allowed to rely on
hearsay
sustain the objection next question
all right you were asked a whole lot of
questions about the different
comparables um and so i'm just going to
go to this again
of all the different movies of all of
those comparables
which movie was the highest grossing of
all of them
again i believe is aquaman i mean
everybody talks about aquaman being
one of the highest if not the highest
grossing films certainly the highest dc
comic film or in that superhero world
but again i don't want to say it was the
highest but i think it was very close to
it
do you know whether walter hamada admits
it was the highest grossing uh dc film
yes he said that yes okay so
when you're looking at all the
comparables what if any relevance is
there to
the degree of success of that dc
superhero movie
objection foundation
she can speak to that your honor that's
the foundation
do you know
the answer to that question do you know
and can you repeat the question i forgot
it no i have to
okay so let's go backwards um
so
what if do you know whether it makes a
difference
whether how successful that dc superhero
movie is in
what types of films they'll be able to
get in the future
objection foundation
i'm asking the foundation
if you want to ask the foundation go
ahead i'm sorry that's what i thought i
was asking do you know whether that
plays any role the degree of success
customarily objection foundation ask her
how she knows how do you know
in 20 25 years of being in the film
industry it's customary for when a movie
does such an extraordinary amount at the
box office it shines a very bright light
on the actors especially if they're in
lead roles and it's customary that they
will get a customer it is
uh
i don't use the word standard but it it
it is very frequent that a star in a
movie that has performed so well at the
box office and with a
role model character that mira was that
she would have gotten
uh
other roles and worked quite a bit
afterwards and that movie would have
helped her career i mean that's that's
no question okay and with all these
comparables uh when you
gave the range to this jury of 45 to 50
million in estimating this over this
period of time did you put amber heard's
estimated damages ranges above all those
other comparables
no again i was very specific in using
the actual
negotiated rates that mr hurt's agents
were able to get for her in that
contract and use that as a precedent so
again i always wanted to be grounded
in what ms heard actually
was in contract for and what her agents
negotiated and i used that as the
baseline for the financial numbers of
her loss i used the comparable actors to
show how consistently they all worked
and how their careers moved forward
after being in a box office okay
um
you asked about disney and the pirate
six again
what if any knowledge do you have of
whether disney is willing to pay mr deb
300 million dollars and a million
alpacas objection no foundation
i i'm asking her what if anything does
she know about whether disney is if you
can lay a foundation okay
did you did you listen to or did you
read the disney testimony
in this case i did yes all right
what do you recall disney saying about
whether they were willing to pay mr depp
300 million dollars and give him a
million alpacas they would not be
willing to pay 300 million dollars and
give him alpacas thank you
you were asked about
the
defecation uh what if any recollection
recollection of knowledge do you have
about whether that social media negative
campaign that you've testified had the
words defecation in it or poop
objection no foundation
i know that the word poop and the
hashtag poop is used okay was that move
destroyed
sustain the objection move to strike
next question okay um
in your review of the social media
campaigns and the negative social media
campaigns that you testified to with
this jury that include the l'oreal that
include the wme that include mr schnell
and we include what you've done
what if any recollection do you have of
how many of those that are influencing
your connections to the defamation
statements include the words poop or
defecation
objection compound
overrule
i don't believe poop was one of the
hashtags that was connected to the
statement okay thank you
you were asked about the time period
between the
defamatory state
between the release of aquaman two
uh in december 2018
aquaman one thank you and the defamatory
start statements that were in april 2020
and june 2020. do you recall that
testimony
i remember that questioning yes okay um
during that time
were you aware of whether aquaman two
was in discussions with amber heard
about scheduling the filming of aquaman
two
in the period between the statements and
before i'm going before okay i'm talking
about the period of time when they
released aquaman one okay and the april
eight first of the defamatory statements
right do you know whether aquaman
whether warner brothers was in
discussions already with amber heard
about scheduling her for aquaman two
objection hearsay do you know i'm asking
her whether you know if
i'll sustain as to hear say okay
do you have knowledge of whether aquaman
was in discussions with amber during
that period objection hearsay
i don't know how to i i i'm asking
foundation right right um
um how would you know
uh
well amber received an early draft of
the script amber's agents were in
discussion objection hearsay i think she
can say sustained okay um
what is in your experience based on
getting scripts what does that mean
i'm asking for experience
in my experience with the movie as high
profile as something like aquaman they
keep the scripts very tight you know
they don't let anybody read them they're
numbered they have your name on it so if
you're getting a script for a movie such
as aquaman that's kept tightly tightly
close to the vest if you will by the
studio you are going to
they can they want you to be in the
movie otherwise they would never give
you the script okay
and so if a script was given to amber
heard before in the first april 8 2020
defamatory statement
what would that suggest based on your
based on your knowledge that you've just
testified to objection speculation it's
not speculation
again if she got the script they were
going to use her in the movie that was
their plan
okay
i have no further questions thank you
all right thank you is this witness
subject to recall
uh yes your honor all right so you're
still an expert so you can have a seat
okay
i'm still thinking okay
thank you thank you
all right ladies and gentlemen let's
come to the end of our day all right so
please do not do any outside research
tonight and uh don't talk with anybody
about the case okay and we'll see in the
morning
bright and early at nine o'clock right
okay thank you
all right
just a few planning notes okay um
after testimony tomorrow and we've
excused the jury we'll go ahead and have
the properties that you requested mr
rottenborn we'll do this tomorrow doctor
is that okay does that sound good all
right we'll do those uh
after like right now tomorrow okay that
should give you
with all the profits that you need to do
for the record okay
all right and then whenever all the
testimony is done possibly at this point
it'd be thursday afternoon after the
jury is excused uh we'll go over the
remaining jury instructions i have three
under advisement we'll take up those and
we'll also if there's any other from the
evidence this week that we need to
talk about we can discuss those as well
after the jury's gone on thursday
evening or if earlier if the evidence is
done before then okay and just as times
up to this minute
uh the plaintiff is used 45 hours and 24
minutes
the defendant has used
57 hours in six minutes which means the
plaintiff has left 15 hours and five and
51 minutes and the defendant has four
hours and nine minutes left okay so
that's where we're at
all right anything else for this evening
your honor the last witness that appears
that
is on the plains witness list it's mr
depp and i was just hoping we would get
an answer
yeah defendant's witness list i don't
know
changing
witness i mean i'm not sure
okay
make a decision in the morning okay
all right everybody have a good evening
all right thank you
you